[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to round 10 here at
the tata steel chess tournament my name
is fiona anthony and i'm joined once
again bye grandmaster daniel neroditsky
dania how are you today
fiona good afternoon i'm doing great
round 10 is upon us this tournament is
flying by but we have so much intrigue
left i can't wait to
jump into today's round uh very
fascinating matchups once again
absolutely we'll get to that in a second
for now let's have a look at the results
from yesterday it was a very decisive
day with
four
decisive games anish giri winning a nice
game against sam shankland
nils grandelius against fabiano that was
such a
an incredibly tight affair in the the
time scramble but fabiano uh winnie
getting a big win with the ballack
pieces
the longest game of the round sergey
karjakin beat pragnanda and
magnus carlsen and what a crushing win
against mahmud yaroff
yeah the greats make it look easy uh and
it's not just a cliche magnus really did
make it look easy yesterday less than 30
moves as he solidifies
his lead he sits atop the standings with
six and a half out of nine he is alone
uh but he is closely pursued by anish
geary who's got six points he's riding a
four-game winning streak uh counting the
dubai game of course but he's played
some really nice games other than that
one as well fiona so he's gonna be
looking to keep that streak going if he
wins this one and this his streak will
get up to five games that'll be pretty
crazy he's facing off against jkd with
the white pieces so we've got a lot of
players who are bound to be taking a lot
of risk as we look at the pairings today
for sure
there he will be looking to rebound he's
still only a full well he's a full point
behind magnus as is visited uh
interestingly enough with the indian
clash today is taking place on republic
day
in india so congratulations to all our
indian viewers that will be a very
interesting
match up the two youngsters yes panko
jordan
another interesting clash and anish
geary of course with the white pieces
that pairing you mentioned he will be
looking to make it five in a row
yeah he will be and duda has not been in
the greatest form this tournament he's
been
making certain uncharacteristic mistakes
uh that is not to say he is easy to beat
uh so we will keep a very close eye on
that one and of course carjacking
against carlson sergey
is an incredibly tough nut to crack
particularly with the black pieces it's
a rematch of their world championship
match i always love karjakin carlson
games yeah plenty of exciting matchups
to look forward to and dania our viewers
at home they too can get involved in the
action
yes they can don't forget to vote on the
results of today's games go to go go to
chess.com events navigate to the
tournament select a game click vote and
select your winner you could win a piece
of the one thousand dollar prize pool
for best voters or free diamond
memberships voting ends after the 10th
move of each game so don't miss out and
remember to vote on all the games find
that at chess.com
events
absolutely go there do it now we are
gonna go on a very a quick break before
we return here as the player players
arrive for round 10 so don't go anywhere
we'll see you very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 10 here
at the tata steel chess tournament four
minutes to go until the round starts and
dania will see the first players are
starting to arrive
i think that's mr asipenko taking a seat
he's always is there such a thing as
fashionably early i think three minutes
early is
you know the perfect sweet spot for
arriving at the game although i know
some people who come 20 minutes early
that's
slight overkill especially at a close
tournament like this
yeah we see nils he's also usually quite
early
and
he's
there getting ready for the game against
daniel dubos niels not having the best
tournament but danine also is still yet
to get a win so he will be looking for
that with the white pieces
today there is the look into the playing
hall so those two players are really the
only two that had arrived we see anish
as well walking around
with his good friend and one of his main
seconds not in this event because he's
playing in the challengers it's a irvin
lamy
this is the most chess player walk ever
there's something just uniquely
chess player-y about the way people are
walking in this playing hall and i can't
quite put my finger on it i think
partially it's walking with your hands
behind your back i mean i do that i do
that before the round specifically i
think everybody does that it's there's a
certain anticipation in the air
and of course the walk of the gm and his
second that that is just a very iconic
you know walking back and forth and
you know discussing
uh
the last uh important opening details
yeah this is
classic right here
i'm loving this
you know bishop g2 and remember to play
you know
even though he doesn't have a russian
accent
i see in the chat that tran is is
calling it the museum walk i like that
comparison
that's exactly what it is
um but it's totally and you know that's
what uh lamia's saying um but yeah he's
got a dutch accent obviously not not a
russian
and we see on the right as we see a
handshake between
is that sam
i think the two players that's
definitely sam
the two players arrived we see on the
right hand side inside our one of our
tournament photographers uh leonard otis
you can find his and yurian who's the
other photographer you can find their
pictures on our social media on facebook
also on the tournament website at
steeljas.com
and
nils he's having yesterday was a rough
game but he seems in high spirits again
and uh you can only comment that
yeah i mean he
you know knowing him he's very hard to
shake and
that's what i love about people like
neil i mean he's really easy to root for
even though he's having a rough term and
same with prague by the way he's you
know he doesn't doesn't show it on his
face
we see there that vidic just arrived for
the olympian clash here once again a
funny coincidence that this game would
fall on republic day again
congratulations to our indian viewers
who i'm sure will be very much looking
forward to this matchup
between two of india's finest players
i'm a big fan of both of them um you
know vidit i've known for a longer time
and he's obviously the favorite in this
game he's got the white pieces in prague
he's demonstrated terrific opening
preparation he's really had very few
problems in the opening but uh in many
of his games including yesterday toward
the middle game you know that early
middle game
uh and and toward the late middle game
yesterday against sergey is where he has
really struggled so we'll see if he can
put together a fully smooth game
and richard reports uh just arriving for
his game on the black side against
fabiano carrana and we just see the
clocks
being started
and fabiano what's he gonna open with
interestingly enough look at this the
armature is starting the clock in
karjakin
against uh magnus carlson where none of
the players have arrived yet but it
looks like there's some trouble with the
clock
yeah our router has to there we go
there we go and of course i didn't know
sergey like to be fashionable it's so
funny that magnus says he's so
consistent in his arrival time it's it's
always late but it's late by the same
amount it's late by 40 seconds
and then who knows it could be that
the lateness is prompted by the opponent
who knows what sergey has arrived
and one e4 is on the board
will wait for magnus as you called it i
think 40 seconds is quite
right on the money the
photographers are getting ready but no
sign of magnus yet as we see the the big
uh the playing hall overview camera
looks like he's gonna forfeit his game
you know i think i think e4 is too much
for him i mean d4 beat daniel dubois and
now e4 defeats magnus carlsen
wasn't it yes exactly exactly exactly
yeah magnus today uh
a minute late but there he is
and i think we'll see a proper handshake
here between the two
players what is your money on what is
magnus first move going to be
i thought he might play the sveshnikov
um he's been going back to some of the
openings that he was playing really at
the start of his professional chess
career
um it really depends on on what his
approach is i mean magnus really plays
everything he can play e5 or c5
uh i don't think that he's going to be
going out of his way to burn bridges uh
sergey is not someone that you want to
do that against magnus is fine with the
draw i mean he's in clear first he's
totally fine with the draw but he's
going to play the position and i think a
lot really depends on
sergey the way that sergey handles the
opening and and how what sergey's
mentality is going to be and we'll see
that you know after the first 10 moves
first let's see what magnus plays to be
honest i'm expecting a quiet
game here i don't expect too many
fireworks but i hope i hope that i'm
wrong of course
yeah yeah i mean
sergey okay so that he was adjusting his
pieces i thought he was about to play c5
the anticipation is unbearable let's see
i see a question
uh in the chat as to what are the
players writing and e5 is on word what
are the players writing on those papers
so those are the the score sheets so
what the players are writing is um the
player names the date probably depends
every scoresheet is a little bit
different but mostly the player names
maybe the event at the date um and later
on the moves
i just have a request for sergey no
italian please i prefer lopez
he has heard you pleaser i love is he he
listened
uh very polite and but now magnus's turn
to abide by my request no berlin
no
and magnus hasn't listened i see i think
i can choose my favorites now
and uh karjakin doesn't look
too impressed either
yeah no nobody i don't think anybody in
the history of the berlin has ever been
happy to see it on the board now the
question of course the big question and
what does the berlin signify that berlin
signifies that magnus is fine with the
draw because
as i'm pretty sure everybody knows by
now white does have a forced draw uh in
the berlin and white has several very
quiet lines where white essentially is
not risking
um and really the ball is in sergey's
court what is he going to go for is he
going to go for the anti berlin with d3
is he going to go for the mainline end
game with uh castles short knight takes
c4 and d4
uh as we yeah it it really depends on
how he's feeling
we'll find out very shortly but then
yeah we had the bird's eye view up for a
second and i already noticed as where
things are not as quiet
and let's bring the birds eye view back
the first game that my eye went to
uh somewhat unsurprisingly is shankland
remedyarov i have no idea how the hell
we got there or what's uh going on
and for the rest well we'll get back to
it maybe we can start there
sure
um sam has the white pieces he
obviously always plays for a win with
white d4 c4 this starts as a catalan
following in magnus's footsteps and
chakra with two
uh black games in a row
and here's the funny thing fiona he
actually repeats the same line he played
against magnus yesterday so he decided
that the problem wasn't in his choice of
variation uh that's admirable that's not
easy to do when you lose a game uh and
then you have the same color in your
next game to play the same line takes a
lot of
uh firmness and resolve and belief in
your in your
openings but sam he goes a3
i think magnus castled here um so
it seems like sam the first to diverge
from yesterday's game
b5
b3 this is classic stuff undermining the
c pawn and after c3 the knight returns
to b1 in order to attack the c3 pawn and
here it's very important that black is
not in time to play before otherwise
white could resign uh but after a takes
before the rook on a8 will hang
therefore chakri are taking the chance
to develop his bishop and giving back
the c3 pawn which uh fiona i'm
pretty sure that sam is going to capture
and he just did
so sam just
captured
and now well my first question to you
daniel the pawn on b5 uh is attacked
what how do we deal with that do we
protect upon do
e4 i think yeah push the pawn and that's
what she goes for
and my guess is that sam is going to go
knight a4 aiming for c5 and we might see
something like knight a4 and
knight bd7 i mean this is clearly the
the proper square for black's knight now
visually
it seems like white's position is
rather pleasant
uh if you look at these kind of you know
not full-fledged weaknesses but
uh slight holes on the queen side where
i could later go queen d2 and attack
before
uh i think sam enjoys these kinds of
positions where he's playing for a small
advantage and i'm sure that he's
analyzed this as well so let's see where
he puts the knight and whether he takes
on b4 first that's another decision that
he has to make
here yeah and uh sorry daniel i was just
distracted by the line between us my ocd
was being triggered i was just gonna
shoot a message
wait what was wrong with it
well
are you kidding me you see us yeah oh oh
my god now i see it all over the place i
cannot see it i was looking at the left
side of this oh my goodness
oh you have to get that away from me oh
my goodness i cannot take that
and i
i think neither can anybody in the chat
i think that there's a universal ocd
component to that in particular
i was literally the last sentence you
said once i saw the line i was like oh
my god i need to and my brain just short
circuited
and i didn't oh my goodness yeah no i
cannot see that
okay
i don't know if i can continue
commenting honestly i'm traumatized
so
hello
yeah no all right all right fine fine
i'll keep going okay let's um
let's move on
perform here as sam fondues his decision
let's bring back the bird's eye view
absolutely
and we see a couple of interesting
openings fiona i mean
really i see already three as we see
sergey castling by the way so he's
likely to go either rookie one or d4
um and we will keep an eye on that
caruana report have an old-school
uh english line that i haven't seen
in top level play for a long time uh
let's maybe have a brief look at that
one
before we go there i just looked at the
chat and while everyone was having a
great time with the the camera line
uh advil was saying does anyone remember
tata still last year when dania asked
fiona if an animal was a dog and it had
a horn i remember that like it was
yesterday
that was hilarious but what animal was
it
um some kind of
cat not a cow but some kind of hairy
yeah hairy cow
right
i mean definitely not a dog any time
not people confuse it all people confuse
it all the time
um so okay uh caruana report um
see i'm supposed to be serious
um i don't know if i'm capable of that
this is called the mckenna's system
now why can play d4 here and transpose
into a nimzoni but why plays e4
and now uh the main move is d5 and we
actually have another game in this round
which is featuring
this line e5 d4
uh this is more common in in recent
times but report playing an old school
move c5
that allows white to play e5 and the
knight drops back to ga now it may seem
like black is undeveloping why is he
doing that well
if you look at it the pawn and e5 is now
weakness the d4 square
is also a hole and black is going to
play knight c6 on the next move so what
white often does
uh there is a pawn sacrifice variation
here knight f3 knight c6 and now the
main move is d4
white sacrifices the e5 pawn
uh and why does he sacrifice it well in
order to get a major clamp on black's
position knight bb5 is the theoretical
continuation
after a6 the knight travels to d6
forcing black to give away the bishop
and you get this kind of position
black generally plays f6
and uh white's compensation is evident
uh there's still well over 100 games in
this position i wonder if we'll see this
main line or if one of them will diverge
earlier
i'd be currently thinking in this
position yeah curious opening choice
by
richard
report
and fabi well he will be looking today
really to make use of the the white
pieces do you think he's happy to see
this on the board
i don't know it's hard to say i mean
he's taking his time and by the way i
should add that
um this line i i happen to know but uh
in general i use the chess.com the very
nifty openings tool
which shows me what the most common
moves are and how many games
are featured with each of those moves
and you know i don't know every single
opening and this really helps me
uh be an informed consumer of of the
games
very very useful tool for sure and i
think at home if you aren't familiar
with it uh you can play around with it
and yeah it really helps to to figure
out especially the opening stages of the
of the games
yeah and i only knew this is the
mckenna's outline but it tells me it's
the mckenna's carl's
sicilian nay gambit that's a lot of
names um
nay was an estonian international master
ebony
i didn't know that his name is also
associated with this line by the way the
only other
popular alternative to knight f3 is the
immediate
d4 so my guess is that that's what fabi
is deciding between but this is already
definitely
not expected um fabi did not expect us
that's for sure
well we're gonna let him uh
decide which of the two he goes for or
could it be a completely different move
and let's go back to the bird's eye view
and what else caught your eye
well we can see we don't have to go
there immediately gary duda
is
another one of those mckenna systems but
but in that position black actually went
d5 um and sergey ugh he went rookie one
he went for like the the very peaceful
line
um what shall we go to now well
we can go to the vidit uh prague game
because that is beginning to heat up
even though they're still in theory sure
let's go there
and actually they're already in
relatively uncommon territory so this
started off as a nimzo indian with queen
c2 we've seen
uh this this opening several times this
tournament
uh castles a3 takes takes
d5 bishop g5 this is all standard fare
and now a relatively uncommon move c5
uh the main line is is dtake c4 here and
fiona i'm having a hard time remembering
which game uh reached this position a
couple of rounds earlier
just trying to put my finger on it there
was a game where
i think takes takes happened and then
black played v6
and i want to say that vidit was oh yeah
vidit was black and
this time prague is black so colors are
reversed i don't remember who was white
in that game but anyways
uh black plays c5
d takes c5 and d4 which is a pretty
typical idea in the nimzo indian
it was
that's right
um so deciding that because he lost that
game with black you know maybe he wants
to take a stab at the other
the other side and now e3
and this position okay prague has played
h6
wait a minute all this has happened yeah
bishop takes f6 knight takes f6
still five games in the database and in
all five of those games white castled
queen side here
so if white castles queen side do we get
a typical um
kind of position where white attacks on
the king side and black attacks on the
the queen side or what's going on here
it's weird because white doesn't really
have an attack just yet i think white is
more trying to cling to his extra pawn
and attack down the d-file actually so
here black threatens bishop g4 and all
five people have gone 92.
uh now there's a deviation
two games d3 wow that looks incredibly
dangerous this pawn uh looks like a
weakness but the point
and now this is somehow beginning to
ring a bell i feel like i saw a game in
this line knight c3 bishop g4
and white plays rook takes d3
sacrificing the exchange and neither uh
player to have reached this position
accepted it black has played queen a5 in
both games this is an incredibly sharp
position fiona where
essentially black is going to be down a
pawn but he's going to have long lasting
chances against white's king i'm curious
to see how deeply the players have
analyzed this position who knows more
they're going down this line 92 has been
played
and they're going down
pretty fast none of them have really
spent much time on the clock so
very likely both players still in in
familiar territory and this is the kind
of position where who lands the first
surprise could be a very important
factor
absolutely currently prague with an hour
37 he's taking a little bit longer than
vidit but i'm sure that he's still in
preparation the other move in this
position is bishop g4
and there's an insane line here that i'm
noticing queen g3
and now one of the
there's d3 there's queen a5 and there's
even knight e4
now that that's not a blunder queen
takes g4 knight takes f2
and after queen f3
uh black actually took the d1 rook if
you take the h1 rook your knight's gonna
get trapped after g3
so it's it's better to take the d1 rook
in order to orchestrate and x-ray down
the e5 down the default this is a
incredibly complicated position fiona
this is really really wild stuff uh
between the two indian players if people
thought this might be a friendly game
and uh well we could it couldn't have
been wrong the players really throwing
uh everything at each other and uh big
is informing us that vidit has reached
this position after
so did he play on the 12th move he
didn't castle but played knight e2 i
think is what vic is saying uh he
reached that game at position in a game
against ganguly in 2018.
interesting and he was also white in
that game yeah
okay
prague is currently
thinking after 92 and
i it's hard to say i mean is he still in
his preparation i i would think so and
there is this choice between bishop g4
and d3 especially if binit has reached
this position before prague must
know about that having gone into this
incredibly sharp line
yeah i wonder sometimes the time
consumption i think can also very much
be related to how the tournament is
going if the tournament isn't going so
well and you want to take more time to
to check and also i mean just maybe to
remember because this is
uh very sharp and it's the kind of line
where if you mess up the move order for
example it can be very very costly
yeah and you know you're trying to
remember
all of those files that you created as
the expression goes the the faintest ink
is more powerful than the strongest
memory
so as soon as you know you transfer from
looking at your actual file to trying to
remember that's where confusion starts
to creep in no matter how well you think
you know the line
but he has made up his mind nd3s on the
board
yeah the first move that we explored and
my guess is that it is going to go
knight c3 black actually is threatening
d takes e2 even though it doesn't look
like that
because after rook takes the e8 block
can simply promote to a queen and the
queen escapes via
via a5
and black is up a piece that's a very
funny line i'm sensing that vic is
preparing to show us something that is
meant to embarrass me
but we won't reveal what it is yet he's
laughing
right
now she has no idea what's going on i'm
missing out on the
soon soon soon
very soon
but for the time being
we're watching vidit yep he's got knight
c3 so he continues
to blitz out the moves
and prague is saying bishop g4 has also
been played so i think we can for sure
tell that the players uh are both still
unfamiliar
you want announcements wanna announce
the clip
do i want to announce the clip
um i suppose that i do this is fiona you
really started started this because you
mentioned something about last year's
coverage and
there was a certain commentator who
legend has it confused a cow with a dog
um now is that merely a legend an urban
legend or did that actually happen well
let's find out
interesting uh they met an interesting
animal here in vikka i'm curious where
when i saw the photo i thought i want to
go i don't know
i think i think most people would think
what is that um
am i are we supposed to know is that a
dog
a i mean who is that what is that are we
supposed to know
my friends nor anyone in the chess
community forgave me for that
how could i think that's that what came
over me
i i really
i i really i'm i'm in total disbelief it
was early in the morning that's the only
thing i can say i mean i think it's one
of my favorite memories
oh yeah no for sure
i i didn't live that down the rest of
the broadcast i was thinking about it
they met an interesting animal here in
vikka i'm curious where when i saw the
photo i thought i wanna go and i don't
what do you even call this animal
actually what what is that um
am i are we supposed to know is that a
dog
a gu i mean who is that what is that are
we supposed to know
okay daddy let's move on should we have
another look at the position on the
board afterwards
absolutely so
i just want to point out one thing
uh which is that black can win the
exchange black can play bishop takes f3
the question why doesn't he do that uh
well the problem is after rook takes c
rook takes the gf3
uh white has two pawns for the exchange
and the issue is that you're not going
to be able to win the c5 oh uh dania
sorry to interrupt you someone uh the
game is already over karjakin against uh
magnus oh my goodness no let's have a
look that was a draw well that our
question was answered
uh i think the moment carlson played the
berlin you know we had the sense that
this might happen
and they went down a very well-known
uh drawing path yeah sergey playing the
rookie one variation and this kind of
signals that he is fine with a draw
bishop f1 knight f5 i mean this is all
very well known and the position is
extremely symmetrical
so 20 minutes into the round we see the
players have already left the board uh
surely soon they will have left the
building
and uh well you called it i think magnus
with the black pieces uh he is the sole
leader the drawing and a draw against
sergey is never going to be
a bad result and if sergey also feels
like also sergey had a very long game
yesterday if he's happy
with the draw as white um so both
players are off into the rest day
yeah i mean here's the thing nobody
likes uh these kinds of games uh uh you
know not me nyu none of the chess fans
but you also have to sort of put
yourself in the player's shoes
you know and realize that especially
magnus has to do
everything you know scientifically
to maximize his chances of success when
you're playing karjakin with black
uh and it's the day before the rest that
you really don't want to lose going to
the rest day
um karjakin is such a solid player that
burning all of the bridges against him
when you're in clear first it is not
worth it and from sergey's perspective
magnus is in great form it's tempting to
you know to score a nice solid draw you
know gain a couple of rating points and
going to the going to the to the rest
day uh you know in a good mood so it's
understandable uh it's not fun to watch
but
it is what it is
and uh i wonder how anish geary feels
about that draw because now while he is
playing with the white pieces against
of duda and with a win he would be
catching magnus carlsen
absolutely let's have a look at his game
against jkd
all right so this was as i mentioned
another mckenna system but this time
black going d5 this is the more modern
treatment of the position
okay so you have a trade on c3 queen
takes f6
knight f3
and now there's e5 uh which is the most
popular move c5 is close second the
bishop comes out to d3 they're still
following quite a few games bishop d7
bishop centralizes to e4 black disarms
the bishop with his own bishop queen
comes out to c2 only one game with this
move
and uh duda currently thinking fiona in
in this position and what he's thinking
about is whether to take the bishop
or to simply develop his pieces in the
game that reached this position
this happened
and now black plays knight c6 and this
transposes to a position without five
games in the database rook b1 is
possible and then black actually has
castled queenside
interesting
i mean i have to say i'm completely
unfamiliar uh with the opening from both
sides and also with the resulting
positions which are
somewhat strange i think this is a very
unusual uh type of uh type of position
can you maybe
try and explain some uh basic ideas for
for both sides and this uh and this
opening in this position
yeah i mean this is a very concrete
opening what i mean by that is it's an
opening that from white's perspective is
predicated on
very tactical ideas to make it work now
the only
long-term asset that white has is the b
file and that's a pretty serious asset
if you think about the fact that black
is likely to castle queenside um but
white's pawn structure isn't good
black's pawn structure is obviously much
better
and so white has to rely on
active
tactical play so for instance in this
position white has to notice that the
queen and the rook are aligned and so
white has the move d4
and the main line continues queen g6
queen takes g6 h takes g6
and now again white has to keep
developing with an eye toward piling up
the pressure and so the move bishop b3
comes to mind
so
the thing about white's pawn structure
to understand is that yes it's pretty
ugly right now but if there is a trade
on d4 then white's structure
rectifies itself and these pawns in the
center could become under a different
set of circumstances a pretty dangerous
force so for instance white could bring
the king up to e2 play rook hd1 and then
white would be ready to push that d-pawn
so
white's position isn't visually
attractive
but it contains uh
you know it it contains a lot of promise
and they're following this line takes
takes knight c6 is on the board
yeah so we could be going down uh
exactly
this path and
some
interesting i'm definitely going to be
learning something today then is the
interesting game ahead here uh between
between the two players i'm just looking
at chad banana just saying fiona
availing herself for free lessons from
dania that's exactly what's happening
here
oh absolutely no i i i know what you're
doing i i totally
i'm just going along with it
dania let's bring back the birds i uh
view maybe let's do it
let's do it yeah let's take a look at
that reaction carlson you know
fascinating we should analyze that more
yeah let's uh let's go there
i'm kidding
sorry oh my goodness i actually i didn't
i didn't hear the name you said i said
that
okay let's move on back for the that is
payback for the dog
[Laughter]
even though you weren't the instigator
it was really bitcoiny to get back i
said i thought you had said karana and
then when i somehow when i processed
what you had actually said i was like oh
my god
we'll do
that that basically disqualifies the
commentator but in in all seriousness
there's a couple of things to point out
and then we can go either to the fabi
game which is heating up or to
do bob grendellius we see a pretty tame
uh italian and yes panko so we can let
them play out the theoretical moves
there
before we actually
uh stop in at that game
uh do love grindelius is a slightly
weird i mean there's a lot of
simplification going on there so maybe
let's have a look at that one
and
okay
um let's go let's go from the beginning
oh knight f3 c5 before this move order
so dubois deciding to transpose the game
into a sicilian
and he plays a rosalina bishop b5 check
or rather i guess the moscow variation
is what this is known as
bishop d7 takes d7
neil is taking with the knight which is
a totally viable system you can also
take with the queen
c3 knight gf6 queen e2 this is all very
normal
e6
and the immediate d4 which is a lot less
common most people castle here
first
but daniel going d4
we have a trade
and neil's striking back in the center
with d5 and after e5
uh you know the standard reaction fiona
is 94 but neil's deciding to throw in
bishop b for check that's a very
interesting choice
and i think the idea
is to meet bishop d2
with a positional
maybe a positional pawn sacrifice on e4
but maybe he also wants to go knight g8
and then 97 and castle
i'm very confused because we left known
territory very quickly was that just by
uh
when daniel played d4 instead of
castling or
did things already get weird sooner
it appears that d4 is is very uncommon
for whatever and i think the reason is
exactly what niels has demonstrated
which is this move bishop before check
and why is this a reason not to play d4
well it's just uncomfortable it's hard
to meet this move you don't really want
to trade bishops here because then you
don't have anything to attack the king
side with and if you play knight c3 then
94 comes with
a particularly strong effect in fact
white could end up losing a pawn black
has rook c8 queen a5 uh this gets really
nasty
i don't know if daniel confused this or
is he
i don't i really don't know what it is
he's aiming for in this position yeah i
was wondering the same exact exact thing
but he's been playing
very fast and it's strange that he would
now pause after
bishop b4 is he at the board can we get
a visual and try and read his at the
board
and
yeah
yeah he is looking i mean he's not
looking like yeah this was all in my
practice was all part of the plan
i think he might have confused the line
i think he simply might have forgotten
to castle
and and kudos to niels for figuring out
that this is and yeah he just seems very
exasperated i'll add that knight b to d2
might be the best way to cover the check
but if you look at this after 94 castles
knight takes d2
and all you kind of have to take with a
bishop
this is not exactly you know what i
would categorize as an impressive
position out of the opening i mean this
just looks
tremendously drawish you know there's
going to be exchanges on the c file and
white might be nominally better because
he's got a little bit more space but
it's not significant no and yeah i agree
with you i think something went wrong
maybe just forgot to cast and maybe
confuse the lines as you said but
this is not what daniel wanted out of
the opening
it's important to remember that
they do so much opening review before
the round they have to go through such a
volume of different positions that
you might say oh how can he confuse this
so early you know didn't he rehearse
this before they game well he might have
but this might have been one of 15
things that he rehearsed
um and and this happens you know from
time to time even even the greats have
you know these
uh these snafus
yeah and well we will come back to to
this game uh in a bit i'm curious to see
how daniel is going to react uh but we
are going to take go on our first uh
quick break of the day and then we'll be
back with all the action here from round
10 so don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
interesting uh they met an interesting
animal here in waika i'm curious where
when i saw the photo i thought i wanna
go and i don't what do you even call
this animal actually what what is that
um
am i are we supposed to know what is
that a dog
a gu i mean who is that what is that are
we supposed to know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to our coverage of round 10
of the tata seal chess tournament and as
you can see one game is already in the
books a disappointment for chess fans
who were looking forward to the clash
between karjakin and carlson uh but
carlson with the black pieces played a
solid berlin and uh karjakin clearly not
in the mood happy to take the quick draw
uh as white and the players are off into
the rest day and danya what is going on
elsewhere
yeah let's as we see our bird's eye view
here i'll quickly run through all of the
games and then we'll decide which one
we want to focus on we have a mckenna's
in geary against duda very interesting
position where white's bad structure is
compensated by an initiative we'll see
if geary is able to conduct that
initiative well shanklin mahmud yarov is
in a catalan it feels like chakrayar has
basically equalized we could take a look
at that game in a little while we have
uh vidit against prague the all-india
matchup prague has sacrificed a pawn in
the nimzo indian for long-term
compensation against white's king we
have fabiano against report that old
school line
also in the english fabiano has just
offered a queen trade and he's trying to
play against that light squad bishop
that's blocked by the e6 pawn i think
fabi uh is building up toward a a very
small edge we have daniel dubov
uh sorry andreas sepenko against van
forest lower center uh
center of your screen that is a game we
haven't checked out yet we can do that
very soon it's a knight versus bishop
situation in a classic kind of rye lopez
structure
uh white's probably going to castle
short and try to exploit the f-file and
in dubai
uh lower right hand side uh dubaf has
just played bishop d2
acquiescing to a bishop trade fiona and
at this point i'm 99 certain that he
just simply confused the opening and
allowed this very nasty check on before
niels should have absolutely zero issues
here if he trades bishops and plays
knight g8 and that will simply be a
completely equal position or what do you
think
yeah i mean
we could actually go to that game really
really real fast just so i can explain
why this is such a big deal you know it
may not seem
uh so important in fact it may seem that
black is losing several tempe
uh by rerouting the night but here's the
thing
uh the structure is incredibly
symmetrical white really needs that dark
scored bishop
as a
you know as an attacker so if you think
about it you know knight g8 first of all
white cannot exploit the temporary lead
in developing the center is way too
locked up
and the dangerous thing after castle's
97 this pawn on d4
is actually kind of a long-term weakness
it is
not it cannot be defended by any other
puns you don't have a c pawn you don't
have an e pawn and so black snipe
kind of french style can swing to c6 the
queen can come out to b6 and so black
has
long term play against the pawn but most
importantly
uh once black castle short just with two
knights there's just no way that white
can create any chances whatsoever
against black's king
uh you know move like knight g5 is
completely a paper tiger it can just be
met with h6 or knight f5
and and
i i have a feeling that the game
might fizzle out into a pretty quick
draw
yeah i think that quite often happens i
think it also is tough i don't know if
you have any experience probably you do
but
yolo i think you're always a little bit
shook when you realize that you've sort
of confused or messed up your lines
for sure we saw duba kind of grabbing
his head he seemed to be exasperated and
he took
probably around 10 minutes on bishop d2
which
really is the strongest indication that
uh this wasn't what he planned for i
also mentioned the positional pawn
sacrifice 94 as a candidate move
but uh i've soured on it a little bit
the problem is that after white captures
it what i wanted to do with black is go
knight b6 and then stick a knight on d5
but but that doesn't work because you
give up another pawn and two pawns is
way too much of a price to pay just for
control over one square so that's it's
not worth doing that i think niels is
going to go knight g8
yeah night jade and well he will be
happy with what he got here we'll see
uh how this game evolves but yeah
something definitely slightly gone wrong
for duboff uh in the opening and maybe
we can check in also with uh yes panko
against uh jordan renfrey's that knight
versus bishop position you mentioned
definitely and let's go from the start
this was actually an italian not a
spanish so it was an italian knight f6
white opting not to go for the fried
lover but instead going d3
and bishop c5 oh and knight c3 which is
a little bit less common than of course
the traditional italian move which is
pawn c3 this transposes the game into a
sort of a four knights defense this
should be three bishop b6
and an early knight d5
which is met with d6 black doesn't mind
uh
knight takes b6 that's just fine for
black h3 but then black decides to trade
bishops
uh and play knight a5 going after this
bishop on c4
uh and that's why in the italian very
often white plays bishop b3 and then c3
so that the bishop can hide away on c2
in this case
white is essentially forced to give the
bishop up bishop b3 takes takes castles
castles
i think white's gotten absolutely
nothing out of the opening i think the
simplest for jordan is to drop this
screen back to e7 fiona
and then
okay maybe this allows
queenie one i was gonna say play for an
early f5 yeah i think even this is
totally fine
no problems here for black and he can
play a6 so the a file isn't even
such a big deal this looks like a
completely equal position
at best for white
yeah so once a another another game
where something out of the opening i
don't know here if it's something gone
wrong
because andrei what's his he's only
spent 10 minutes
or if it's just a little bit
of an opening experiment which didn't
really yield any efforts
well the other thing to point out fiona
is that even if black doesn't play five
now generally these positions white's
main idea is to go knight h4 you know
queen g3 assemble the pieces on the king
side
but with only one minor piece i'm just
not seeing
uh the serious attack happening and
there is the move knight f5 in a
position like this
and and if you take on f5 and drop your
bishop back yeah white has the move f6
and white actually wins queen g3 is
coming
but in such situations uh as uh my
grandfather used to say it's not
checkers in the russian version of
checkers you have to capture
the pieces and hear why black would play
queen g5 and say all right you're
welcome to chill on f5 but now i want to
take you
so in this spot do we have to drop the
knight back or is there any way to
continue the assault
well there's the move h4 and but here
there's the very pretty idea of going
queen d8 blundering upon an h6 not a
blunder king g7 and where is this knight
going to go absolutely nowhere you have
to sacrifice
on f5 but at this point capturing and
dropping the bishop back is a far more
viable strategy f6 can be met with king
h6 and white is just not in time queen
g3 rook g8 all key squares are defended
and black is up a piece now of course we
went pretty far but this is just an
illustration uh to show that if black is
careful he shouldn't have really any
significant problems on the king side so
jordan um
easily equalized do you think black
might be better here with the bishop
uh well the the engine is giving a tiny
preference to black i would disagree
with that i think it's equal i i really
don't think that black is better uh the
structure is too symmetrical and the
knight is not bad in this position make
no mistake as jordan does indeed play
queen 27 i think we're gonna see queenie
one
and and i think we're likely going to
see some sort of liquidation
down the f-file
okay well this one's shaping up uh quite
peacefully at the moment we'll see what
happens let's go back again
to the bird's eye view
and
um where do you want to go next
well we have some developments both in
the shanklin game as well as the vivid
game let's start with a vivid game
perhaps and then move to the shanklin
mamidiarov affair
uh okay well this is getting pretty
crazy i will point out that vivid is
still playing very very quickly he's got
almost all of his time remaining
very impressive looks like fitted still
in prep here
so
where did this leave oh we're still here
until here following a couple of games
and yeah this is the novelty it appears
rook d2
d2 is the novelty that the previous two
games had both continued e4
and admitted going rook d2 to defend
to defend the c pawn with his bishop
that this move actually makes a lot of
sense to me e4 makes less sense yeah i
was gonna ask you because i was still
stuck at e4 i didn't understand
why we can afford to to give up that uh
big pawn in front of our king oh
i think the i oops not rook d5 the idea
is to play rook d6 i'm pretty sure and
rook takes f6 is unstoppable i mean you
can drop the queen to ca but that
doesn't stop rook f6 and h3
very nice so that's the idea of e4 but
black is under no obligation to take c4
in fact black drops the bishop back to
e6 and white does encounter problems
with the c4 pawn so
wit it going rook d2 and now b4
absolutely fearless just opening up his
own king
and after queen c8 he is thinking
he's got a couple of options he can take
on e5 here
but then he has to calculate bishop
takes c4 and i get i like what prague is
doing prague is going for
a long-term attack against white's king
and white has to be very precise in this
kind of position i mean b4 has to be
preparation right he must have looked at
this before because it doesn't look so
dangerous to to the human eye to open up
the king like that
yeah it does and and i think one way
that he could consider handling this is
to take on e5 and to meet bishop take c4
with king b2 the king b2 is not entirely
unsafe black can try to open up the king
further with a5 but that will be met
with b5
and on the other hand you know
i like what prague is doing generally
speaking but if he doesn't show
something concrete on the queen side and
if white is able to bring this last
stroke into the game
let's not forget that black is down a
full pawn and it's a healthy fun white
spawn structure is completely intact
yeah very very interesting battle here
between the two indian players as vedic
was
hovering with the hand but then the hand
went back on the head
i think he's gonna take on e5 but i
really don't see him playing the move c5
here
that overextends
the queen side even further and after a5
you know
black is going to take on b4 and get the
a file
and i think you just took on e5 yeah
e5 is on the board and
well we'll come back we'll come back
here but very interesting
stuff indeed
and the other game we wanted to update
was
shankland mamedyarov
indeed
okay so we
saw sam playing knight v1
chakri are developing and throwing them
before yeah knight a4957 is what we
expected castle's castles queen c2 and
now bishop b4 kind of a typical
idea executed by chakriar where the
bishop moves away from b7 and then the
queen
uh takes the bishop's place to get
that battery along the long diagonal
rook fc1 queen b7 and sam disarming
that battery by playing knight e1
takes takes and rook f e8 i think shakur
is preparing to break free in the center
with a movie five now sam once again
he's got c file pressure he's got
control over the c5 square
i
i think white is for choice here i think
white's position is slightly preferable
but look at jacques i mean the speed at
which he's played is incredible he's
spent less than five minutes
and he doesn't look too concerned at all
no i wonder what he's
yeah he's looking off into the distance
just uh i don't know if he's frustrated
or if he's just bored he looks
incredibly boring
he looks very comfortable in some weird
way but yeah he
[Music]
[Laughter]
the camera broke like this this is
off into the
up into the sea we go
oh yeah that is the sea that's the the
painting of the sea right
or is that just about yeah it's the the
background in the the playing hall
right
now we zoom back into reality sam is
hard at work here thinking about his
movie yeah he has spent
uh he spent about 40 minutes
yeah but uh i agree with you i mean
white's position
looks
very
nice to me
you have to wonder is this all prep is
this what where he wanted he doesn't
look unhappy so
uh we'll come back here and and find out
what is going on as shaq continues
looking
uh
very very relaxed
indeed and if we can go back to our
bird's eye view we've got a couple of
expected developments um we have first
and foremost did it yeah he's gone
bishop takes c4 king b2 and now the onus
is on
prague to to prove his compensation for
for the pawn
uh which is a pretty concerning moment
yeah for prague i mean prague has lost
three games in a row uh which is a very
tough spot then to play with black
yesterday he sacrificed an exchange
which looked uh really interesting in
the end it
didn't work out for him
but yeah today
the onus is on in on him here as you say
to to show the
the compensation and i think since we've
just come there we'll return a little
bit later while we let him figure out
how he's going to go on about that of
course yeah
shall we update
anish maybe
yeah it's been a while since we looked
at that and anish has just played rook
b1
uh so he took a very significant amount
of time on that move
uh he's dropped down to an hour and nine
minutes and we were discussing
rook b1 and the the idea is essentially
to induce long castles
uh in order to make sure that the queen
and the rook are aligned now white has
to move d4 so we were discussing the
line with queen g6 now the question is
back of alternatives to castles
well
black has them of rook b8 but i think
that's highly inadvisable
because apart from everything else
there's tactics with the rook takes b7
but even the simpler move d4 looks
incredibly strong and that rook on v8 is
unstable it can be attacked
uh by the bishop uh through f4 but the
the engine is actually indicating
that rook takes b7 in this position is
very strong takes c6
and now oh bishop g5 is totally crushing
bishop g5 wins the queen
because if you move it you get
checkmated with queen ca
that would be one brutal way to end
to end the game
yep he's castled and i think gary
is gonna pretty quickly play d4 i i
guess white could also castle short and
and stay flexible but the issue with
with that to me is that black is gonna
go queen g6
and then you're gonna regret not playing
d4 when you had the chance because now
this pawn on d2 is a backward pawn and
uh d4 is no longer possible so
you need to take the opportunity while
you have this temporary
uh tactical trump card
uh to to get d4 in so that you get your
pawns rolling
yeah for sure um aneesh he is taking uh
his time but
i'm um
yeah i am with you i think that uh
sorry
i'm so sorry i just completely lost my
train of thoughts
oh you're good
i know i
think what is it about this cursed day
i'll just blame it all on magnus the
camera has also lost the thread yeah
they can't
no i think i think everyone do bothers
can see it's in the air
it's in the wake on zayer you know
duboff confuses his preparation
and we've got weird stuff going on in a
lot of games
you know it's the day before the rest
day it is the day before the wrestling
restaurant clearly cannot come soon
enough
move on from this game and uh go back to
the bird's eye view
and now we see by the way that uh
in
yes panko and forest they are following
that simplifying line when forest has
gone f5 uh and andre has captured i i
have that game might end pretty quickly
i mean it's such a symmetrical position
and we also see that uh daniel duboff
has castled queenside
yes he has that's very dubovian of him
let's take a look at that as we see gary
did indeed play
uh d4 but let's go to the dubai game
okay uh he decided after knight g8 yeah
he decided to castle queenside
and that's not necessarily a declaration
of war it's just that his king
probably is just as safe on the queen
side as it is on the king side
and it it is a declaration of war in the
sense that i think he does still want to
attack black's king
when niels castles and my guess is that
nils is going to castle king's side
dubois could even consider going h4 in
this position
just to get a head start on on the
attack and in the event of black castles
uh you go h5 and you know white's
already creating creating uh some some
threats and probing for holes uh the
attack isn't that strong but it can get
annoying
okay so from wilson's perspective i
wouldn't cancel that quickly
funnily enough that answers my question
i was gonna ask can i stay uh with the
king in the center for now and maybe
launch my queenside pond
i'll tell you more i would even
contemplate castle in queenside if i'm
new so something like queen b6 queen e3
and castle's queen side
is very much on the cards as well then
going king b8 you know if white's king
is safe black's king is also pretty safe
but you mentioned the idea of pushing
the side pawns also very possible you
could
you could say hey if you're getting a
head start on your attack well i'm gonna
get a head start on mine and you can
play a move like a6 the problem is that
black's pawn storm is just not as
effective there aren't really any
targets on the queen side whereas on the
king side you know white is already very
close to playing h6
and creating a lot of dark square
weaknesses and if black goes h6 then you
know g4 g5 comes and this can get pretty
unpleasant
but it's funny how after the opening
where we felt that something happened uh
most likely confused some line or
um but he's found a way i think to to
still make this game uh interesting he
said okay
i might have messed this one up slightly
but that that's not to mean that this is
just going to be a boring equal game
no and and double um
he he always knows how to make it
interesting even
in the driest of situations i
i agree with you i was trying to think
of a pawn his name means a dub in
russian means oak like an oak tree oh so
i was trying to figure out a way to work
that into a pawn but i have so far
failed i mean oak is not an easy one to
work with no not at all not at all but i
remember
uh teasing him
when i was at the
i played a tournament in russia in 2008
which was called the young young stars
of the world it was a
scholastic scholastic tournament with
some of the top players i think under
15.
and duo won that tournament it was
really one of his first big tournament
victories he was not even in the top
half of the tournament standings rating
wise
um and i remember my good friend alex
dipato and i were chasing him around
uh the the park outside the playing hall
and we were we were arguing what his
skype name would be would it be dub97 or
doom 96 you know because that means that
means oak
so good memories good memories that was
the first time i met him
uh and since then he's only
shot up fun times um
but
he doesn't looks like he's having so
much fun right now still looking
somewhat uh
concerned but
yeah h4 i i like your i like your
suggestions
we will leave him to it for now let's
bring back the bird's eye view again
and uh prague
he
is uh answering our questions as to and
just as we say that h4 has appeared on
the board
and uh in prague's game maybe we can go
back there is there anything else daniel
you'd like to go to first duvaf just did
go h4 by the way so this idea of getting
a head start
uh he he's done it
um and and the last thing i'll say giri
and duda are going down that engine are
in that end game queen g6
trade and giri's probably going to go
bishop e3 but yeah let's let's go back
to the
vidid game and explore this position and
see if black has enough compensation for
that pawn
so we only left the move ago after king
b2 and we were wondering what is prague
gonna do as you say he is upon down he
needs to show something and a5 probably
one of the most direct approaches and i
think you had shown
b5 being the logical move uh the logical
reply for vility
yeah and i mean black needs to create
anchor points for his pieces because
otherwise this king is not going to
checkmate itself
uh so the move a4 comes to mind as one
way to do that if you look at the b3
square uh this essentially prevents
bishop takes c4 which would be totally
unthinkable that would help the queen
get to b3 uh so this would create an
interesting kind of tension between the
bishops
white can drop the queen down to d4
with a two-fold idea that the main idea
is to cover the c4 square so that the
queen doesn't get to b3 and if the queen
tries to get to that square via e6 then
white can cover it with queen before the
very important thing for fitted is
obviously not to go upon grabbing
further something like knight takes a4
allows the move knight e4 and white's
pieces start to get overextended so
this is definitely dangerous for white
but from a purely objective standpoint
fiona i i think that black doesn't my
intuition tells me that black doesn't
have enough if vidit plays very very
carefully
i has plenty of time on the clock to to
find those careful moves uh and let's
remind everyone maybe we can very
briefly bring up uh the standings
because with it he is one of the players
who is in a close pursuit of magnus
so this hasn't been updated yet magnus
he drew his game so he is on
seven out of ten right now which means
that if it can get a win here he will be
only half a point behind magnus
absolutely and uh vidid has had great
tournament we can remember his
uh his wonderful save i mean his save
yesterday was something to behold
against uh against rapport that was
textbook end game play and when you
score score a game like that even though
you didn't win i talked about this
yesterday it's the same it gives you the
same confidence as the windows because
you tell yourself man i mean if i can
save these positions i'm basically
unstoppable and uh he's been playing
fast today
uh but we'll see if he manages to handle
this very complex situation against
prague indeed we'll come back here
let's bring up the bird's eye view
again and dania let you choose where to
go next
well let's see we have a couple of moves
played in
the espanko van forest game an
interesting move there
uh we have anishigiri did indeed play
bishop e3
um and it's been a while since we
checked into the caruana report game so
let's have a look at that one and assess
that end game
another strange position with f5 having
just appeared on the void let's go back
to to where we left it off
so fabi did end up deciding on the
immediate d4 he didn't go for that pawn
sacrifice variation i showed earlier
now the this is
not a sacrifice line because the queen
anchors itself to the pawn uh richard
goes d6
baby keeps the tension knight f3 knight
h6 okay we have a trade and now this
move queen g5 essentially forcing a
queen trade because
uh you don't want to give up the g the
g7 pawn obviously so take stakes and now
to move f5
and i think richard's idea is to uh
reroute the knight back to f7 now one
might ask well why didn't he go to f5
that seems more active well the problem
is that after white castles this knight
is is quite vulnerable and you know
white's already threatening g4 although
the engine actually prefers this to to
what richard did but in any case he's
gone f5
fabby has castled and now a decision
moment for for richard who's got to
decide whether he plays knight f7 or
bishop c5 or bishop b8 very very
complicated end game here in marijuana
report
yeah i have a question about that pawn
formation on e6 f5 for black what is the
idea does black want to try and get in
e5 in the long term or otherwise are
those pawns not
too weak like how do you how do you feel
about like pawn structure
i think in the long run black definitely
wants to go e5 before but the main
drawback of that is is that the movie
five creates a big hole on d5 so i don't
really see this happening anytime soon
black's position is still
quite a bit too passive to sustain a
move like e5
uh and there's no big hurry because the
bishop on c8 is doing a good job of
protecting the e6 pawn it's not an easy
pawn to attack uh the but the main
concern i think for black right now is
is how to
first of all finish the development the
bishop unsee it is still undeveloped and
i i think f5 might have been a slight
misjudgment by richard who who might
have just underestimated the extent of
white's initiative after knight f7
uh you know something like bishop e3
also threatens the move c5 and then the
bishop could come out
i feel like this is quite a bit
unpleasant for black to be honest yeah
and fabiano must be quite happy with
what he has
gotten here he had a slow start to his
event but he's picking up speed now in
the second
part of the tournament
and we'll see if he can get squeeze
something squeeze a full point out of
what looks like a nice land game
meanwhile the hoodie is back in the
arrow game
it's well and truly back
it is
the just the level of focus is
is incredible
i'm curious let's bring the bird's eye
view to see i'm curious if it's shaq's
move
or yes
he is thinking yeah
yeah i mean sam has got knight f4 sam is
rerouting that knight to d3 where it's
going to control the c5 and e5 squares
and if shock doesn't go e5 in that
position
well uh he might end up in some trouble
positionally speaking i don't think he's
necessarily thrilled
with his position fiona yeah it's funny
because last time we were there he
looked very relaxed and very calm and
and confident but
this is a very different
shock
we are going to go on a quick break now
we'll be back uh with all the action
here from round 10 during the break like
every day we'll be checking in with the
challenges uh section with big bringing
you some highlights so enjoy that and
we'll see you soon
[Music]
yes welcome everyone to check in with
the challengers my name is welter bick
i'm the esports producer here for
chess.com and also the producer here in
waikanza at the moment and next to the
master section we also have the
challenger section and the section the
winner of that section will obviously
play in the master section next year so
there's a lot on the line and today
we're checking in a little bit each day
it's a segment and ganguly versus bier
we have a look at this position and it's
absolutely already crazy there's mayhem
on the board the king is not that safe
this king is
prone to attacks uh the rocks are coming
in it's absolutely beautiful we already
see it's a plus five and a half for
white and after the move
queen to e6 which seems like a very good
move the idea here is rook to d7
uh
trying to
put more pressure on so i absolutely
understand this move there's actually a
move here for black
that would
solve the situation and it is bishop
takes f3 we are going in hams jabroni i
don't even know that's a word but it
should be now because after bishop takes
f3 we cannot ignore this
we give a check and the point is ladies
and gentlemen this rook isn't defended
at the moment
and if you go up
to h2 there are like a bunch of checks
you can do and the queen will zigzag
around you have to be careful you're not
getting mated you cannot go to this line
because this knight will jump in and
uh-oh your checkmate is to show a little
bit
if you start running in the wrong
direction 93 check
you're losing this rook this one's
coming in i'm pretty sure this is made
uh even though after king e2 you might
escape this is absolutely horrible so
we cannot do that so we cannot really
take the bishop and if a rock takes g2
we take here uh it's actually a pretty
equal position at this moment
uh black has a lot of attack going white
is very solid in that regard
uh and they're both trying to survive g5
is hanging there's a whole mayhem on the
board
but it should be equal
the move that white should have made was
queen to d8 and obviously this is move
was it 35 they both had a minute left so
i don't really mind that they didn't see
this but after queen to d8
uh bishop takes a three we go into the
same idea we can see now
that the rocket d1 is defendant and the
idea of government d7 later in the
position is still a theme and after k2
there are no longer adding checks you
might throw this one in uh just for
the fun of it
but after let's say here here
rook g2 it's finally over and you can
see that this pawn is getting absolutely
slaughtered on g5 and black cameras are
in here because there's no way to defend
the queen and the rook coming in
delivering checkmate at some point now
this option was missed unfortunately by
black and after a few moves
uh which is not my analysis
we came to this position a rook to d7
again and white played bishop to b8 now
you're attacking this at night there's a
a pin on the queen and the bishops there
are no background checkmates because
this rook is defending c1 so obviously
this is a very good move the engine
still likes white well there is a crazy
variation that's what i really want to
show you that
the move rook to c7
was the best move now you might be
thinking like well back what happens
after bishop to d5
this is not this is actually not that
great
if i take this bishop or you think like
well this could happen at least i can
trade something off
and save my guts
again bishop d5
seems very tempting but white has a
better move than just taking that bishop
is bishop
to d4
check
with the idea that if you take my bishop
your rook isn't defended anymore and
even though it is defended by the bishop
like through an x-ray
you can deliver an easy
checkmate
this way
unbelievable i'm going to leave that
position on the board and if you move
away at 2h7
now we're just going to take your bishop
and again there's no backward checkmate
because this rook is defending it very
nicely and it is absolutely mayhem on
the board so
let's leave it like this bishop to d4
check it absolutely crazy uh position
there at the end white did win this game
as he should because this was a
spectacular fantastic game from both
sides uh the challengers group is
growing some arjunary guys he is now
two points in the lead he's gonna win
this tournament with three rounds to
spare or something so it's gonna be
absolutely ma'am so i we're not going to
congratulate yet but he is doing an
absolutely fantastic job
uh for the community and hope you guys
enjoyed this small little technical
oversight
again my name is about the big and i'm
not gonna bore you with any more
challenges section you can follow it as
well on chess.com events or
tatasteelchest.com to follow all the
games that are going on at the moment
but for now let's bring it back to fiona
and dania
[Music]
i used to read a lot of books i even
wrote once to play in the c group when i
was like very very young so i guess i
was around 13 14 something like this
yeah i think around that time i must
have heard about them
but i finally got the opportunity in
2018 i was already 2700 back then and i
played the b group as the top seed
which i managed to win and then play in
their group
i came here first as a second of anish
not as a player
and then of course winning the b group
was very very special
that is something
which was kind of a breakthrough
to get elite level tournaments
invitation
if i don't use technology i'll be just
lagging behind
against all my colleagues because you
have to use it kind of the thing is i my
thinking is a bit old school
because it's very slow to do it old
style with the chess board it's possible
um but i think you need a team which
will help you
at least somebody has to check with the
engine that's what i feel
in my heart
i like to you know move the pieces and
do it on the board
welcome back to round 10 here at the
tata steel chess tournament we just
heard from vidit who on the republic day
in india he is playing his compatriot
pragnanda one game has already ended
karjakin against magnus was a quick draw
and danya where would you like to go
back to
yeah we've got interesting developments
in a couple of the games uh let's have a
look at yasipanko van forest
just to see whether andre
has managed to create anything out of
that position and really the answer that
to that seems to be no
uh fiona we saw uh jordan
go for this f5 idea queen e1 f5 we had a
trade interestingly jordan takes with
the rook which i wasn't really expecting
was expecting to take with the bishop of
course rook takes f5 is also perfectly
viable and now queen before trying to
prevent
black from developing his bishop aiming
at the b7 pawn to which jordan responds
c5 i think the point of this move
is not only to attack the queen it is to
prepare the development of the bishop
because now the queen on e7 defends the
pawn on b7 and queen e4 is likely here
and then after bishop b6 black is still
i think quite doing quite all right can
we go back to the moment when jordan
decided to capture on f5
with the rook
i think bishop takes looked so natural
do you think that rook takes is a more
ambitious choice so how would you
explain it yeah it's hard to say i mean
maybe he was worried about knight h4 but
it's very clearly nothing to worry about
due to bishop h7 and you know g6 is
uh is well protected i should also add
after rook takes f8 check
you can go rook takes f8 and if white
grabs the pawn on on a7 there's this
very nasty move e4
and and the knight on h4 experience is
big big problems so you could also just
play queen takes f8 here even if you
didn't see that
so
i really don't know
why he subjected himself to this kind of
slight awkwardness
now he has to make a weakening move i
don't think it's significant i still
think it's equal
but i'm a little bit confused to be
honest i i don't fully understand oh
maybe it was maybe he was worried about
e4 but it's not like white didn't have
e4 after rook takes f5
so i don't know
yeah hard too
hard to understand his decision maybe
we'll hear
from uriden later but
he's
he's also looking like he could be in
some trouble he's looking quite
concerned
yeah i mean
i i think queen e4 is the likeliest the
white players choice by andre all other
moves just either seem awkward or
not particularly ambitious i don't think
he's going to drop his queen back so i
think after queenie 4 bishop okay
andre's about to make a move and it is i
think queen e4
let's confirm yes queen e4 has been
played
now
bishop e6 is
i wouldn't say forrest but
pretty naturally it's already been
played yeah
yeah and now the move knight h4
could end up being a little bit of a
problem fiona because okay let's say
black takes on f1 and white recaptures
one very important detail is that d5
runs into queen takes e5 and the bishop
on e6 is gonna hang
otherwise you know the knight either
comes into g6 or to f5 and black still
has
yeah maybe small problems but black has
to solve problems and that's not
something i thought jordan would have to
do in this game at all
yeah a very strange
decision to to take on f5 with the rook
and as you say it's probably not big
trouble but um
little trouble is already worse than
equality which the other line seemed to
be giving
but we'll come back here see if he as a
pango
can continue taking some small small
ground
uh meanwhile elsewhere should we maybe
check back in with shakira mamidiarov
i was thinking too
yeah that game is undergoing some
developments and
we saw
chakriar contemplating what to do after
knight f4
and i think he correctly decided i mean
he took on a3 first to open up the b
file
but i think largely he correctly decided
to play fighting otherwise let's say he
makes a neutral move like h6
sam goes knight d3 and then the
opportunity train passes you can't play
e5 anymore you can definitely never play
c5 and white's got this nasty clamp on
the center on these two squares
so chakri are taking the chance while he
still has it
and sam has just dropped his knight back
to d3 anyway
no question in my mind that white is
better the question is how much
and i think if black is careful the
advantage should not be too significant
maybe rook b5 i mean that looks pretty
natural here
uh rook b5 and you could consider going
rook h5 and going for the king side
attack but
i don't i don't think that's i think i
feel like that's hope chess
how much of a concern uh are the the
weaknesses for black on the on the
queenside department c7 the pawn on a5
yeah well that's the reason why it's
better i think i i think the pawn on c7
is really the biggest it's the most
accessible weakness it can be attacked
by the white queen
as of yet you know you're not going to
lose either of these pawns if you're
careful so for example after rook b5 if
white just plays queen c3 that's not too
effective due to knight d5 although
white could
advance the queen to c6 and in an end
game
these weaknesses become even
an even greater concern because black
doesn't have as many resources to defend
them so sam is playing risk-free
essentially this is already a game for
two results but i think a draw is a lot
likelier than a shankling victory here
yeah but sam one of the players who also
is still chasing his
first full point and he is going to try
and make the most
out of what he's got and i'm curious
will shakhia return
to to this line a third time yesterday
against magnus that went wrong very
quickly and today
um
as you say i mean the position is far
from being much worse or anything like
that but still i don't think that this
is really what shah wanted out of the
opening
no and and you know
is there a little bit of tilt involved
i'm sure he was very unhappy to lose in
the way that he did yesterday he didn't
play terribly
uh and again we discussed it many times
how magnus just he makes
people look i don't want to say like
fools but you know he just he makes it
look easy and he makes you think that
you've just played a terrible game when
in reality uh you've just only really
made one
you know
seemingly small mistake which is kind of
what happened yesterday it was even hard
to say where chakra went wrong exactly
and very true
and yeah we'll see he's quite an
emotional
player
i don't know if there's already he
shouldn't be tilting of course he is
only one point behind he's still in uh
contention not just for podium but also
for first place he's a player who's
entirely capable of bringing together a
few
wins but yeah we'll see we'll come back
here
but sam he is enjoying himself in a
position i think as you said where he's
pretty much playing for two results
unless something
catastrophic happens here
yeah sam is almost impossible to beat
with black also people don't realize
that but he is
so so solid with the white pieces when
he wants to be
um and we do have our first irish pawns
of the round gary accepting the tripled
pawns in his game against duda let's
move to
let's let's move to that one as we look
briefly at our bird's eye view here
no big developments in any of the other
games oh andre did go knight h4 by the
way and fabi with a very interesting
move knight e5 but let's move to the
geary game i want to see how the pawn
structure transformed in that end game
so d4
queen g6
we have an exchange bishop e3 f6 due to
preparing king side expansion with this
f6 g5 idea that looks nice you need two
g5
and
after h3 bishop e7 anish couldn't resist
he took that pawn
and duda responds with e5 controlling
the d4 square i think black is totally
fine here
but so is white i mean i think this is
equal
i mean it's always such a weird uh pawn
structure here so you think the pawn
sacrifice was
justified um
by baiduda what are the plans now for
both sides you say both
should be happy but how do they continue
i think i would also point out that
these tripled ones aren't that bad
they're defending important squares you
know the pawn on c4 is creating an
anchor point on d5
the pawn on c3 is guarding the d4 square
which would otherwise have been a
potential outpost for black's knight
so i suppose i don't know exactly who
benefits in the event of both rooks
getting traded so if blaco's rook d8
here
white could respond to the move rook d5
in fact i think he will so probably not
worth
playing rook d8
um
and i mean the engine likes king c7 here
and if white still puts a rook on d5
then there's an interesting idea of
going
bishop f8 and following it up with 97 in
order to chase the rook away from d5 so
i feel like they might run into a
situation where neither side can make
much progress perhaps why i can swing
the knight around to e4 if given the
opportunity so there's ideas for both
sides these ideas are approximately
equivalent and again the likeliest
result in this game is definitely a draw
yeah
and we see a niche there
of course maybe he was hoping to get a
slightly bigger pull with
the white pieces he will continue
trying but looks like duda is
very solid he also has a very healthy
time advantage on the clock so we'll
come back here shall we go to to fabi's
game
let's go to fabi's game couple of moves
in that game
uh and in response to bishop c5 so f5 we
saw castles rehear going bishop c5 and
now 95 a very interesting try of course
the knight is untouchable
because of rook d8 check and rook takes
h8 winning the exchange
uh but i i like what richard did he
didn't panic and he just brings the
other knight back to f7
offering white i mean forcing white to
trade
the knight for one of black's knights
now i would imagine that fabi takes the
knight on c6 to at least damage black's
pawn structure you can't take the bishop
still because of rook d8 after b
b takes c6 bishop e3
uh this type of end game
fiona also looks pretty balanced to me i
mean white also has a weakness
black can go e5 bishop e6 here and
finally get that bishop
out of the out of the self-made prison
i i don't think fabi has really gotten
anything at all
uh in this endgame if fabio doesn't have
anything here do you think maybe knight
e5 was not the best trying or
[Music]
yeah maybe not i mean maybe the thing is
you probably do have to defend the f2
pawn it's not that bishop takes f2 is
such a huge and knight g4 is a very
nasty threat here
because then the knight captures on f2
with
uh very annoying consequences obviously
so a move like rook d2 could have been
considered
but yeah now black plays knight f7
and if you move the bishop to f4 then
the pawns already start rolling so this
idea of e5 is now uh a lot closer to
becoming a reality maybe not immediately
maybe black should even castle first but
e5 in this position is definitely
already a kind of positional threat so
maybe the case it's just the case that
visually white's position looks very
pleasant but if you look at it
concretely black uh black house all the
important squares covered yeah and i
have to say once again that i'm very
impressed by how rapport has handled
this position i i like the look of it
for fabiano
earlier on and a few weird looking moves
later he seems to be doing completely
completely fine
interesting and this is richard at his
best this is how he plays chess you know
he has a very unorthodox style he has he
used to have these insane offbeat
openings he's gotten that under control
just a little bit and i think that's
served him very very well uh and he's
stabilized at high 2700s
but people really don't always think of
rapport as
having the same rating as some of these
top guys let's not forget he's 27.63
he's higher rated than sergey koryakin
for example
yeah incredible and well we see we go
down
uh here with the knights being exchanged
on
c6
is bishop three
the only move can bishop h4 be
considered
i think
well there is an idea so you can go
bishop g3 f4 you do have the move knight
e4 here but that's a
uh you know that could be easily paired
with bishop e7 and the bishop is trapped
so no bishop h4
another question is can you sacrifice
the pawn on f2 and you play bishop f4
i think the answer is no for several
reasons first of all i just don't see
where the compensation is
and second of all bishop f4 also walks
into e5 so it's it's bad for multiple
reasons no i think you have to play
bishop e3 and bishop
yeah is on the board already and uh
it looks like we're gonna see take
stakes in e7 yeah and um richard would
you say that he has just equalized here
completely i think he's got no target
and the thing that people have to
realize is when you look at this
position it's just again visually it
might seem like white is better where
does that intuition come from well i
think it's the fact that c6 looks like a
weaker pawn than e3
that's an illusion because c6 can be
very effectively defended with for
example a bishop on d7 or later on a
rook on ca
uh not to mention the fact that you
could push that cpan in perhaps another
set of circumstances
um and the second thing is that black's
bishop is temporarily not that good but
as i explained it can get into the game
very easily with e5 bishop e6
yeah and we see that oh richard didn't
play
no sorry no he did take i thought we
were already on the on the next move so
here is the moment where we expect king
e7 and um yeah just very impressive how
he handled
uh this position he's shaking his head
one which i'm not sure what that's about
but um
no he has every reason to be happy with
what he's uh got here
and um where do you want to go next
tanya
uh well let's see let's let's start by
going back to our to our bird's eye view
our beloved bird's eye view i think uh
yes the penguin on forest
they have a situation in which they
could repeat moves
um so let's stop back onto that game and
and let's see um whether andre goes for
the repetition or not
okay so
we were discussing that jordan
it's too that he's in trouble
but he's got some problems to solve
and the way that he went about solving
them after knight h4 he decided not to
take on f1 but instead to go rook g5
which invites uh a repetition i mean
andre could go back to f3 and then i
guess
jordan will have to
go back to f5
does white have alternatives to knight
f3 well you could build up the pressure
by playing a move like rook f2
and preparing to double
uh on the f-file the problem is that
there's bishop takes h3
and
you would have to sacrifice a pawn here
so
i don't know we'll see i mean let's have
a look at this uh pawn sacrifice because
the engine
is just
white it's winning knight f3 oh
that's a not actually a pawn sacrifice
zone again no because after london e5
h7 what king h2 and the bishop is all of
a sudden just trapped by the by its own
rook oh my goodness okay so this isn't
an option
for black nope and it and one more thing
if bishop f5 then all of a sudden queen
h4 and now the queen is
on e7 ends up being the the culprit
geez
so no you can't take on h3 not easy to
see by the way
um what you can do is get the queen
for example to d7 the point is that
knight g6 no longer comes with tempo
that's important
and if for kf1 you can now play the move
d5 which puts white in an
incredibly awkward situation you could
try knight g6 and that doesn't work it
almost leads to mate
but unfortunately at the end of this
line the knight on g6 is undefended if
only there was a pawn on h5
uh but there isn't so
it's also i think a tough spot for
frieza panko from a psychological point
of view because a couple of days ago
with the white pieces he could go
for a draw out of the opening against
aneesh he decided not to do that ended
up losing at the game and surely that's
got to be at the back of his mind now
yeah i mean he's
the thing is once you've
lost a game like that now you want to
get back and and so the next time you
have this dilemma perhaps you're even
more likely to to not take the draw
um you want to vindicate your approach
yeah i'm curious what do you predict
what is he do will we see a repetition
here or no what do you think i don't i
think he's gonna find a way to keep
playing whether it's something like king
h2 sort of just a neutral move getting
out of the
the x-ray or or rook f2 i think he's
going to make one of those moves and
he's going to make jordan jordan work
for it
interesting well
he has a decision on his hands now we'll
come back to it
um
do you want to update the indian clash
has anything let's do it happen there
yeah there there has been an interesting
development
um
okay so this is
this is interesting because prague has
gotten his queen to c4
and he's almost certainly going to
follow up with the movie for the rook is
hanging mm-hmm
eric is hanging and if if you go rook c1
prague's idea is to play a4 and he is
going to get his queen to b3 now
there is a very powerful defensive move
white can go queen e7
and the idea is to take the sting out of
the move queen b3 check you just drop
the king back to a1 a3 is protected and
if black tries to pile on the pressure
of the rook fc8
white chases away the queen just in time
with the move rook b2 and black's
initiative fizzles out he ends up
one pawn down perhaps even two pawns
down if white snaps off the pawn on
yeah so this doesn't look uh
good for for black so after
rook c1
is a4 is maybe not the problem with
queen b4 the problem queen b3 the
problem in this line or
um oh is the position already just
problematic for black
i think the positions already i i think
if you don't play a4
i mean what else can you play arc fca oh
no then there's rook d4 and the queen is
simply trapped you have to go for a
queen trade here
in fact rook d4 is a very serious
positional threat on top of discoveries
if if uh
well yeah and vida just has to realize
that he doesn't have to go rook b1 i
mean he can go rogue b1
and then king a1 but this is incredibly
awkward
and and he's got he's got to find the
move queen e7 if he sees that move
and he goes right c1 i'll tell you what
black is in serious danger here of not
having enough for the pawn
in fact black doesn't have enough for
the pawn and bit it just has to find a
couple more accurate moves
let's see if we can get a visual
on
on vidic or if someone is like
blocking the camera is he even at the
board does he sense his moment i'm sure
he does dania because he came to this
game incredibly well prepared and
he must have
looked at not this exact position but
that type of position before
that's exactly right and that's what
these players do when they prepare they
don't just try to memorize moves they
look at ideas and they talk more
generally about which types of positions
are favorable and which are not and i'm
sure that it has come across
a similar type of position and he
believes in his ability to
disarm
black's initiative which is really only
composed of the queen that's the only
attacker it's very very hard to succeed
uh in an attack that is conducted just
by the queen you know the queen alone
is often insufficient to cause serious
problems against the best defense and i
think this is a great example of that
yeah and with it well we'll see if he
plays rook c1 but
of course it it would be tough for
prague uh to to lose four in a row but
for witted on the other hand he is at
the very top well not the very top of
the standings but towards the the top
and a win for him would be absolutely uh
huge today we are back in the birds i
uh view and where shall we check in with
duboff and grandelia so
what do you think yep and i i will
mention as we do that that andre has
gone queen f3 so he
has found a way to keep the game going
not surprising and he's got the white
pieces he's not just going to give up an
easy draw
good stuff there
and here
this one
h4h5
no this is a little concerning for black
sorry did me interrupt you
yeah it's uh it's strange i mean
a few moves ago we thought that niels
had solved
all the opening problems after the
exchange on on d2 but
long castles and some h pawn pushes
later suddenly this
looks quite different again
yeah and i mean
dubois has done a fantastic job actually
creating creating play this decision to
play h4 and castling queenside it seems
to have paid off queen b6 now simply
queen e3 defending the pawn
neil's activating his rook
and you know i actually think that niels
maybe should have castled queenside
himself
i think he should have taken the
opportunity and gotten away from the
kingside the problem rick said he burns
his bridges now he can't castle
queenside because the rook has moved
he can only castle king cider stay in
the center
and
i think dubois should just go g4 i think
you should roll with it
and and try to get this pawn down the
board as quickly as he can before niels
is able to create
any significant uh counter play on the
queen side
and
this is unpleasant yeah and dubai
certainly not one who's going to
to shy away from an opportunity to to
throw
the g pawn up the board as well
and i'm curious
yeah yeah sorry go ahead no i'm
expecting g4 that's all i was going to
say yeah g4 and then the question is
what is nils gonna do i think castling
kingside surely must be completely out
of the question by now
yeah i mean castling king's side would
be like those oh and there it is there
it is it would be like those 18th
century games where
you know one of the players just almost
deliberately goes into an attack just to
let his opponent play a brilliancy that
was a pretty common practice
um when there were no stakes associated
with the games and
i'm shocked at the move rook c8 feel and
i'm going to be totally honest here
i'm
i'm at a loss to explain
you know why niels didn't didn't castle
queen said because now his king is stuck
in the center
and it's not like he has anything
clear going on on the queen side i mean
maybe knight a5 can be played but what
does this do this doesn't do anything it
doesn't threaten knight c4 and after g5
white is already crashing through on the
king's side i wouldn't say that black is
losing or anything like that and maybe
you should just escape with like maybe
we should go king d8 and try to castle
by hand that's not out of the question
either
i was funnily enough i was gonna ask you
about that but
once again that is just
so tough to do when you had the
opportunity to castle queenside and then
resign yourself to spend like what three
extra moves on getting the the king
there right it's tough it it might still
be fine for black actually though king
d8 i mean white can try to discourage
the evacuation by playing rook c1 but
i don't know what this accomplishes and
black is
able to get the king to ba perhaps why
ghost queen f4 and hits f7 i think white
is for choice
but for niels i think it's time to start
thinking about
uh moderating the damage and if you look
at his clock he's again
he's starting to slip
into time pressure
this is very reminiscent of of the game
yesterday fiona where he got off to a
great start
and took too long at one moment and and
made a couple of very questionable
decisions and i mean from the the camera
nils we can see that he is not happy
right now he realizes uh things have not
gone uh his way and
yeah it's just it's uh tough to to see a
player who is struggling
in their tournament and
today once again from a position with uh
which looks so comfortable to so quickly
suddenly find yourself having to answer
a lot of questions a tough spot here for
nils we will come back to this game and
at the other
five after a quick break so
dania they should stay with us and we'll
be back in just a few minutes absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
magnus crossing a quick draw with sergey
koyakin that's a nice way to clear all
the black black games
uh yeah
it's
quite all right considering the
tournament standings um i'm still gonna
be at least in the shared lead
after this and i got a couple of
couple of white games um
yeah i didn't really know what to to
expect today i thought
he would probably be um
relatively satisfied with the way the
last few rounds had gone but
uh and maybe not risk much but on the
other hand you know um
you could have almost caught up with uh
with the lead if you if it won so i
expected him to
at least have some
uh to try a little bit
i suspect he was a bit surprised by the
berlin since i haven't played that
recently
[Music]
and
maybe
he had some try there from from the
match because evidently they
prepared it
maybe had a couple of ideas that he
sort of didn't feel prepared to play
today uh and uh thus he just
decided to
call it a day early um it's always a
it's always a pity to miss a chance to
to fight against
a strong opponent but
yeah
tournament wise this is um
this is okay but
yeah you certainly don't want too many
of these
i want to ask you about the sensation of
the tournament so far which is uh arjun
arigazi in the challengers uh eight out
of nine
um do you have any comments on on his
play
yeah i don't think he's a sensational at
all he's gonna be 2700 very soon he's by
far the best player in the
um
in in the b group uh which we've seen
for for a while now uh both in
in in rapid and and blitz
[Music]
so uh i guess the only surprise is the
um the score he's winning with uh but uh
yeah he's by far the best
best player and he's um
uh he really uh plays chess in a way
that uh that i enjoy yeah can you can
you describe like what is his playing
store why is he so good and why do you
think he will make it to 2700 or higher
you can just sense it that he knows how
to play
both uh he has a good tactical tactical
eye and he can switch styles very easily
so yeah he's very strong yeah and then
um
what has been like your most favorite
game that you have seen so far in the in
vikings eight this year
um yeah that's uh
that's a good question um obviously
aryan
um
played uh played some
some nice games but uh
i'm gonna go with a a bit of a
scandinavian flair and i said that i
really enjoyed you know this game
yesterday against congolese that was
nice
okay well thank you so much thank you
[Music]
some very high praise there dania from
magnus uh for argenti who's leading the
challengers section with an absolutely
stunning score eight out of nine and
dania i remember in the early days
magnus he had some high praise
for a certain alien firouja um and well
we saw where that has
that has uh led
so
um what do you what is your what are
your thoughts actually i'm sure you have
played arjun plenty online what are your
thoughts on him
i've probably played him over a thousand
times across time controls online i've
never met him in person
the fact that he's below 2600 which is
he below 2600 he's a little over i think
and a little bit over still still still
very underrated he should be 26.50 i
mean
he is such a classy player and i mean
his positional sense is amazing
and as magnus
indicated he's got that universality of
a 2700 player he's got that ability to
play
really any type of position
um and you know a lot of people have
heard of him because of his performances
in the scc
but i think this is really the first
tournament where i i think a lot of fans
are realizing that he's got it
in classical chess as well so i'm very
impressed with archen uh and you know
how could one disagree with magnus he's
definitely gonna be over
yeah and very soon i mean in this
tournament alone he's gaining some some
nice rating points
already so i'm sure on his life rating
he must be over 26.50 already and yeah
next up
2700
and for now uh well we see that in the
the position we currently have on the
board niels has matched g4 with
queen b5 so not too much
to report here i guess
we're still
feeling very worrisome about neil's
position
like we be five is interesting as he
drops below 30 minutes i i suppose that
he is preparing knight v6 maybe
uh trying to go to c4a4 duboff taking
care of the queen side and going rook c1
um classic sort of play on both sides of
the board this also immobilizes the
knight on c6 it creates a pin
i still think as i said earlier i i
think that niels has to bite the bullet
it doesn't look pretty
but you've got to get that king over to
the queen side because if it gets stuck
in the center uh you know there's going
to be no more flights
the airport's going to get closed when
white goes g5 be no
in the center available we can go back a
few moves i think uh just after white
played queen e3 that was the moment
where you were saying you're so
surprised by neil's decision to play
roxy8 when he had the chance to cancel
queenside and get the king out of the
center
yeah and and
i'm sure he was aware of the possibility
of castling and i thought about this
during the break i think what he might
have been worried about is rook c1 and
rook c3
and this idea of getting the rook to b3
but if you look at this sort of very
concretely rook b3 is just not that
dangerous i mean the queen can
move on over to a6 and you know then
you're going to have knight a5 because
the c file is open any time white puts a
rook on c1 black is going to move the
knight away from c6 and offer a trade
now the interesting thing if we uh
circle back to the current position
is that so after rook c1 the the engine
proposes castling short believe it or
not i don't believe this and i think
this is a great example of
not over trusting the engine it was
saying equal at first
i i bet a silver dollar it's not equal
the point is that g5
is met with night before and all of a
sudden black develops counter play
against white's king based on
queen d3 check g takes h6 amazingly
black plays g takes h6
and if queen takes h6 then black takes
the rook
and if white takes back with the rook
then queen d3 and knight c2 comes at
exactly the right time and white's going
to have nothing more than a perpetual
there
i niels is not going to castle short i
mean if he castles short
everything i know about chess
you know will go up in flames
i mean it does look completely
uh insane to castle into white's uh porn
storm on the on the king's side
uh yeah i would be shocked i would be
absolutely shocked if niels does that
but who knows we will come back here
let's bring back the bird's eye view and
see what's been happening elsewhere
indeed well we have shanklin mamadiar
mamadiarov trading a pair of knights and
you know they've gotten the kind of
position we discussed where chakriar
has these two weaknesses on the queen
side that's really weighing him down and
he's got to be careful
um
vidit has adopted a defensive posture
that isn't entirely what we expected um
let's let's check into that game and
let's see what's going on there
sure so because i uh-huh no sorry go
ahead
no but it actually went rook c1 oh he
did want to go roxy one and now in this
position we were saying that queen e7
fiona is the best defensive move but he
dropped his knight back to b1
so a different way of defending the pawn
on a3
do you like this one less
and why yes
i like this one less i feel like it's
more passive
i think if we compare this you know so
what's the it's good to do direct
comparison in chess so why is queen e7
a better idea well a couple of things
first of all
uh here if black procrastinates with
queen b3 check then the queen will get
get back to b4
and obviously the queen trade is always
in white's favor white is just up upon
but the main reason is that after queen
b3 king a1 that knight is going to
remain on c3 and it's going to hold the
b5 pawn together and if black goes rook
fc8 as we discussed white is in time to
go
rook b2 and black is actually just in
big trouble here the queen doesn't have
any good spots
um knight b1 just seems like a more
passive version of
this type of line and after rook ac8
prague
keeps keeps the initiative going it's a
lot harder to get this queen out of b3
because if you play rook b2 here
well among other things fiona black can
just play rook takes c1 and get two
rooks for the queen and this position
looks
very unappealing for white white is just
too passive here so
i don't know
yeah this one
it looks like prague here
the in better shape then if the queen
were on e7 what i wonder is what should
fit it do now how should he meet rook c8
as white do you want to swap the rocks
um how do you go on about this
i mean i don't see what else you do i
don't think you should move the rook
away from the from the c file and just
uh sort of resign resign the battle over
the i guess you do resign the battle
over the c file by taking but at least
you simplify
and the sort of dania sorry can i
interrupt you for one second to let you
know that everything you thought you
knew about jessa has just come out
in flames
oh my god it castled
i can't believe it and i want to see
what do bob's face looks like right now
because
okay you know what what uh
i'll say in my defense
first of all duboff took like a minute
to write down that move
then he took his mask off and
i think he's as surprised as i am
did you see nils before we went to
dubrov like when dumas arrived at the
world neil sort of almost smiled like
half smiled at him
well i i think for nils he's like you
know i have 25 minutes
i'm i'm playing badly in the tournament
i might as well uh do something
interesting i might as well create some
fire on board and that is crazy that's
just mad and
i take my head off to nils
it is mad funny you should use that word
because i was looking into the chat
and listened uh this in drawings was
just saying he did it the absolute mad
land lad yo he is a mad light and
you can see duboff is definitely
surprised um
now
the fundamental question for white and
let's go back to that game we'll get to
the proud game later this is the the
pressing game right now
white could very well consider playing
a3 in order to prevent knight b4 and
then on the next move uh push g5
so that's one option
the other option is is to go g5 and
after knight before
to
to to make a move like rook g1
and and try to pile up on the g file but
keep the queen on e3 for defensive
purposes to stop queen e3 check right
but here black has to move rook c2 and
if g takes h6 there's actually a
brilliant tactical idea rook takes b2
check
after king takes b tune it's mate knight
d3
you can't go to a1 because of checkmate
on b2 and of king c2 there's check
gamed one
and oh check on c1 and knight for me
look at that line
that's incredible
wow did niels calculate everything here
probably not i mean he probably saw
rooksy two and just intuitively
concluded that that he's got enough
counter play here but
what an incredible decision and if this
pays off
this will be just a monumental
uh effort by meals
i mean it's
so crazy and to judge especially with so
little time on the clock
like i have to say for me i feel if i
were playing black it wouldn't even
enter my mind
to look at till it had castle in king's
side but i mean this is really gonna
become very very interesting we saw we
see that duboff uh well he's
uh
now he's calm down but he was definitely
very perplexed uh when he sat down at
the board and so
uh
king side
well i mean he's got an hour 12 that's
what what's going to hurt neil's in this
position now now that
things have gotten so sharp
i would imagine that duba might spend 20
30 minutes in this position he's got
that time to spend whereas niels has to
continue playing
very quickly well we'll keep an eye
on this position we'll see what do bob
decides will he go for g5 or
will he try to play prophylactically to
slow down black's counter play before
going g5
so let's go back to
vidit because i had just interrupted the
point you were trying to make no no
rightly so rightly so
so we see the rooks have come off and
queen f5 was played by vidit
yeah that's an understandable move he's
attacking the rook and of course rook c1
gets checkmated so queen f5 forces the
rook to stay on the eighth rank
uh
i wouldn't want to move the rook away
from c8 if i'm prague
can you def i mean i guess you can
defend it with queen c4
that looks like a pretty
uh interesting move and i guess at this
point uh black isn't really threatening
anything so vivid could take the
opportunity to
um
to improve the position and play f3
followed by e4 now i didn't want to
suggest in what i said previously that
white is not better i think if anyone is
better here it's white i don't think
black has sufficient compensation even
now i just think that this is
uh a more appetizing
version
uh when compared to
uh
when compared to uh queen e7 so
i don't know yeah what wise advantage is
yeah i'm a little bit confused about the
position actually that you showed on the
board there with um
with f3 appearing uh just as to how
black is planning to continue making
progress because uh right now well as
you pointed out the rook is tied to the
to the defense of the back rank and
black's pieces all kind of look nice but
i'm wondering
concretely wha what's next for black
yeah it's very interesting this knight
on b1 is a it is a good defensive piece
it's guarding a3
um
the
the engine suggests queen c7 and the
point of this move is just to say yeah
i'm going to retool my pieces i'm not
going to checkmate you in the next two
moves but at least i'm going to try to
untangle and you know the bottom line is
that white's king is going to be weak
for the rest of the game
at least until the queens come off
and so
and when that situation occurs it's very
difficult to convert
a material advantage because the more
you push your pawns the more
overextended you become
and you're always going to have to watch
all of these squares which is a giant
headache so i guess the point is just
that white has a hard time making
progress himself and black doesn't
really even need to do anything specific
so for example e4
maybe black just goes rookie 8 and stops
the e pawn from progressing any further
this is not glamorous fiona but it's it
can be a very effective way of defending
just sort of doing nothing and
and
waiting for white to overpress
could white okay i guess white first has
to deal with defending uh dh2 pawn now
that the queen is not tied to defending
the rook any longer
yeah you should you should go g3 i was
wondering as white could i try at some
point to try and use my my pawn majority
on the king side to push those pawns up
the board and
uh maybe also challenge the black king a
little
yeah i think that should be the the
general idea and so from that
perspective you could you could go g4
but black has the response rook e6 and
if you sort of blindly go h4 you get you
can get your queen trapped with g6 uh
that's a funny line
uh but yeah no in general i agree i
think that that should be why that's why
white's only plan really because how
else do you use your pawn majority
very interesting game here i'd be very
curious to to know how prague feels
about his position like
is he happy with the the slight pressure
he has or would he rather have his pawn
back at a different kind of i guess he
would always take white here nanya
yeah but
and i think he has gotten quincy for yes
he has kudos to prague this is an
important move this is an important
movie keeps his rook on the c file and
you know i think i think i would say
that a draw is is the likeliest outcome
here just because it's so hard to make
progress but we'll see uh there's a lot
fight you know this game could go in a
lot of different directions and it's
hard to predict at this at this exact
moment yeah and what's going to happen
we'll go back to the bird's eye view
like every day people are discussing the
prague mask situation i can confirm that
is by choice i think prague also in
previous events has always played
with the mask on so that is his choice
indeed
and tanya where should we go next yeah
there's a lot of games that have had
that have had developments um
by the way a3
uh was chosen by dubob and niels
immediately responding with knight to e7
preparing
to move the knight on over to f5
in the event that dubois goes g5 so
we'll return to that game once a few
more moves are made shall we have a look
at the shanglen game and see how
chakriar
is faring in his defensive task sure
let's go there
okay
i think shakur is doing
fantastic i i think he's on the road to
solving most of his problems
he's gone catch up yeah
yes 92 rookie 7 sam
goes knight
c3 okay
shakur immediately jumping out to e5 and
trading one pair of knights
and then he goes h5 creating some luft
and of course preparing
uh h4 h3 that's a very annoying idea
and this is the position on the board
knight chief iv is also an idea here
yeah i mean earlier at some point you
mentioned black
when black went through key five that
potentially there could be some attack
on the the king side and suddenly the
queen on b6 although it is on the the
other side of the board it is looking
directly down at the king on g1 also the
pawn on f2
and
it is white to move first but is black's
idea to throw in some knight g4 and
continue with the pressure on the king
side
i think baca's two main ideas the first
as you indicated is indeed to play
knight g4 the second is to play rook v8
let's
not fall asleep on the fact that white
also has a weakness on b3 that pawn
uh was always very hard to attack but
for the first time in the last couple of
moves it has become readily accessible
and the irony after rook b8 is that a5
and c7 are now
as safe as they have been
uh in the last couple of moves that rook
on e5 is such a hero for defending a5
and h5 it's stabilizing the whole
position and even though white does have
an x-ray against that rook there are no
discovered attacks i mean the knight
really doesn't have any good squares to
move to
i think sam you know this move knight c3
it might not have seemed like a
significant moment
but i wasn't sure that there was a need
to move the knight off of a4 that early
i think he might have underestimated the
effect of uh the night trade on on how
it helps black stabilize his position so
i think shock is doing well here and i
have another question if sam feels like
his uh advantage has vanished is there a
way for him to
immediately
sort of simplify the position
yeah i was thinking about that as well
i was briefly considering the move b4
but
if anything this move seems to do more
harm
than good i mean first of all black
could start with knight g4
uh and attack f2 and then after e3
there's an interesting try rook b8
and if you play rook takes a5 thinking
that that this leads to simplification
well no it doesn't okay fiber k5 and
queen takes a5 wins an entire
rook so
all three results are possible here this
does look very trash but
uh you know there's no way to peter this
out by force i think
yeah and i i mean i might have to take
back what i said about once again i mean
it's one of those games where a few
innocuous
looking moves happened and
suddenly um yeah
i mean you just said it don't three
results are possible an hour ago we
thought sam is playing for two results
it looked like there was no danger on
the horizon whatsoever but
um that's just what players like shahia
mahmoud yarov do
yeah i mean he's incredibly crafty and
and he's gritty you know he doesn't
he doesn't let his opponents do
what they want to do as we look at
chakri are adopting a very by now what
is an iconic iconic stance iconic
thinking posture
the finger on the
on the cheek
and that reminds me of the pinky you
kind of stick out when you're
uh you know
he reminds me of
drinking
what is it austin powers like where the
the bad guy what's his name
you know he puts this no
yeah exactly he does that no
i know it's been so many years since
i've seen that
i'm sure somebody in the chat can
confirm probably right
for now let's move on
uh from here but yeah
uh asking some serious questions
of
uh it's dr evil not doctor
dr noah is from james bond i think yeah
exactly
yep yeah that makes sense
or something
and
elsewhere
[Music]
what can we do you want to update the
fabiano report end game maybe sure
doctor eva
oh the evil bar yeah
well it can be the eval bar can can be
evil sometimes
for sure
okay well in this one uh we liked what
uh richard had done that we only left it
a couple of moves ago i believe after
king e7
yeah um the evo bar likes what fabi has
done so bishop e2 developing and richard
deciding to expand on the king side
which is you know
which is a reasonable approach knight a4
establishing blockade over the c5 square
making sure that black doesn't play c5
and h5
and fabi has just got knight c5 sticking
that knight onto a very nice square
and my guess is that richard is just
going to keep expanding he's going to go
h4
the we can wait for the evo bar to
stabilize the engine wanted fabi to go
h4
and essentially dry up
the king side like that
which which makes some sense i mean by
allowing black to play h4 you're really
giving black the opportunity to expand
quite significantly on the king side so
i'm anticipating the move h4 i still
think this is about equal i wouldn't i i
really don't think that knight c5 is a
mistake i just think that it's a
dynamically balanced end game
and ultimately i think a situation might
arise where you know where neither side
will be able to make progress
yeah richard uh once again i mean the
whole opening play was um
very i don't know even what the word
should be
kind of different like i think very
rapport like a different approach to
what we see but uh seems to to
absolutely be paying off
indeed well you seem to be a fan of it
so you can give me a full report later
no then yeah
that's not allowed i can't allow it
okay all right i take it back oh and
there there it is
oh my god
oh that was amazing
how did you
how did you like
vixen is working hard behind the scenes
while we are commentating here that is
that was first on twitter
it's genius you i'm more impressed of
you just noticing that straight off the
bat like that
that's amazing work by vic as well wow i
am surrounded by very impressed people
shout out to whoever did this on twitter
i mean the timing everything is just so
great
big needs a raise that's amazing
he didn't so he found it on twitter i
think somebody we should give a shout
out to whoever
it's on our chest so
okay okay okay so shout out
to whoever just.com did this
and then you think shakaria has seen
austin paris yeah maybe he's trying to
be the
the man
it would be mind-blowing if he's doing
that deliberately
mind games
okay let's move on from here
is dr evil
what do you think of that
oh my god
did you say did you say you wanted to go
what what did you ask
no i i was proposing a remake uh
remake austin mommy
no
as dr evil
shakur is too sweet he's he's got such a
such a a calm and and courteous demeanor
i don't think he'd be a good doctor evil
no i agree
um although he's not so nice on the on
the chessboard um nope and yeah we'll
see we'll see what happens
what happens there what happened we
updated
uh in a while
maybe anish geary against duda
yeah let's see whether anish has
turned on third geary
that was so bad that even i was just
disappointed as i was saying it yeah
your face spoiler spoiler alert he has
not uh gone into third
third gear or any gear he's actually not
better he's probably slightly worse
okay so
duda has just
infiltrated the d3 square with his rook
um we'll get to that move in a second
but let's see how this has all kind of
gone wrong for anish so
uh there's an interesting subtlety here
fiona where white has to decide which
rook to put on on d1 and i'm very
surprised
that anish went rook bd1 i thought that
rick hd1 is a lot more natural you know
to keep the other rook on an open file
and if black plays knight a5 as he did
in the game then after
the rook trade and knight d2 if you
compare
the rook on d1 versus the rook on h1
well there's no comparison the rook on
b1 can swing up to b5 and chase this
knight away
this very small subtlety i think
contributed to uh
the the progression of
of of the play so 95 92
uh duda starts to double on the d file
and fiona would you just love to have
the possibility of going rook b5 here
and chasing that knight away i would
and gary going rick b1 there's the case
in point he spends another tempo
bringing the rook back definitely a
mistake to go with the b rook f5
striking at the other side f3 doubling
geary is forced to defend passively and
after rook d3 rook c2 i don't think that
white is clearly worse but i think that
giri needs to be extremely careful here
gouda can continue
increasing the pressure with bishop f6
uh anish has to be has to be cautious
here that's for sure
yeah and i i wonder uh bishop f6
and then how do we is e4 already is some
kind of threat or what's uh yeah yeah i
mean let's say white plays rook b1
you could definitely consider an idea
like e4 f takes e4 and f4 this is a very
classic
classic type of idea where you push a
pawn
uh and then you push the other pawn
forward you don't take on e4
black has very definite compensation
here i mean then i can go to e5
so this is interesting uh but black can
also play it in a more calm way i mean
black and dropped the knight back to c6
it sort of has done its job on a5
i i like what dude is doing here another
idea for white is to play g4
trying to carve out the e4 square
unfortunately for for white this doesn't
seem to do much on account of g6 but
maybe you can take on on f5 and go rook
g1 and try to get counter play
uh oriented around the g5 pawn i
actually think that might be the best
approach for anish
and danya bishop f6 i think we'll come
back to this
game we're going to go on a quick break
and we'll be back with the remainder of
the action here in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round 10 here
at the tata steel chest tournament where
things are are heating up or in shocking
cold case
maybe they are
colding down what's the word pulling
down takes like a sip of water you know
what that means fiona right he's happy
with his position
we don't even have to look at the
position to know he's happy with it you
know who's not happy with this position
crazy
let's go to daniel duboff against neil
scrandelius just a few moves ago we saw
the incredible decision
um and incredible in the good signs from
niels to castle king's side
and
it looks like daniel was maybe thrown by
that move
incredible decision making by brendelius
um this is why people love watching him
play
uh and and daniel deciding on the slower
approach going a3 to stop knight before
i think he missed 97 and i think he got
frustrated here the point of 97 is to
meet the move g5 with of course knight
f5 and if you move the queen to f4 you
allow a potentially unpleasant check on
d3 i mean this remains incredibly
complicated uh and needs to be analyzed
black also has knight b6 knight a4 so
the knight on f5 is is an amazing
defensive piece and so danielle deciding
on an understandable movie goes knight
h4 which is of course
aimed against knight f5 but neil's
immediately activating his other knight
and i think what duba might have
overlooked is that after g5 h takes g5
queen takes g5
black plays knight a4 and
black is the one who delivers checkmate
i mean this is just crushing because if
white plays b3
boom
boom
boom right there isn't even much to
calculate here that queen on g5 is too
far away from the king
in order to lend its defensive powers
and if white plays b4 then queen d3
queen takes a3 is also checkmate
so with that in mind dubob is unable to
go g5 and he has to waste the tempo
on the move king a2 and if niels plays
knight c4
it's very clear fiona that he has
managed to strike first
i mean this is simply incredible uh
stuff
um from nils who do you think what are
the chances dania that nils is gonna get
his first win of the tournament here
i think he needs to play quickly though
he's got 19 minutes and he's got 20
moves to make that's the most concerning
thing for me not to sound like a broken
record but
you know i wouldn't overstate the case
here i think after knight c4 just to
illustrate why why is this that good for
black well the point is that if knight
takes c4 black plays dc and look at this
monster score look at that square on d5
and this is basically unthinkable for
weight for example g5
knight d5 queen g3
c3 is coming in with tremendous effect
this is crushing so the knight is
untouchable okay that means the queen
has to move where can it move well it
can't move to c3 it has to go to b3
offering a trade of queens which
i think niels should decline with a move
like queen a6 and if white moves the
knight away there is a very nasty rook
lift through c6 2b6 with the knight on
c4 like that fiona the attack uh reaches
very very dangerous proportions and
potentially decisive proportions if
dubob is not very careful i mean it's
really crazy to me how quickly
uh duboff's king which looked so safe a
few moves ago suddenly finds itself
in in quite serious trouble actually
trouble indeed and
one might wonder what niels is
contemplating here what are his other
candidate moves
i mean i guess he might be thinking
about knight a4 but this is
clearly a lot less dangerous for white
uh one of the reasons being just the
move b3 forces the knight back to b6 i
don't think black can afford to lose
this many tempe
i'm
a little bit surprised that niels is
taking as long as he is knight c4 is a
very natural move
and i've said that before and
you know he's proven me wrong uh in in
terms of castling but here i think he
really needs to make an effort
to keep some time on his clock
yeah so reminder we're on move 21 so and
niels he needs to make 20 moves and he
shouldn't spend too long here uh
hopefully knight c4 will be played soon
we'll come back here but what a
turnaround and what a game in general i
mean incredible
really crazy crazy stuff we'll come back
here let's go back to the bird's eye
view
and uh dania where do you want to to go
next i feel
good i'm giving myself a pat on the back
look at what's happening in giri duda
bishop f6 was played and anish going for
g4 i think he's going precisely for that
idea with g takes f5 and rook g1
attacking the g g5 pawn and distracting
black's attention i have a sense that
that game
it has the potential also to fizzle out
into some sort of a draw we'll keep an
eye on that and i'm reading in the chat
that prague has apparently blundered we
know that people take liberties with the
word blunder but let's go and see what's
what's happened
no but he's given up
well here's the thing he played queen c4
right
vidit responding with rook d4 and now it
appears that he had to go queen c1
in order
okay but here you have to meet rook
takes a four with a ridiculous move
now here's here's the idea you want to
go rook c2 right
you can't do it because you get
checkmated so
you might ask yourself well i need to
prepare rook c2 how do i go about doing
that it's not so easy because you can't
play g6 but you can do it with the move
king h8
and the idea is that after h3 rook c2
this is no longer effective due to
knight g8 but how easy is this to miss
i mean you have to say there's a
stunning move but yeah as you say very
easy to miss
and but prague
yeah he goes queen c7 and now after rook
takes a four he really has nothing to
show for
uh for the for the second pawn that he
sacrificed i think his idea
might be to swing this knight over to c5
but it's just
i mean i still think that black has
long-term compensation i don't think
white is winning or anywhere close to
that um i would push back against the
notion that
you know that that vidit is even close
to being winning here but
sacrificing coupons is a pretty steep
price to pay for
uh for the position that he has
yeah and um
you got a fancy village chances here
today both players uh
similar amounts of time left on the
clock we're also on move 28 already so
this shouldn't be so much of an issue
uh today that it has not captured the
pawn yet but um i guess i mean i guess
he will what else well there's
attempting move b6 um but
after queen c6
i was thinking about doing something
along this
along these lines but the queen can
always drop back to e8 and this only
serves to overextend white even further
on the queen side i think that it's
going to capture that pawn
so uh vidit is going to capture that
pawn most likely go up two pawns there
is still some play for uh prague but
you've got to fancy with its chances
today to rack up another win
let's go back to the bird's eye view and
see
um what else we haven't checked in with
yasipanko and jordan for a while
by the way neil's played knight c4 and
they're following the line we discussed
queen b3 queen a6
and uh
daniel dubov is in the lion's den now
we'll keep a close eye
on that game as it unfolds but yes i
agree let's stop in at the andre
esopenco hotel
take a look at what's happening there
and gendry yes panko well he decided
early on to play on and good on him
because
uh at least from when we drop back my
eye immediately goes to the bar and it
looks like the bar is liking and what
he's doing
yeah and i mean here's the thing jordan
if you remember he had to play this move
c5 in order to be able to develop his
bishop and he's kind of picked the price
for that these light squares are very
weak
and and it's unpleasant black's position
is just unpleasant white has king side
play this knight on h4 is poised and
ready to jump into one of these squares
at a moment's notice jordan tucking his
king away on h7 andre doing the same
thing just a little prophylaxis queen c7
back to e2
andre goes maybe vacating the f3 square
potentially and now he's doubled on the
f file white is
clearly better jordan
doesn't have a ton of time he's now
below 30 minutes
and andre is continues to assemble his
pieces on the on the king side and an
attack is definitely possible here my
question is okay let's say black play
something like b5
and you didn't hatch exactly he has just
made that move
oh you just played b5 okay great
um
how exactly does white continue on the
king side my guess is that
rook f8 can be contemplated by andre
and if you have a trade on f8 and black
tries to dislodge the rook with queen e7
after something like queen f3
man oh man is the kangan concerning
shape here i mean the rook is
threatening to move to a8 the knight can
still go to f5
i'm concerned about jordan's position
do you would you say that all of this
trouble stems basically from the
decision to take on f5 with
i would absolutely say that and i i
still can't explain it i just don't
understand
um because this move doesn't even really
have any virtues even if white doesn't
go queen before yeah you're going to go
i guess what jordan was saying is that
he's going to accelerate
the pace at which he doubles rooks i
think he missed queen before
and this is actually a very difficult
move to deal with and
you know the problems really started
around this moment i'm sure that he can
still equalize i'm sure the engine
in fact the engine indicates that rook
takes f1 was the best move here after
rook takes f1 queen d7 black is
ready
to play rook cafe and it does appear
that black is able to still
preserve near equality here but that's
not so easy to find you have to give
away the f file
um and that's how these issues begin
yeah
thinking this position and jordan
now
finding himself in a situation where
he's definitely
under uh pressure and it also andre
he is sensing
his chance uh today he's had a cut a
difficult few days of course with that
loss starting with the loss against um
against aneesh before the previous rest
day and today he will be looking to go
into
uh the next rest day on a rin rudder uh
rather than the last we'll come back
here and let's go back once again to the
bird's eye view and danya i'll let you
choose the the next game
we've got some action in as duboff and
he is thinking in the position after
knight c4 my guess is that he's going to
spend
quite a while
uh trying to figure something out let's
check back into theory again because uh
dania just to say that it hasn't taken
the pawn on a4
oh wow
so there was something about that line
that he didn't like i
really am kind of at a loss to figure
out what it was he's played g3
so he's played a pretty slow move and
maybe he's saying that the pawn on a4
isn't going anywhere it's actually not
so easy to defend it
so maybe that's his logic um in any case
we'll keep an eye on that game as well
um i wonder how prague is going to react
to that i want to stop in
at
the gyri duda game because that's kind
of heating up let's go there
and it's very likely that the position
the smoke will clear in just a couple of
moves so duda oh sorry gary going for g4
takes and rook g1 this is a very
powerful defensive idea striking at the
g5 pawn and duda responds with e4
now
giri's about to make a move i think it's
bishop takes g5 yes so what we're very
likely to see fiona is bishop takes rook
takes
now i think duda is going to play e3
and while this looks very intimidating
after something like knight b3 knight
takes c4
now this is not possible because of the
very powerful move rook d2 check this is
a very pretty tactic
knight takes c2e takes t2
now you stopped the pawn right nope
knight e3 check is devastating
but white has
either knight d4 in this position or
even the mover rook g8 forcing a trait
of rooks
now black doesn't want to take on g8
because then black is going to lose the
e5 the e3 pawn
black wants to play the move f4 here in
order to solidify that pawn
and the funny thing is that the engine
line is h4
95 to defend the rook
rook chief i have knight c4 with around
oh my gosh
crazy so one way or another this game is
likely to end in a draw i mean i was
wondering why is it giving all zeros in
this crazy looking position and there
comes the
very calm and collected move repetition
that's a crazy a crazy line but you
think very likely that we will see some
kind of simplification now which might
lead to quite a quick draw from here or
not yeah dude is definitely taking i i
guess he takes f3 is also a possibility
he takes and the knight takes c4 the
point being you i don't think you can
play rook takes f5 on account of the
fork on e3
uh but you know white can play a move
like h4 and i would say that this end
game looks quite balanced black has
a lot of piece activity but white does
have the outside passers so you know
it's it's hard to evaluate this with
scientific accuracy
um but as young schistoph ponders his
move
it seems to me that
neither player is going to stumble here
this is a pretty easy position to
calculate
let's go back once again to the bird's
eye view has something happened in the
fabi game because i'm reading in the
chat fabi
laundered upon question mark and there
were a couple of comments so let's go
let's go back there
let's um yes it appears that oh he
appears that he has walked into a tactic
breaking news alert in this position so
he's gone g4 to try to slow down
uh black spawns that's normal after 95
though he had to go rook h to g1 rook d4
is a blunder and it can be punished by
knight takes g4 fiona bishop takes g4
and now e5
right i'm confused isn't this so what's
the position on the board right now wait
what is the position yeah i think you
were going down the
line
and now i'm confused as well
no no no that i think the this is the
life position and reporter's just taking
on g4 no this is happening
wow this is happening and fabi has just
blundered bishop takes g4 he has
completely missed the intermediate move
e5 it attacks the rook the rook has to
move after f takes g4 black is on the
cusp of being winning not only is he up
upon fiona but look at that pawn mass on
the king side black is on the verge of
creating a passer with g3
and fabiano i mean when we tuned in he
just he looked pretty much straight at
the camera and i think fabiano is
someone that we can
we know well enough to to know when he
has i think it's clear yeah he has
missed it not just from the body
language but also the board tells a
story here which uh which is obvious
and how much trouble is it is it more
trouble than just a pawn because that
was
completely losing very scary what did
you say sorry well
i would say it's not completely lost i
mean white could go after the e pawn by
playing knight d3
um and the point is to meet king e6
with knight c5 check the king doesn't
really have a safe safe spot i mean if
it goes to the f file it walks into
another check so in this position
uh what black should probably do is just
completely orient himself toward the
idea of creating a passer so for
instance let's say you play bishop f5
then you give up another pawn
then you play bishop e4 forking the
knight in the rook white can defend
against that with a check but the idea
that i want to demonstrate in this
position and this is what's going to be
deadly
g3
h takes g3 h3 threatening h2 the rock
has to stop the pawn but just look at
this look at the fact that white is so
completely tied down to that pawn and
even though black is now down two pawns
well the engine evaluates this is
winning for black and i don't think
that's particularly surprising it's
really only a matter of time before
black doubles on the f file infiltrates
to f2 and promotes the pawn so i think
that with best play black should be
probably technically winning and the
other part about this is is to recover
from such a blunder is very difficult so
fabi has to make sure that he doesn't
tilt that he finds objectively the best
defense that's a shocking blunder and
it's the second one that fabi has made
this tournament not as extreme as rook
v6 but is still at this level
this is a shocking oversight
and i mean crazy stuff here and i was
just looking at the at the standings
richard report and five we are actually
currently both tied on a five
out of nine so uh richard rapport i mean
we sometimes it's strange like you said
it earlier i mean he's in the high 2700s
i feel sometimes he's a little
overlooked here
he hasn't had the best run for the last
um
for the last four games let's say he
drew the last three lost to magnus but
yeah he could be on the cusp of a big
big win against fabi who
um who's looking i was reading in the
chat someone said he is looking quite
distressed and
yeah i think it's just i don't know how
you explain it rook b6 as you say was of
course even more shocking uh but
something isn't quite going fabia's way
in this tournament
yeah it's just the board vision you know
the crisp opening preparation that we're
used to
the you know the energetic play it's
things just have not been clicking in
the way that he would have liked
in this turn and he might lose a second
game with a white pieces which for fabi
i mean
he virtually never loses with the white
pieces
at all and to lose two in the same
tournament is
is pretty shocking it's way too early to
talk about game losing
but
man oh man is this a is this a crazy
turn of events
yeah and today's round it started
somewhat slowly of course we had this
very quick draw between karjaking and
carlson but now things are are coming to
life and we see daniel duboff in the
bottom right corner he's still thinking
after
rook c6 he is
he
so he he played knight hf3 and
man roxy 6 threatens rook b6 and he is
still in big trouble i mean he's not
solving
these problems anytime soon
great stuff by niels
yeah absolutely we'll get back there uh
shortly
um
do you want to update with it against
prague
or maybe some against my medium because
i see a queen has landed on h3
i think we might see a repetition of
moves than sam amidjarov i i predict
that we will see a draw
now black threatens nigeria for white
has to go rook h4
and then i think mamidyarov simply plans
to return to e6
and then sam has nothing better than to
return to c4 i mean the rook on h4 is
terrible
it can be locked in with the knight on
g4 so the only real move here is rook c4
i guess sam is contemplating the move f3
but something tells me that this is just
a little bit of a too big of a risk to
take and although sam is thinking
i think ultimately he's going to go for
the repetition here i don't think he's
going to take any crazy risk yeah
because f3 of course you keep the game
uh going and i'm sure simon away
will be
a little bit disappointed if this were
to end in a repetition here he is
famously very hard on himself and he
must have sense that at some point in
today's game there was a little
something it did look uh quite
uncomfortable for shakira mahmudeer out
of the opening
yeah i know for sure sam sam is gonna
maybe be kicking himself for
uh allowing the night trade so early
but
you know for the time being he's still
still thinking i'm sure he's still
entertaining the prospect of going f3
but it's just that
you know black still has this weakness
on c7 but really other than that black's
pieces
are perfectly coordinated so there's
really no grounds to assume
that that white should be
better here at all
yeah so we'll keep an eye we'll see if
the repetition uh happens or if some
does decide to play on maybe with f3 are
there other other options as well
i don't see anything else because
because of the threat of knight g4 i
think this is a devastating threat yeah
so two options one could lead to a
repetition the other will keep the game
going we'll keep an eye see what sam
decides on and um
shall we go back maybe to the
indian clash or
what else
yeah and by the way caruana report we
see that bishop takes g4 e5 has happened
um
so they are following that line yeah
let's check that and andreas bango has
gone rook f8 in that game with jordan
van forest
as he continues to escalate the tension
on the king said okay let's go back to
the video prague game
uh where prague has just gone b6
freezing white spawn on b5
so we left this off just a move ago
after black's
after proximal queen c7 we were
expecting vivid to take on a4 he didn't
he went g3 instead and i'm just curious
if we just go back that half move
after g3 i guess there was no way to
hold on to to the pawn on a4 well there
was the move queen c1 which essentially
transposes to
queen c1 on the previous move g3 doesn't
make any significant changes but of
course if you didn't see this idea once
it's very unrealistic to expect that you
will suddenly find
uh the move king h8 so b6 is
understandable from that perspective
now you can still probably grab the pawn
uh but
and and i'm sure this is really good for
for white but i i still think prague
wants to reroute this knight c5 in fact
i think that's why he played p6 uh to
create that anchor anchor point for the
night
uh but your idea fiona of attacking on
the king side
i think is very effective here if white
goes h4
with the straightforward idea of g4 g5
this rook on d4 is doing a great job
just limiting the knight it's just
really not allowing the knight to move
anywhere and if you go 98 you walk into
rook d7 so
yeah not much that i can do here and
suddenly even that night that at first
we didn't like so much when it came to
b1 just because there was an option that
looked better and that night is doing
such a great job service
sheltering at the the white king all all
by itself
indeed and not only is it protecting a3
but it's also guarding the c3 square and
it's a very underrated way of defending
i mean the knight next to the king
is a tremendous defensive force it
guards all of the important squares
around the king
and this gives white the freedom to
uh
to focus on the other side of the board
without having to constantly attend
to to the king
yeah so we'll we'll see does with it go
for the the king side attack which looks
promising he is still thinking we'll
move on uh for now
uh bring back once again our overview
and
where do we go
yeah i mean do bob is still thinking
fabiano has indeed gone knight d3 going
after the e5 pawn that's
of course his best chance
as as we were discussing and gary duda
are also following the line that we
outlined fiona with
the black pawn on e3
um and a very very sharp end game but
one that is likely to fizzle out
nonetheless for sure everyone seems to
be thinking a lot to contemplate all
over the place maybe
maybe we update yesterday panko against
jordan
yeah sure so
[Music]
in in this position we were discussing
uh jordan's move b5 we proposed her cafe
which is what andre has played
and jordan continues to expand on the
queen side a4
ba-4ba-4 i guess jordan's idea is to oh
and sorry yeah sorry to interrupt you
but we did see
uh the repetition i think you were
highlighting in shankland mammadyaraf as
a draw is agreed and plenty to discuss
for these two players a very interesting
game
yeah short but but interesting um a lot
of positional subtleties there and
nuances uh this is a game that
definitely can be studied to get a
better appreciation for
you know for the role of pawn structure
and weak pawns in defining the game they
actually didn't end up repeating but um
i think queen h3 was accompanied by a
draw offer which sam accepted so they
both saw the repetition of course
they did indeed
so a draw agreed there that's our second
draw of the day after karjakin
against uh carlson but we expect some
blood to be shed
elsewhere
for sure and now we can return perhaps
to the as a penguin forest game
uh this is the position on the board and
i think the reason jordan has gotten
this pawn to a4 is to
clamp down on the b2 pawn now he can
reposition the queen to let's say b7 and
at the very least he's going to have
some counter play
in relation to that pawn and that is why
white can seriously consider playing the
move c4 as a prophylactic measure just
so that white doesn't have to worry
about this pawn constantly being weak
i think this makes a lot of sense
yeah and jordan
what do you mean how do you evaluate
andrei's
chances um to win this game
i would say it's probably somewhere
around 70 30. i still think that the
draw is a likelier outcome than a white
victory
but you know if you asked me after f
after jordan played f5 i would have told
you
you know 90 10.
and then the 10 being like
one of the sides wins because black
wasn't even worse
yeah it's crazy how how this position
has changed and jordan has just
made a move
or i mean it's it's andre's it's andre's
move right now oh wait after we take
safer yeah no
okay i'm just i guess he's writing down
he's writing something down i don't know
what it is
yeah
do you think no surely he didn't offer
a draw oh well we will move on from here
yeah shall we maybe take a closer look
at what's happening in uh
dub of grand delious and we've also had
some moves so let's go let's go there
absolutely because uh
oh they're repeating moves
they've just repeated moves once
and this is interesting is nils okay
dubob is definitely going for the
repetition he's got no choice
and for niels he's got 13 minutes for 14
moves
so what happened is queen b3
so queen b5 queen b3 queen a6 and qi
this is the repetition that they're
currently going for if niels is to
decline the repetition the way to do
that would be rook f to c8 black is a
hundred percent much better after rook
fca but the time pressure could play a
role in nielsen's decision
oh he's thinking about it yeah also of
course the confidence uh he's had a
rough tournament but i have a feeling he
will play on what do you think
yeah it's really hard to say i mean with
every passing minute it becomes less and
less likely because you know if he had
five minutes in this position i would
take the draw
and you're i think you're right on the
money fiona you mentioned confidence
that's how
having a bad tournament actually hurts
you you begin doubting your ability to
convert an advantage and you say well
maybe making a draw
uh going into the rest day isn't the
worst idea at least i won't lose
so you begin to convince yourself that
you shouldn't take any risks when
whereas normally niels
uh almost always tastes takes risks in
these kinds of positions
on the other hand there is of course
also
maybe the thought that okay i'm having a
bad tournament anyway like i don't want
to say it doesn't matter but it's like
i might as well try and get the the win
so there is that but yeah
i think the clock really is the main
main consideration
i think that's what what he should tell
himself is yeah there's nothing to lose
you know if i lose another game well
that doesn't really change anything
i think he's going to go rook fc8 i mean
it's such a natural move too it's it's
sort of asking to be played
although let's not sleep on the move g5
duboff still has
what could turn into a very nasty
kingside attack if if niels falls asleep
and you know allow something like that
it things could turn around very quickly
here as well so
let's have a look maybe yeah guys shall
we have a quick look at that line
yeah so what happens after rook fc well
if white doesn't react
there is a brilliant tactical shot here
knight takes e5
okay so if you take the knight then
black simply takes the rook and he's up
in exchange
and neil's
what did he do all right he did okay
good stuff which dubai
immediately responded with roxy through
was there ever any doubt but now what if
niels just sends his beep on down the
board b5
uh dubai was very disappointed at that
he was really hoping
for a draw of course
and
danya i think
we
maybe we'll take a quick break as the
the time control is coming up in an hour
but some very exciting stuff happening
here we'll be back to this game and the
others after a quick break so don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round 10 here at the
tata steel chest tournament we're one
hour away from the first time control
and things
are heating up let's start where we left
off dania with the game between daniel
dubov and nils gwandalius
indeed well niels in this position we
were
contemplating b5 which is
extremely nasty for white
but i was thinking that it's quite hard
to find a response to the move rook b3
and in time pressure neil's going for a
simpler continuation knight takes d2
which probably is objectively not as
good as
b5 but preserves a big advantage now the
point is this if you recapture with the
knight
then black blaze rook takes c3 and in
the end game
black not only wins a pawn but gets
you know infiltration to all of these
squares and d4 is really weak this is
very bad for white
but that might be the best that that
white can actually do i mean the
alternative
is to play queen takes a6 which
essentially just transposes i mean this
is the exact same position
and here's the amazing thing if you play
rook takes c6 first looks like white's
out of the woods but no there's knight
takes c6
and the
weakness of the pawn on d4 i mentioned
that in the opening and finally it comes
back to bite him
i mean it's such a tough spot for danny
luber for and the best you can do is
transpose into a an end game where your
pawn down do you think that end game uh
is lost or there is chances for duboff
to hold on there
yeah well i mean first we'll see what
dubois actually i mean queen takes oh he
plays queen takes c2
so he figures that
the best chance is to keep the queens on
the board this has to be lost rook takes
e3 bc
okay now niels also has eight and a half
minutes apparently the move rook c6 is
extremely strong here he already played
something it wasn't rook c6 what was it
okay that makes a lot of sense of course
and i guess now rook c6
[Music]
well you can go queen b5 check and
repeat moves once if if he wants to gain
time
but rook c6 is really asking to be
played for sure
for sure i see that our engine wants to
uh play rook c6 with the queen already
like with the queen on b5 what's what's
the difference
yeah that's a great question rook c6
here
i guess it allows something like queen
c2 and if you give a check
the king drops back to c1
and it has chances to escape via d2 now
this is still losing for white no
question about it
uh but by giving a check on b5 first you
are ensuring that the king will will
have to stay on the a file
uh because if it goes to c2 you can go
queen a4 check
force it back to the b file and now go
with c6 for b6 this is a better version
white's position totally collapses here
that is a a nice point um
yeah nils i think queen b5 would make
sense anyway because even if it's only
as you said to get closer uh to the the
40 move mark when he will get well the
players get an extra 15 minutes
uh we on move 30 so neil still has to
make
11 moves
and i think he must he must be
contemplating when is the best moment
for me to bring the rook to c6
i mean realistically
his clock is due bob's only hope because
the position is
the position is terrible and
you know with with just a couple of
accurate moves black should be able to
win this game the other thing to to
remember after queen b5 king a2 rook c6
it looks like white defends with rook b1
but it turns out that after queen c4
check white doesn't have a way to defend
everything if you go king a1 you drop c3
if you go rook b3 you walk into a pin
and after rook b6 queen c2 black
actually wins a minor piece rook takes
p3 and we need to check
lose pieces
drop
lpdo absolutely
okay so niels
is thinking
and he's reaching out and he gave us a
check yeah
very impressive and i think dubop is
going to go a2 i just don't see him
allowing king c2 queen a4 jack
and for i mean what a what a turnaround
really this game uh at some point later
on and it all started with meals finding
or not finding out playing the
incredible short castles and
from that moment from that moment on out
it was
all downhill for duba
yeah you know it's great to see players
rewarded for brave decisions um
we're not rooting for anyone in
particular but i like it when you know
someone makes a decision as gutsy as
niels and he's been doing that this
whole tournament and no matter who
you're a fan of it's it's hard not to
feel bad you know uh because of the
types of positions that he's gotten so
it would be great to see him
take one all the way to the end and and
you know to be do up with black is
uh no easy task that's for sure but now
he's given the check on c4 again
i think you might end up going rook c6
here i think the more human decision
is to play rook c6 here
even though it's not quite as good i
mean it's just
it's hard to figure out that you need to
get the king to a2 and only then play
rook c6 i'm only i'm danny i have to
admit i'm so terrible at counting
sometimes the three move you cannot
afford to go queen b5 one more time
right or can you
um no no it's not just you it's like
that's a common thing to accidentally
repeat i actually think you can no i
think you can so
one
yeah you can play it again
you can play it again but i think you'll
either go rook c6 another possibility is
to go knight c6 and try to use the
knight
uh and bring it all the way to a5 and
okay he's made a move yeah rook c6
has been his choice
and
does danya have a
a choice here with queen c2 and freeing
the the path for the king the only the
only way
yeah i guess you have to play queen c2
and another possibility here by the way
is to go knight c8
knight b6 knight a4 white is completely
lost even here i mean i just don't see
it
six and a half minutes is plenty of time
to find
you know these kinds of simple maneuvers
or simple tactical moves
and
he's not so far away from the time
control i mean it's move 32.
and niels uh well he's had a rough start
but it would be fantastic of course for
him uh if he can get a win here
especially against
especially with the black pieces um but
let's bring back the bird's eye view and
see what's been happening uh on the
other in the other games
first of all vidit has snapped off that
second pawn on a4 so um it took him a
while but ultimately couldn't avoid the
temptation
and
yeah prague has gotten his queen to c5
he's obviously much worse he doesn't
have enough comp for the two pawns
uh but there's plenty of fight left i i
saw some murmurs in the chat that um
that esopenko is now winning yeah i was
literally just gonna say that uh dubai
bar has skyrocketed let's go let's go
back there
oh and okay so
he has gone c4 and now jordan apparently
made a big mistake queen e7
queen f3 bishop g8
and it's funny it's one of those cases
where it's plus four but not because
there's a tactic it's just plus four
positionally takes takes queen f8 is the
correct approach essentially forcing a
queen trade
and if you think about it just look at
this position that rook is completely
dominated by the knight it has no way
back
uh and white's literally just going to
vacuum
all of the pawns up i mean starting with
the d6 pawn white's going to rick d8
rook takes c6 rook c6 rook takes c5 4k5
rook takes a4
and black is never going to be able to
get this rook back into the game so
maybe black
can actually avoid the queen trade with
queen a5 but this is obviously
desperation you're giving up d6 and
the knight is coming to have five
white should win this game
what was the mistake bishop g8
bishop g8 all right
apparently queen b8 was the best move
here queen b8 is just more incisive it
it forces white to decide what to do
with the rook and most probably andre
would have dropped back to f2
and then probably played against this g5
rook but at least this is playable for
black
i mean i was wrong i thought that jordan
would consolidate and it's actually gone
the opposite direction
and it's gone in the opposite direction
in a dramatic fashion i mean if
and he's about to
to take i think he has just captured on
d8 uh queen takes will be played as soon
as jordan is back
and yeah and then queen f8 is such a
strong move it just shows that you
understand the position
it's also i guess not
so hard to find or what would you say
yeah queen of fate is natural like once
you notice that the rook is dominated by
the knight as hess says this acid
banking game will be like pac-man
without blinky inky pink and clyde
chasing you yeah you're just eating up
all the uh all the little pieces on all
on your own you're the last man
remaining in the world
and
as long as andre notices that wait a
second you know the rook is
it's stuck on g5 queen f8 comes very
naturally because the only piece that's
capable of defending the weak pawns
is the black queen and without it that's
it the game is over
well what a i mean
suddenly everything really is bringing
to life here andrea cepenko on the the
verge of getting a winning position he
is super focused
um i think he said i mean i think he has
seen uh
seen this he's just double checking
maybe especially the line with queen a5
i i would be shocked if jordan went for
the the pack line the pack
the pacman line which is just too
depressing
um but he is in great shape andreas
dipenko let's bring back the bird's eye
view
now
the um gary duda game just took an
interesting turn 94
by anish let's have a look at that if
if that's okay i think i see i think
this is about to fizzle out into a draw
i think that we're about to have a mass
trade and a draw and here's how i think
it's going to happen and it's already
happening in fact
so
knight d4 was played slicing off the
connection between the two rocks if you
play knight takes d4
um then i guess after c takes d4 white
is going to emerge
upon up in the rook end game so instead
of that duda has taken on c3 with the
rook
and the point is that after takes takes
king takes e3 it looks like white is
white is doing well but black is a
concrete drawing idea and that is sort
of the sundial with the knight you keep
checking the king and the king is unable
to leave con you know to lose contact
with the knight i mean it can go here
uh but then rook takes c4 rook takes
that f4 is obviously also a draw and all
of that is already happening on the
board as well
and we'll see a handshake here in a
second
and i think that is the final rep
repetition
oh not yet
i mean
briefly contemplate king c2 but
he's going to go for the repetition
and i'm reading in the chat that things
also happening uh in the vivid game this
one here is it about
uh to to end in a draw
uh and i think well maybe we can stick
around
i don't know it feels like it will end
in a second but then no here we go there
it is
yeah king's d3 i mean king c2 is totally
useless i mean black is actually drawing
from a position of strength there
and jan
kristoff repeating
they're really dragging milking the end
of that game
yeah there's really nothing to calculate
here you have to go for it in there
there he goes an ish
okay
nope
what is he thinking about pink
exciting
is that it feels like we've had this
position
uh
so many times but i think we're almost
there now
we're almost there i think they're one
repetition away
duda is looking like okay i'm ready the
mask is already on he's ready to go home
tomorrow is a rest day this game will
end peacefully
um
as anish
and he's just thinking about
the previous moments in the game and
there we go handshake another draw and
that is our third result of the day
geary and duda making a draw yeah she's
going to be slightly disappointed maybe
but again drawing young shirts of duda
is never
an embarrassing or disappointing result
in the least
for sure and let's bring back the bird's
eye view because i think i read in the
chat that something was happening in
vidit's game or maybe we can just go
there straight away something is
happening in bits game now wait a minute
now wait a minute
this actually
has this been a turnaround the evo of
our shows black is being winning what
the holy smokes let's go back um
wow what a turnaround okay let's go back
first and see what
what did we miss
now wait a minute now we saw this
position right queen c5 black is down
two pawns but clear compensation against
white's king apparently the move here
was rook before which is understandable
right you have to defend the pawn but it
he decided to take the pawn on h6
and after queen takes b5 i think his
point
is
to play rook h4 but here
black gives a check on e5 and black
strikes first because if you move the
king up to a2 you simply get checkmated
roxy 2 queen b2 and knight c5 this
necessitates rook t4 but with the rook
gone from the h file black infiltrates
to c2 and then black threatens knight c5
followed by knight knight b3 as well as
queen e6 queen a2
i mean this is this is insane this is
absolutely
incredible and
i wonder what i was thinking i wonder
what fidet missed
i mean i i'm at a loss to say what he
missed maybe he simply missed queen e5
check just forgot the rook leaves 84
because here's the thing what if white
doesn't play rook h4 well if i doesn't
play rook h4 black threatens knight c5
knight b3
with absolutely devastating if a black
white just doesn't have any moves not
that i see maybe it's not as lost as the
ebola bar is initially showing
but this looks so dangerous and if queen
f4 for example knight c5 brook before an
ip3 check there's one more very
important detail it looks like white is
out of the woods here but no he is not
queenie to check
leads to immediate made very very pretty
made in construction
um and that is one of the reasons why
white
uh really can't stop knight c5 and and
knight b3 this is a potentially stunning
turnaround
and uh well prank he is still thinking
do you think there are other moves that
are
i don't see them i mean queen takes p5
is natural i mean in this case that move
is
pretty understandable you have to vacate
the c5 square for the night and while
you're at it you might as well take a
pawn i think prague is just double
checking he sees it he just can't
believe it yeah i was gonna say that as
well i think he needs to recover from
his surprise it's such a i think during
games especially when you play opponents
who uh are so strong and i'm sure he has
tremendous uh respect for videos
especially as they also
um and you understand you're under
pressure you're under pressure and
suddenly your pronoun plays a move and
you're like
what
like right what am i missing here what
am i missing yeah that's exactly what
you're saying
and yeah i think he will take he still
has 20 minutes on the clock we're
already on move 33 so um
only eight moves to go time shouldn't be
such a big issue here what a turnaround
i'm reading in the chat that daniel is
making a comeback let's go back there
let's see well um
yeah so daniel duo has managed
to get this into an end game where he
has
definite drawing chances uh where
what happened since the last moment so
rook a6 king b2
okay so we had a repetition and
apparently
knight c6 bringing the knight into the
attack was
decisive with the idea of 95 but niels
going for the queen trade which you
can't really blame him for that i mean
he's got no time
and he sees that in the event of this
end game he's playing risk-free he wins
the a3 pawn
and this certainly looks incredibly
nasty for white i don't know if white's
drawing chances outweigh black's winning
chances i don't think so
this looks
very very hard to defend because the
knight is still coming to c4 fiona and
black has an extra past fun
on a7 yeah so the good news for niels is
now making the move 40 won't be an issue
well they're almost there knight d2 was
in fact white's 40th move so niels only
has one move to make
but on the other hand the other one was
a crushing
attack while here there is still
plenty plenty of work to do
uh to get the full point and of course
and daniel has
definite survival chances
yeah no i mean and and i guess the point
of knight c6 i think what niels might
have been worried about is g5
and it's not so easy to coordinate
black's pieces correctly it's not like
there's maiden two or anything like that
you have to give you probably have to go
net a5 here
and if g takes h6
you go queen b5 check
king a2 and then knight c4 is mating and
if king c1 in this position
then there's knight b3 track king d1
takes a3 but finding all of this again
like three minutes on the clock
is not easy it's it's very disorienting
to have to
maneuver the knight and the queen and
the rook in the right way a lot of
moving parts
and look at
look at meals he's almost like talking
to himself i don't know he was muttering
something that needle is away from the
board i wonder if niels himself is in a
way a bit
uh disappointed with having to
i'm sure with more time he wouldn't have
gone for the end game
and here do you think he's calculating
lines what do you make of the
what he's doing what do you think that
is yeah i i think he might i think he
was expecting to deliver checkmate at
some point i mean once duboff
went queen d2 and he had that wide open
king i think
you know grindelius was already
he was already sensing sensing that
first win and now as he looks at this
position and realizes that you know he
has to win the game
not from scratch but
that he has to convert an advantage that
uh that may not be convertible you know
that's a very disappointing feeling and
the reason i say that is just because
white has all of the squares protected
duboff still has a nice space advantage
on the king side and
his pawn structure is fundamentally
sound and extremely solid this
might very well end in a draw and that
would be the ultimate disappointment for
nils yeah for duboff this must be such a
huge relief well we'll have plenty more
time now to come back
to this game so let's bring back the
bird's eye view as we see that prague
has indeed taken the pawn
on b5 and that one is completely turning
around i mean with it in a lost position
and the problem is there's not really
much he can do to to fight or to create
some tricks
not that i see him i mean maybe
again i wouldn't put too much
necessarily all of the stock into the
evo bar into the engine evolve but
the problem isn't it the point isn't
that the engine evolves in black's
favorite just that the queen on h6 is
totally removed
from the defense the knight is coming to
c5 black's ideas are very clear cut
unlike one could argue the dubai
grindelius game black's attack here
proceeds uh with forced moves and
there's just
nothing that i don't see what i can do i
mean the top engine move is a4 that's
incredibly ugly and that's saying a lot
oh queen c6 a knight c5
this does not look good yeah i mean if
rook h4 doesn't work which we have seen
it doesn't
and then queen h6 and you're also
wondering what's that queen doing there
of course it did pick up a pond but the
white pieces they were nicely
coordinated uh just a few moves ago and
suddenly um that white king is looking
in a world of trouble and the white
piece is uncoordinated and far away from
from the defense of the king
that's well put and also you know what
exacerbates this is 11 minutes for
forbidden so he doesn't have
much time to think of
think of defenses he's not
i mean you can kind of see the concern
on his face as he's starting it's
starting to dawn on him that there might
not be any defense here
and there isn't
and
what a huge huge huge win that would be
let's not call it over just yet right
but a prague he must be
i mean he always looks so calm but
surely inside uh the adrenaline must be
kicking in oh yeah
he i i can guarantee right now he's
sitting there he's praying that there's
no defense that his
uh conception of the position is
accurate and of course we know that it
is we know the truth but
put it yourself in practice he doesn't
know whether there's a defense or not i
you don't know the truth of the position
and
uh and so you get nervous but fitted now
down to ten and a half minutes i wonder
what he's going to find here can he find
any way
to complicate prague's task to make the
attack as practically difficult as
possible
that's what he is looking for for sure
and
he has gone a for
yeah that's a good move that's that's
the best that he can do at least it
forces prague to make a decision
although that decision is pretty easily
resolved the point is that you need to
keep access to one of these two squares
so that rook h4 can be met with queen f6
and that's why queen c6 is pretty
natural
so we'll see
probably going to take a little bit i
think he's going to try and use a little
bit of his time at every turn i don't
think we'll see any fast move by him uh
as he has plenty of time to reach the
time control so maybe we can go back
either to maybe touristy panko will run
for race
um well there's actually been no moves
oh nothing i'm still thinking yeah he's
taking about 15 minutes i want to say
deciding whether or not to play queen fa
queen f8 is the winning move uh no doubt
about that i think he's going to play it
i think what he's thinking about
is how to respond to a move like queen
85 how should white
uh extend the initiative and the engine
suggests the very cold-blooded rook f2
just stop the queen from infiltrating
2d2 but that's not the easiest move to
come up with
i also had the idea of going queen c8
not with the idea of rook f8 but after
queen d2
there is this move queen e1
and white is not in time black is in
time
to deliver perpetual checks or rook up
to is kind of a prophylactic move and
then you can prepare the infiltration to
the eighth rank so
we'll see
but andre down at 13 and a half minutes
for 10 moves that's not a ton of time
either yeah here this is one maybe the
only game where we'll have some sort of
time trouble action for now let's check
in with fabiano how is his quest going
we saw him lose upon an uncharacteristic
fashion
now material is even but those black
pawns still look pretty threatening
yeah so richard he
okay so let's see e5 rook two knight d3
he went for rook h6 this apparently was
very inaccurate
so he didn't go for this double pawn
sack line bishop f5 and king e6 that we
initially discussed can't really blame
him i mean coming up with the idea of
stacking e5 and c6
again very difficult so he went with h6
swinging the rook to e6 fabiano takes
the g4 pawn rookie four counter forking
the knight of the pawn
and we have a trait of rook so obviously
black is playing for a win and you know
that because black is the one who has
the potential to create an outside pass
also the bishop and in these wide open
positions is of course better than the
knight but fabi going g4
and is he's able to station his knight
on an outpost uh which is huge and now
he's inching his king closer to the king
side black for the time being hasn't
even created a passer i think fabi is
holding this together very nicely
yeah still some work to be done but this
is definitely looking better than some
of the lines we had analyzed earlier
dania we're going to go for a very quick
final break before the first time
control
so don't go anywhere and we'll be back
very shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
2010 when i played in the c group it was
uh fantastic i mean that was really the
first time for me that i played
you know on the same stage let's say as
all the top players and i had them so
close up and i could just go there and
watch their games and so on and for a
young boy of course it was fantastic
i do like to sit down with an actual
chessboard and analyze things and or at
least think about things but when i use
let's say technology or engines i try to
use the best ones
always
i think the next development we will see
this is a bit of a guess but i think
what they will try to do is because now
they are they are so incredibly strong
and so much stronger than all the humans
but rather what they will be
improving is uh to make them play more
like a human or make them play more
similar to how how the best humans play
so i think we will have a
shift to the engines working in that
direction rather than just pure you know
strength improving
this year of course and last year was a
little bit
strange because of the pandemic
we don't have this vibe in in the
village of the
let's say the festival i think we still
managed to keep some of that spirit
alive and but of course we are hoping
for
you know back to
to the old way soon
[Music]
let's indeed hope that we are back to
the old ways
soon and meanwhile needs he might be
kicking himself now that the time
control has been made and he realizes
this is not going to be an easy
uh conversion and danya how do you deal
especially nils
these players are so strong he
some of the time might go to considering
the chances that have gone by
yeah you almost always do that
especially when time control is reached
you have more time
now it's so hard to stop yourself from
from from dwelling from spending
sometimes even 15 minutes dwelling in
what could have been now
why is this end game
hard to win well i think he he could
start by playing b6 that's probably how
how black should start
because i mean you have to restrict the
knight
dubov is probably going to play f4 and
reinforce
his king side and it's just hard for
black to untangle the rook on a4 is
currently a little bit trapped if you go
rook c4 you could get your rook trap
broke a1 a5 knight t2 and you know
goodbye so black also has to be careful
here that's why i think you should move
your knight away first in order to have
this pathway
back towards c7 and here duboff could
create active counter play by playing
rook f1 and preparing f5
and yeah fiona i mean this this very
very strong king side
coupled with the fact that black black
is going to have a very hard time ever
pushing the a pawn past a4
makes this end game very difficult to
win
yeah so uh niels well he will try of
course this game i think is gonna go on
for quite a while
but definitely a big missed chance um
as duba fought valiantly to hold on and
now
well we are in this ending but we're
back in the bird's eye view we haven't
made the time control in other games
let's start with vidiq gujarati against
prime minister
yeah this is the key position right now
with five moves left until time controls
prague
uh has seven and a half minutes on the
clock and the move is knight c5 here for
sure you have to start with knight c5
and the bottom line is that black's
attack is just overwhelming so here's an
example
knight c5 rook c4
you actually don't want to play knight
b3 check which is incredibly tempting
but this end game is a lot less clear
than it might seem because don't forget
white has two pawns for the exchange and
with the king in the right place
white could go after
the the b6 pawn okay this position has
been reached vidit has gone
rook c4
and the best move here is to reposition
the rook to a8 rookie this to me
is the biggest roadblock if prague finds
rook a8 i think he wins the game but you
have to notice how strong that move
actually is rook a8 prepares b5 fiona
and it transitions the attack to the
right place to the a file
what about other moves like okay it
looks very strong what if your eye isn't
drawn there what if i uh i activate my
rook let's say via d8
yeah that's that's a viable option um
but it's just that i'm not sure where
exactly the rook is going i suppose you
could deploy it to d1
but but maybe why i can go rook before
and then get the queen involved via c4
the other move that i was thinking about
is is b5
but
apparently white can just drop the rook
back to c3 and after b takes a4 this is
what you don't want to allow you don't
want to allow white's rook and queen to
essentially coordinate and control a lot
of entry points to white's king that's
why rk8 is so strong because white
white's queen is still far removed from
the king side or i guess it's
technically the queen side but
from the area near white's king and so
you want to strike while you still have
a chance in the fastest possible way
yeah so rook a8 the most convincing the
reason i was asking about other moves is
sometimes here we have of course we see
the evaluation and then we only see the
top line so i always wonder when the top
line is so strong are there other moves
that sort of keep the advantage but it
looks like everything else we've looked
at is nowhere near uh as convincing so
this is really uh potentially the
decisive moment of the game
it's a missable move i mean to me b5 is
extremely tempting i could totally see
proc playing v5 here
um i couldn't see him go knight b i
don't think he's going to go knight b3 i
think he's going to recognize that the
end game is far from clear
but b5 attempting your move rook d8 also
you know definitely tempting but i'm
with you i think it just doesn't do much
and another move that i that i thought
about is queen d5 to threaten knight b3
check and again after rook c3
white is able to involve the queen but
that's very very easy to kind of
overlook or underestimate prague now
down at five and a half minutes he's
gonna have to make a decision very
shortly yeah
so five moves five minutes and rook
worker eight is the money move
um not an easy move to spot but on the
other hand it makes sense the rook the
king on a1 you want your pieces to get
closer to that that is the the target of
the position and from that sense it
doesn't uh it doesn't make sense to
align your work with the with the enemy
king
yeah yeah rook a8 and then b5 and after
rook a8 it's not that white can resign
yet but
it gets very very close to reaching that
point this is the game
deciding moment can prague find rook a8
i think he recognizes the importance of
this moment he's taking a while now and
he's making that investment he's telling
himself if i find the right move here i
think i can win the game so he notices
that but will he deliver on the move
itself
while we wait shall we very quickly
update uh what's been see has years well
we don't need to go there but yes panko
has found
a queen f8
but then yeah he has and the ordinance
shall we very quickly check
check in
yeah and actually this
seems to be
something has seemed to go wrong now
in this position
i think uh so so the key position is
here after bishop e6 andre went rook e2
to stop the queen from coming to
e1 but apparently
no knight f5 is not the move
it's funny because the engine
oh g4 apparently you have to play g4 and
fully restrict the rook gosh that's hard
to see and especially allows queen e1 oh
and knight g2 knight drops back to g2
chasing the way the queen and now you go
queen e8 followed by rook of fate with
unstoppable that's not easy and by the
way just to let the viewers know that
the camera that we've kept above is from
the prague game so
we will see when he when he makes a move
but that line was crazy dania
it was and after rookie two jordan
pounces on the opportunity he goes a
three takes takes and here's what i
think andre overlooked he was orienting
himself toward queen takes c6 but
there's this stunning tactical counter
blow bishop takes d3
and if dc4 or sorry bishop takes c4 and
if d takes c4 queen g3 check king h1
queen takes h4 and yes you know white is
up a pawn with some winning chances but
you know black is as alive as he's been
in the last
you know seven moves
so i i think andre might have to go for
this position i don't really see an
alternative
uh because black is black is attacking
the d3 pawn and if he takes it then
black has developed full counter play
against the king
and here actually the time situation
we're not out of the woods yet where uh
both players have around six minutes
left and we're only on move 33 and it's
not an easy uh position like there are
some positions where you can make some
easy quick moves reach the time control
but that's not the case here as so very
exciting stuff very quick look at karana
against report
maybe see if we had an update there and
then we can go back to pragnanda whose
time must be ticking down dangerously at
this point
yeah and it's the same type of situation
with uh kirwani he's got six minutes for
five months and it's still a very very
unpleasant very dangerous situation
i wouldn't be surprised if if he ends up
losing this game
as richard you can see him playing on
both sides of the board he's just played
a5 fully restricting white's pawns
basically stopping them from from moving
and keeping them on light squares where
they could be attacked by the bishop but
prague
has played my move which is
bad news
oh man
not necessarily
bad news for him and i mean my move is
the last move that i wanted him to make
for his own sake
and immediately we see the bar shoot
back up the other the other way
yeah but now vinida has to find a very
difficult move rook b4 is not intuitive
it's just not intuitive to
to voluntarily uh unpin the knight and
also walk into a fork
you just have you have to see that you
can just go back to c4 i mean this is
crazy no i don't think that it's gonna
play rook before if he does
you know major props to him but if you
don't play rook before what do you do i
was just gonna ask that also how much
trouble are you in if you don't play
rook b4 one of the reasons why we we
discarded rook d8 after i suggested it
is because
um yeah what what's the follow-up i i
like putting my work on on the open file
because in general that's a tempting
thing to do but are there any concrete
threats for black
well i guess yeah rook d1 is going to be
the follow-up and let me be very clear
also b5 is still a very dangerous idea i
could still see vietnam losing this game
in fact i think
uh from a practical standpoint rook d8
is not such a bad move i mean it
increases the pressure it puts white in
a very difficult spot and i just don't
see vinit playing rook before i feel
like rick c3
uh might be a more more human move but
now definitely prague is going to go
rook a8 and hit it where it hurts
so white just has a hard time finding a
single
move here i mean his pieces are kind of
stuck in molasses
and nine minutes for visited there are
four four moves to be uh left to be made
for either player
rook b4 of course would be a
really spectacular find by vidit um
it really would be
if you had to predict a result from this
moment on out what what do you think the
most likely result is
i mean i would still predict that
prague's winning chances outweigh
vidit's chances of saving the game not
be again vidit has proven himself and i
said that yesterday and i'm gonna prove
me wrong finding an amazing putting
together an amazing defense against
report in that end game the difference
is that this is not an end game this is
a middle game
and it concerns me that prague has
gotten himself down to two minutes
but vinits had eight and a half minutes
and when you're defending these types of
positions you need 30 40 minutes i mean
you just you just can't play quickly
because every move loses and you often
have to find a single accurate defense
i would say that prague still has
excellent winning chances in spite of
rook d a being objectively speaking a
mistake maybe a minute we'll go h4 or
something i mean i would i would at
least i i would probably go before i
know here's the problem you know what
black's best move is here
rookie eight
of course or k8 still wins but prague is
not going to do that he's probably going
to go rook d1
and now vinit can go h5 and this
actually becomes
quite a bit more unclear i'm thinking
that this might actually happen we'll
see
yeah i agree with you h4 seems like a
much more human choice than work before
well wit it still has eight minutes
that's very quickly bringing up the
bird's eye view and see especially in
the essepenko van forest game there's
been we've gone down that line uh where
jordan
is now upon down so andre with some uh
chances of course
but uh there was better how do you
evaluate the winning chances here with
the extra pawn
uh in jordan's game yeah by the way
vidid has gone rooksy too
vivid has gone rook c2 and he
but it's so tough when you've just gone
rook c8 when you've just gone from c8 to
d8
but
i guess the fact that the rook is not
defending the pawn any longer makes it
even more tempting
yeah now i think rook a8 is very human
because now you you see that it creates
a concrete thread of rook takes a four
and you play it
but prague now down a minute and a half
can he play it in
rapid fashion after rookie eight i think
vinit is planning to play rook a2 i
think he he saw her k8 and after rook a2
prague has to continue playing very
accurately and there's gonna be two or
three pivotal moves that he's going to
have to find
with less than a minute on his clock
here we go buckle in
can proc start by seeing rookie eight
he was getting ready to make
to make a move we don't see prague any
longer we only see that fateful work is
it gonna land on eight eight
under a minute
for a crucial four moves
here he goes 50 seconds
he's hovering over the queen actually oh
queen h1 maybe does he want queen h1
to me rookie it is pretty pretty natural
move although again of course i have the
benefit of the engine so it's almost
impossible
to really say what's human and what's
not
queen h1 indeed each one
okay so he's preparing rook d1 and now
vidit has the move queen c4
consolidating and bringing the queen
back into the defense the point is that
after rook d won
white parries the threat with queen b5
keeping the rook on the second rank for
defensive purposes this was another
mistake by prague
and if vidit finds queen c4 he is right
back in the thick of things
i mean this game really has what a crazy
there's so many chess funds in india and
they are really getting their money's
worth here today and i think also once
again it's so important in these
situations where we have the benefit of
the bar and it goes up and down so much
with every every move but remember these
players are sitting over the board the
situation is completely uh different
and um
anything could still happen here i mean
i'm not i'm not going to stop the chat
from cut from you know passing judgment
and
many people from thinking that these
players are actually terrible at chess
uh you know there's no there's nothing i
can do to change someone's mind but i
can try
and and it really is impossible
to when you when you see the engine move
it is impossible to actually
figure out how difficult or easy that
move is you or the contrary you always
are going to find a justification for
the engine move and you're gonna say
okay this move is clearly good because
it attacks a4 right so therefore prague
should find this move what you don't
realize is that for every one of those
moves there's three or four other moves
that are equally tempting you know that
those moves aren't correct but he
doesn't so it's so important to realize
that with that being said i think in
this specific position he should have
seen rka this is a mistake that i think
prague himself is going to be very angry
at himself about over the game the
previous move
zero blame rook a8 is such a hard move
to appreciate the strength of but here
you've got to see that the queen and the
king are so incredibly vulnerable and
the way to exploit them is through the a
file i just think he wasn't looking at
the a file i thought i think that he
just
was intended on putting the one yeah go
ahead after after queen h1 i saw frisky
frog in the chat say that knight a4 he
thought was a a threat here
so uh followed by rk8 i guess
so how does queen c4 stop that
yeah well it again queen c4 is also a
very difficult move for that reason you
have to see that queen c6 forces the
queen trade here
because if black screen moves away then
the a8 square is no longer protected and
you can take the knight
c6 wow another very hard detail to spot
it might not see that either
and
he's got let's not forget three moves to
make and he's got five minutes on his
clock
and queen
b4
okay but now isn't there knight takes a
four
yeah now there is knight takes a four
and he might want to just take the
knight on a4 and sacrifice his queen
does he have a chance that might happen
is the question no
he after knight takes a4 he has to take
it and then take a 8. but that resulting
position fiona i think is going to be a
lot closer to a draw
than to a black victory we'll cross that
bridge when we get there prague
currently with 30 seconds can he see
knight takes a four in time
i'm sure he will i'm sure that was one
of the ideas when he played queen h1 so
i expect knight day four
to be played but it is also tempting by
the way true very true
and 20 seconds for prague
1615 and night day for a day he goes
yup knight takes a four played good
stuff by prague
and yeah i mean rook a8 is now once
again a massive threat
vedic
is most likely going to take on a4 and
then take the rook on a8 and hope that
the rook and the knight and pawn
uh constitute sufficient material to
pull off the fortress
yeah it's gonna be a very interesting
endgame this one i feel with the black
beep
pass pawn there on the the queen side
and um
i mean i would i i love the queen still
right now i'm curious to you'll tell us
more when we get there first with it has
yet to make a move um
and wait he didn't take he didn't take
he went rookie two okay
but wait a minute okay eight rookie two
okay rick gt also makes a good deal of
sense i think he's still harboring
thoughts of winning this game i can
guarantee you
the reason he didn't take on a4 is
because he's still hopeful
that prague will somehow mess this up
which is understandable 20 seconds for
prague he's got to go rook a8 and then
meet rook 82 with b5 to support the
knight not an easy 40th move to find but
he hasn't gone to a8 once again
rook c8 and again i think bit it
probably has to go for the queen take
safe i think he has to bite the bullet
because now prague is threatening rook
c1
and knight c3 this just looks incredibly
dangerous fitted though with five
minutes to make his 40th move
so last move for both players i'm in
this game daniel's has been so so
intense between
the two players both of them are so many
fans so i think today it's been a tough
day for the the fans on the sidelines
yeah by the way rook c8 is not a bad
move it's probably just as good as
rookie eight i mean rook a8 is is far
from convincing after rook a2 this
position
is the engine recommendation but it's
hard to figure out why this is winning
for black i mean white has all of the
key squares protected i guess just the
point is that black is probably winning
this in the long run if he brings the
queen back but this is almost impossible
to establish with no time on the clock
yeah and
uh
as he said
probably he just has to take now on a4
we can have a look and see if we come up
with any alternatives but rook c1 looks
i mean again i just need to but i just
need to make it clear rookie it is not
obvious it's an obvious move but it's
not obvious what to do after rook a2
when prague looks at this with 10
seconds left he's like okay i have to
move the knight and then that allows a
rook trade
and i don't you know b5 is an incredibly
difficult engine move what about queen
takes b5 you have to see the move knight
c3 here the fact that rook takes a a it
allows queen takes a check so i really
need people to understand that this
stuff is incredibly hard and the only
thing i would fault prague for is not
finding rook a8 two moves ago every
other quote-unquote mistake by both
players has been the product of the
position being incredibly complex
i mean it's just incredible and for
vitid it's a tough spot he didn't want
to take only from the previous move i
think absolutely because of what you
were saying he has zero winning chances
once they go into this end game with the
rook and knight versus the queen but
here uh yeah there might just not be a
choice under three minutes now this is
vidit's final move before the time
control
this is his final movie he's going to
take all of his time
roxy it has been played and
he has to make this big decision does he
want to play queen takes a four he
probably knows that that gives him
excellent drawing chances in fact i
would go so far as to say that that
should end in a draw
um i don't i just don't see another move
i mean
too many threats i think he's going to
end up doing it but let's see he doesn't
look thrilled as he reaches out
and he is going for rook d8 he wants to
trade rooks and apparently
so the move here is queen all the way
back to a8
forcing rook the rook to come to a2 and
then once again this slow roll approach
of going b5 and going for the long-term
attack apparently that is the approach
prague has to take but he's got one more
move to make and he's got 20 seconds to
do it is he gonna find queen a8
he looks so stressed as well this is the
last move 10 seconds now four practices
he has to find this move there he goes
queen a8 wow
my goodness 50 moves have been made now
that it is going to go rook a2 because
it's forced
and then prague is going to go b5 that
stuff is natural
it's impossible to say how this game is
going to end
danya i don't know how to play it i'm
exhausted just from watching this oh
absolutely me too oh my goodness
and let's see elsewhere uh have we made
let's go to asapanko against the wine
for no
fabiano okay let's go to fabiano
it's it's winning black is completely
crushing and fabi is
going to lose this game most probably
shall we okay they have just made move
40 so we can check in there again very
soon and go into more detail let's just
see if jesse panko and jordan have made
the time control as we see it rejected
fabiano that's tough to watch they have
also made the time control the time
control has been reached everywhere um
and then yeah that leaves us that gives
us the chance
that's our breath
just a second
i know goodness
oh my goodness
that game i mean we really
do all deserve a rest day
after that we really do
we really do and so so do prague and
visit it
they do now maybe we have time to
quickly see how did report get his pawns
so far
and uh yeah as it looks that he is gonna
score a big big win with the black
pieces over fabiano carrana
yeah and you know there was a moment at
which i felt like fabi was making pretty
good progress and he really was rook d a
check
and and apparently i mean the the engine
doesn't like king e2 again this is ridic
i mean king c3 here is some is a move
that no human would ever want to play
how do you
how do you know to get the king away
from and the evil bars doing
cirque du soleil level acrobatics here
but after king e2 king f6 rapport brings
his king up fabi tries to
set up his his queen side pawns uh to
make them as invulnerable as possible we
saw rehard playing a5
and and see the problem for white is
just that fabio is kind of in zug's long
he just doesn't have any good improving
moves if he moves his rook away from g1
he allows g3 so he ends up going king e1
richard improves his position again and
now rook h8 defending the pawn
and here it comes you know i mentioned
this breakthrough
and it was really only a matter of time
before he would
uh put that into practice h takes g3 h3
and the pawn is unstoppable what kills
white here is the fact that the bishop
is going to inevitably land on e4 and
chase the rook away
so fabi ends up having to
allow this pawn to get to g3
and then the other pawn gets to h3
and we currently have this position on
the board
black can play c5 here that's the most
clinical move just stopping white from
playing b4
and white's
uh possible moves just evaporate here i
mean let's say a4
oh and then there's the move rook d8
beautiful
absolutely beautiful rook takes the
eight g takes h2 and the pawn is
unstoppable
this is something report of course is
going to see and if you move the rook
away the simplest win fiona is bishop f3
threatening checkmate forcing white to
take boom
now the king is on f2 it blocks the
rook's
pathway and you go h2 and make a queen
this is approximately i think how the
game is going to end i mean this is
beauty price material very
very beautiful finish uh on the cards
for report if he can find it but as
you're saying this is right up his alley
and he's got plenty of time we see at
the 25 seconds but as soon as that takes
down he will get an extra 50 minutes so
dania i think we are going to go on a
short break we all need it after that
insane action in vinigat against prague
four games still going we'll come back
to them uh in just a few minutes plenty
to play for don't go anywhere
welcome to the world rapid championships
from warsaw poland we're about to get
going magnus now forcing the king closer
yeah this is very very tricky for the
georgian player no and he bothers his
rook oh my god oh my god
and magnus wins the game and that was a
lesson in just pressure pressure
pressure
duda he has three pawns more than his
opponent duda has won three in a row he
is getting off to a fantastic start
gunina and castenu two players with a
perfect score they're going to be facing
each other kustenyuk once again has
turned it around and for the first time
in the game goonana is down on the clock
gunina is gonna have to resign what
initially looked like an amazing game
from her
magnus still has the threat on the pawn
there's the threat of rook f2 magnus was
actually very clever in how he just
avoided the trade and shiro has lost on
time so we have three players in first
place right now in the open section this
round is olivereza perugia and magnus
carlson i think magnus is going to wrap
this up really quickly the king moves
away from the czech magnus maneuvering
his knight to a superior position
and ali reza resigns the game the number
one and number two players in the world
right now and magnus calls him coming
out there victorious needing a win here
if he is to have a soul lead magnus just
simply retreating the king one step back
there's no stopping him from getting a
queen on the next move he's going to win
it and he's going to take the lead in
this tournament
carlson playing against the youngster
from uzbekistan abdusatorov has speaking
some really strong players in this
tournament and that makes me kind of
optimistic about his chances against
magnus here and magnus now is going to
give up another pawn
wow look at this for the second time
magnus is giving up pawns in order to
just get rid of them uh if there's a
check coming in here from oh my god
and magnus resigns abdu satoru takes the
lead after a win against the reigning
champion carlson will have the
opportunity to strike back with the
white pieces against napoleon chief
magnus is probably regretting this
knight cd5 now he's definitely forced to
be playing football he's not going to be
catching yon napong
that was surely a very disappointing
game with the white pieces it's the big
matchup of this round if casteniuk makes
a draw with the black pieces she will be
crowned world champion i would have to
give the edge to white in this position
because of the permanent nature of
black's king problem i agree that this
is an advantage for white
what they're it's over kastenyak is the
champion yes castaneux she had a
wonderful tournament a very convincing
first place with nine points alexandra
castaneux the new women's rapid world
champion nakamura facing off against
carlson we've been waiting for this
pairing and it couldn't have happened at
a better time when everything is on the
line magnus moved his rook and no longer
is trapping that king on the edge of the
board
yeah i mean rook a5 is a pretty good
move but also king g2 as you said
um and magnus gives it up it's a draw
and the rules of the event stipulate
that only the two players with the best
tiebreak score will be allowed to play
the playoff third place then the bronze
medal for carlson it is abdusatura
getting ready for the game he will be
facing jana pomnyachi of russia and
black's king doesn't manage to get back
to defend the pawn so yana pognachi is
steering this game towards a draw and
that means norderbeck is gonna have the
match ball with the white pieces in the
next one nepali getting rid of that last
black pawn norther back getting rid of
the white pawns the guys shake heads the
white king is trying to run away from
the checks the brook just keeps checking
in on that white king can the king get
away both players are down to just 10
seconds on the clock the king is finding
shelter on the side of the board now
he's returning to that checkmating idea
that irena identified earlier on and now
here comes the new queen the new queen
comes in and then he's going in for the
checkmate napoleon she will have to
anything resigns nor defect abductor is
the new rapid world champion wow this is
an amazing turn of events i mean what a
special moment that we're witnessing the
world rapids champion norderbeck abdu
saturo that is going to be a name to
remember for the future only 17 years
old and already a world champion
hello and welcome back to round 10 here
at the tata steel chess tournament and
as you can see three games have ended in
draws karjakin carlson giwida and
shankland mahmudirov but plenty to play
for in the four remaining games and
dania we just saw the craziest time
scramble between uh not so much time
scramble but the craziest series of move
maybe of this tournament as we just see
widget uh making his first move after
the time control there do you want to
start there or where would you like yeah
let's start there and just sort of i'll
try to explain why this position is
uh you know so bad for white in the long
run and what's important i mean this is
what what's so hard to evaluate when
you've got 30 seconds it's the fact that
black is not going to deliver mate in
the next two moves and probably not in
the next five moves but maybe in the
next 10 moves so prague should start by
playing b5 and anchoring this knight so
he doesn't have to worry about anything
happening down the eight file now rook
c1 is essentially the the
tactical danger to white's king is
coming from two different sources and
you can't stop both at the same time the
first source is the rook coming to c1
the second source is the long diagonal
black screen jumping out to d5 or to c6
and then delivering an incredibly deadly
check let's say on f6 or e5 and
on a on a general level white is just
white's defenses are over strained
there's no way to hold both at the same
time especially because the rook has to
stay tied down a2 it can never leave
um it's in hotel california
it's checked into a2 but it's there
forever
um as long as the queen remains on a8
so
a very hard judgment to make and
wow what a crazy
final five moves before the time control
and prague is just taking some time to
calm himself down
uh but i think he's playing b5 here
yeah i mean this game
uh
really it had it all ups downs i saw on
twitter during the break that especially
indian fans they don't know
how to feel who to cheer for
but prague right now after the time
control has been reached he's a huge
uh
favorite to get a big big win uh over
with it
yeah these 50 minutes will be used very
wisely i am sure he's just going to do
as much calculation as he can
um and you know if the time scramble
continued here i think that vidit would
have practical chances but
uh with all the with all of this extra
time i you know i just don't really see
him pulling this one off
yeah so well let's move on now there are
some other games we haven't checked in
with neil's for example for a long time
which earlier on was our main focus of
the day because that was crazy as well
um and maybe we can go back here to
where we left it off because not that
much has actually happened
and niels already has 20 minutes again
crazy
and he's pushed i mean so i i
recommended b6 here but he's taking a
different approach he went b5
knight a5 trying to get it to c4
so duba
goes 92 to prevent it and now b4
so
now a choice for daniel i mean he can
play c takes before
but after rook before king c3
oh yeah there's a very strong move
knight c6 here attacking d4 and white
has this very unfortunate dilemma either
give up the pawn or
allow a trade of rooks which is totally
unthinkable the knight end game
is losing so it turns out that white's
most resilient move for that reason is
actually c4
and here's the hilarious thing this
allows black to create
connected passers which in the end game
generally is quite deadly but in this
particular end game i suppose that white
can go after black's pawns with rook c8
and rock fade this might still be losing
though fiona this is very very close to
being lost for white
i mean i i would i sometimes i don't
even know
how you evaluate these rook endings i
think
would you agree that they are the kind
the hardest maybe to evaluate from a
distance
is this drawn or is this
losing i mean even even with engines
sometimes it's it's difficult to
uh to make the proper assessment
um
but
yeah i mean even if you take this
position
there's always going to be two or three
different options and they're all very
tempting you can go rook a3
and then a4
or you can go b3 and give up the b-pawn
we go after the d-pawn yeah which one do
you play
so it's a nightmare you know these end
games are awesome sorry daniel to
interrupt you we'll come back to that in
just a second but fabian's resigned fabi
has resigned uh so we didn't see any of
that
beauty quite up here on the
well twitch made its way to right
and he did go right the a no he'd ah he
did go rook t8 oh he did go rook d8 we
did get it in my apologies
what a
fantastic what a fantastic game and
finish for richard report and what a
huge
huge win for him today is a good day for
the players with the black pieces
rapport the first one to strike here uh
we have nils who still has chances we
have prague who is in an objectively
winning position so this could be a huge
day for the players with the black
pieces and sorry dania let's go back to
what you were saying about this weekend
and yeah you're absolutely a huge win
for re for richard and again beating
fabio with black is is just
massive and it really all came down to
that blunder although i would argue that
uh richard set a good tone for the game
earlier on it it seemed at the start
like fabi had a pleasant end game but i
thought richard played it very very
accurately
and by the time that fabby blundered he
was already under a good deal of
pressure so
um definitely very disappointing for
fabby going to the rest day
but um
for richard a very well deserved uh
victory and fantastic conversion it was
not easy to convert that extra pawn and
he did it with augusto okay
so shall we go back to the by the way do
what oh duboff has captured
duboff has captured him before i think
he missed knight c6
i think he has forgotten about knight c6
and knight c6 and
is that just that how do you defend
well let's have a look basically that's
six
i mean you have to defend the pawn yeah
do above is not going to give it away
i don't think dubois is going to give
the pawn away and the funny thing is
after rook c4 check
oh man after king d3 there's there's
this beautiful move knight takes d4
which wins the game on the spot wow
that's beautiful because
rook takes c4 there's d take c4 forces a
transition into a pawn end game with an
outside passer
but
okay why you can play king b2 to
circumvent that but i am positive
that even if black just plays a5 here
this end game is completely winning and
it's like a b6 it's ironic that niels
this time is on the winning side uh we
we just took some time to explain i mean
neil's fabulous that's just yesterday
i'm losing track of time that was just
yesterday yeah that was just yesterday
that's how much just happened
it feels crazy
so niels there was on the the losing end
of an ending where fabi had the outside
past the pawn extra pawn and we spent a
lot of time explaining why that is last
but today
he is on the on the winning side and he
i think has seen knight c6 he's look so
he looked a little bit surprised at
first but uh yeah
so let's show once again sorry we can
see if daniel defends the the pawn
maybe with
is knight f3 a better try
yeah it's possible there's also king d3
by the way um to to give up the pawn and
then garuxy and roxy but i want to look
at your move knight f3
um
well i still think that if black trades
rooks rook c4 tracking me too
this has to be winning one approach that
black could take here is to play f6
i mean essentially this force is a trade
and now black has the possibility at a
moment's notice to create a second
passer with with e5 or even to open up
the king side with f5 so
i mean these end games are almost always
losing one's with an outside passer
even you know even with the presence of
knights it doesn't change all that much
yeah so here knight
you're saying you think knight c6 was
simply missed by daniel otherwise he
would never go king c3 well or or maybe
he had king d3 in mind i mean this is an
idea that
i could plausibly see him
uh falling for
but
the knight simply moves away i mean this
is really easy knight p f5 brook takes
f7 rook takes g4 and black preserves
his full material advantage black is up
two pawns and
you know rookie seven ninety four
temporarily giving away one of the pawns
but now you win it back again with
knight knight c6 i mean these lines are
are composed of
uh simple tactics that niels niels will
see even in significant time pressure
which he's digging himself into very
rapidly by the way he's down to 16
minutes yeah he really needs to start
picking
picking up pace here knight c6
there is the good thing about knight c6
is there isn't
there aren't so many at least there
you're not in trouble right to
to lose something there are no tactics
um where the knight can be dislodged and
your rook could be in trouble right
right
no no the only the way that would happen
is if black played brook takes d4 here
um and yeah that would be very bad on
account of kingpin not losing black
could still bail out with rook takes d2
but
obviously not what he would be looking
for
and so for that reason i'm a little bit
surprised at how long
niels has taken here but
i mean neil says
has been on top all game long so
he just wants to make sure he doesn't
give away
you know the game for a second time i
think he senses that
he missed the win in the middle game and
the worst thing is to miss a win in the
middle game and then squander it again
in the end game
and there he goes
yeah knight c6 has been played and we're
going to go to an interview with robert
reports you just beat fabiano caruana
with the black pieces um sounds like a
big game for you yeah certainly this is
a new new feeling i think this is my
first uh classical win against him um i
didn't have something i still don't have
such a good score actually plus okay
he's a
an extremely strong player but also a
very nice guy and i'm with feeling sad
that i with him today with a bit of luck
um where did it uh what were the key
moments in the game today uh yeah so he
surprised me with his first move already
i went for some things that i've checked
during throughout the event
for some other game
um
yeah this knight h6 i think was played
according to my knowledge at least once
uh in some online online game
uh i think uh
yeah and it was bishop d2 i think in
that game and he went it takes the six
queen g5 which was uh i mean okay i
didn't expect this line so i don't know
if i have checked it or not but i didn't
remember
so we went for this end game and it was
very concrete with 95 knight f7
attacking rc6
should be 3 fe3 very strange position
and there are not so many pieces on the
board but somehow the position is uh
you know so weird that he's having a
huge position advantage on the queen
side i have the same on the king side uh
during the game i felt like okay
maybe somewhat unpleasant but then when
he allowed
my pawns to advance on the king side i i
got some
invisible at least counterplay and then
he just um yeah he just blunt i mean i
think this g4 was already kind of
dubious but after 95 he just blundered
through d490 ng4 bishop g45
uh yeah and then yeah he lost like the
pawn on g4
and it was such a massive block there
yeah and then after that i suddenly
wasn't sure what to do i mean of course
i'm clearly uh
the one who's playing for a window but
still uh like he played his 93 and i
played rook h6 i don't know if it's a
good move or not i just didn't see clear
uh you know
way to convert every time his knight is
on time or his question pounds or has
some counterplay so i tried to go for
something which is relatively one-sided
and uh when he took on e5 and rookie 69
g4 he kind of gave me that i'm not sure
if you know i am
serious how much better i am but he's
completely one-sided game so maybe he
shouldn't shouldn't have done that i
thought maybe e4 was better instead of
95 or just something to to hold the
position for for a bit more
and yeah and after that i think he just
started to miss a couple of things um
like after bishop v6 rook g1 i think
it's just a blunder rook of fate and he
has to move with the knight
and things like this and suddenly okay
we are kind of short on time and i have
this uh tactical ideas with g3 all the
time i mean this upon g4 h4 and uh
bishop before which we have three
threats so he was kind of in a minute
song and um
yeah i exploited this that he was sure
on time and the position was really um
tricky let's put it this way
um
yeah i forget a good start of the
tournament um and then you lost to
magnus a couple of draws now you're back
at plus two i believe
yeah i mean i had a good start if you
can call losing in the first game a good
start yeah yeah yeah so i had a let's
let's put this film the first uh half of
the tournament or quarter of the
tournament was much more
you know up and down than um than this
one right so i won at one point i was on
plus two yeah i lost to magnus um
uh this catalan yeah of course uh i had
my chances in that game to to make a
draw but obviously i i didn't use them
well and after that i had some okay some
exciting game against uh
and some not so exciting game against
sergey and then
i had this game yesterday with vidiq
which i felt like okay it was a huge
position out of the opening and i had
some chances afterwards but i misplayed
it in the time travel phrase and uh it
was just um yeah like in in that game we
had like this opposite color bishop
ending
um
did you check it afterwards like was
there a chance to win no i mean i don't
it was very strange you know because i
saw it immediately i draw of course if
he goes like with g5 at any time
after mu 40 and he's thinking forever
like he can play g5 immediately or
bishop g2f or g5 is just uh that draw
and then he didn't see this idea for
some reason and he went for this um what
he did yeah which is uh okay a much more
creative but also a much more difficult
way to defense but i think uh sadly for
me it wasn't i was never on time because
he has this idea of his h4gh which i
paid for which is really funny yeah
because you know he's thinking so much
and uh instead he goes for something
which is requiring some skill so i
figure maybe i have some practical
chances but objectively i think it was
just um it was just a drawing
um rest day coming up three more rounds
um is there enough firing you with
enough energy for the next three runs
yeah we'll just uh we'll just see after
the rest of the year
okay i wish you all the best
always a pleasure to hear from richard
to report his first
uh classical win he is saying against
fabiano
and it's so nice to see the the
compassion really lovely lovely guy
absolutely and you know he's still very
very young but he's been
over 2700 for many years now again
somebody that people kind of tend to
sleep on when they think of top super
gms but he is such an entertaining
player
and it's interesting he seemed to think
that uh the end game yesterday was was a
dead draw so
uh that's that's pretty interesting to
me because i thought that uh you know we
thought that he was closer to winning to
a drop but he's analyzed that he's right
and um
still a great game today by airport
beating fabiana he's going to be feeling
real good tomorrow during the rest day
absolutely elsewhere other games have
ended peacefully so far
but the two players are pushing very
much uh with the black pieces as well
pragnanda against vidit and jordan went
for race uh no sorry niels quindalius
against daniel dubov
jordan isn't pressing his defending will
go to his defensive effort well maybe
even right away
yeah let's check it out um and see if
he's on the path to making a draw i
think he actually is and that would be a
tremendous comeback by jordan if he is
able to pull it off so we have this
position on the board right now
he's attacking the e4 pawn it appears to
me
that white has to start by giving a
check on f5
and then black is going to cover with
the rook this is jordan's idea the rook
on c2 is hanging and if you move it to
f2
well black could throw in a check on g3
just to push the king away
and now apparently the move queen e3
is the most accurate it basically
preserves the ability to do all sorts of
stuff to give a check
on c1 or e1 and it also simply attacks
the pawn
and i don't see a good way to defend the
pawn if you push c6 black is going to
pick it up like this white is going to
take e5 but this position with all the
pawns on one side of the board fiona is
is basically a dead draw
it also looks like the white king is
just never going to be quite safe enough
yes with the black rook and queen
working together very well
yeah i don't see this happening for
andre and really the pivotal moment just
to remind everybody there was apparently
a very difficult win with the move g4
forcing the rook out of commission
and you had to allow queen e1 and
recognize that the knight can drop back
to g2
and ultimately the idea is to play queen
fa queen eight for cafe but andre uh
deciding to go for a prophylactic
approach going rookie two and jordan
very very well done spotting this
brilliant tactical defensive idea of
taking on c4
and swinging the queen over to g3 to
pick up the knight
and that is how this type of position
was reached they actually have made a
bunch of moves
in this type of material and balance
okay so ultimately
this is what they have on the board
right now plenty of time i'm imagining
that uh both espanol and force are going
to be taking oodles of time on every
move here as they try to be as accurate
as possible
a very resilient defense firm jordan uh
indeed let's go back to maybe the indian
clash with it and pregnant or we could
bring up the bird's eye view actually
and see yeah let's bring up the bird's
eye view because in the
bitter game so b5 has been played and
vivid has responded with queen b4 which
is
uh sort of very understandable very
natural
and uh one thing that surprises me is
how duba grindelius has unfolded if we
could maybe stop at that game for a
second and then come back to the vidic
game for sure uh because what what's
happened here is that
um
niels
okay so in response to rook c7 i thought
that knight b5 was the cleanest in order
to
uh take the g4 pawn but nils going for a
more
um
killer approach he goes a5 straight away
and now after rook takes f7 i think he
just wants to push his pawn and make a
new queen
now he goes knight c6 this is very very
accurate attacking e5 he forces f4
what is the secondary point of putting
the knight on c6 it is to stop the white
rook from coming to a7 after a4 i think
white stays our numbered fiona because i
just don't see a way to stop the spawn
yeah and well you said
allowing black to capture the pawn on e5
was also not an option so duboff has
gone uh f4 and
uh yeah a4 and how do you stop that
black pawn
you have only one way you have to go
rook c7 and then you have to
swing the rock from c8 to a8 but the
thing is white
black could still push the pawn all the
way to a2 using the fork as an indirect
defense
okay and if white moves the king for
example to e3 yeah knight before ends
the game it threatens rook a6 it
threatens knight c2
so and also rook c6 and rook c1 there's
too many pathways too many ways
uh to pry white's pieces away from the
ledge dubov
uh is
going down this line f4 a4 has been
played
uh it appears that niels is right on the
cusp of winning
his
uh and i have to say this win of the
tournament mm-hmm sorry
is this his first win yeah yeah yeah so
nils is i think on two
two points two out of nine going into
this round sorry i interrupted you yeah
no no i was gonna say i was gonna come
to that exact same point that i think
means really has had such a tough
tournament and um i'm very happy for him
of course it's not a secret he's a great
friend of mine of course we're trying to
be
unbiased here but i'm
very happy we see the standings here so
going into the round he wasn't two out
of nine and i was worth four drawers he
had five losses so really a tough event
and uh i think getting a win is for sure
going to um lift his spirits and um
i think also vik is a tournament where
it's tough to to get wins there still a
fair few players
in the field who haven't uh haven't
scored a win
indeed and as we have a quick look at
the updated stan are you telling me that
you're friends with one of the
participants i think that disqualifies
you as a commentator that is
that is too much now that is just i mean
had i known about this beforehand you
know
this represents a serious problem
this might be a problem it should have
shut my mouth but whoopsie
um yeah so so magnus is still still
going to be in front by half a point but
what's the most important game of the
game still remaining it's probably bit
it's game because if bit it at least
pulls out a draw
he brings himself to six out of ten and
at least he's still going to be pretty
much in contention
yeah so let's check in there um
i'm not so curious on the clock
situation but it's good to see that none
of them have
dropped too far down so often we see
this they make the time control and then
half an hour is invested but that hasn't
been the case yeah at least not yet
right so queen b4 has been played now
black would ideally love to play rook c1
um but unfortunately for prague he can't
do it right now because white can take
b5 what he can do
is essentially do the same thing with
the queen and go queen h1 he just has
now queen takes oh he just played it and
queen takes b5 can be met with knight c3
which is crushing
yeah vidit is in huge trouble good luck
wants to play rook c1 and knight c3 and
just that just looks killer
man man man
yeah what do you and
i mean uh the prague before the time
control there were certain missed
opportunities but after move 40 has been
uh reached every move i think has been
pretty much the the best move here
so far so good for prague and okay so
after queen h1 rook a3 is the engine
recommendation to prevent knight c3 and
now
i'm thinking that queen takes h2 is a
possibility this is a really cute line
if queen takes v5
[Music]
always a lovely move to play check
check you win the queen but that's not
the end of the story you also win the
night at the end which is no less
crucial and you win the game that's some
beautiful full board vision right there
yeah prague's gonna see and i think
something like that is likely to happen
um i don't see what vidit can do other
than rook a3 because
the threat is you know rooksy one knight
c3 knight c3 is also a threat because if
the rook leaves the a file
uh prague's favorite mover a check is
maybe ultimately going to going to win
him the game we'll see
they'll visit in very dire straits here
and we are gonna go on a very short
break i know it hasn't been so long but
it's the day before the rest day which
means uh it is testing it is testing day
here on site and i've just gone for mine
on the previous break but vic will send
him off now to get tested as well and
we'll be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my first memory would be being here with
my grandfather and my little brother
playing here for the very first time i
was playing in the amateur sections and
really desperately trying to get a look
at
the two players playing
so my best memory would have to be
definitely
while winning here last year without
question
a couple of years ago we started getting
neural network chess engines
into the into the
jazz world and they really changed the
game
the way we see the game
very differently and it has improved our
understanding of the game immensely so
it's a very interesting development and
the way they play chess is really
magnificent so it's it's very nice
i have a chess board at home so i like
to bring a chessboard to my tournaments
but
90 of the work i think does take place
on my laptop and using technology
i always think that like the engines we
currently have they're like the
strongest
there can ever be but they keep on
getting stronger so who knows
what's uh going to come in the future
i've basically played in all of the
groups and indeed that
just coming here as a kid and now
playing on the highest stage is of
course very special to me
[Music]
always nice to hear from jordan but
he has not gone queen g3 dania and
instead it looks like uh queen c3 is a
big blunder
yeah he lost his patience here and what
what he has allowed is the move rook f3
which of course andre will play and of
course jordan saw this now my hypothesis
is that jordan only considered rook g3
queen d6
and now rook takes g6 and queen takes e5
and
this end game should be a draw if black
is very careful because essentially in
queen end games there's always the
possibility of perpetual check but
anyways that's a moot point because in
this position andre
uh in this position andre is not going
to go rook g3 he is going to throw in
the move h4 i think this is the subtlety
that jordan overlooked now white is
threatening h5 the only way to stop that
is for black to play h5 only now fiona
does white go rook g3
now you might ask well what's the
difference right why throw an h4 h5 it's
not because of queen takes h5 that lets
black off the hook dude work h6 no
forcing h5 creates a hole on g5 white
occupies that hole
then after a move like queen e6 or in
fact queen b6 a6 it doesn't matter white
wins not just one pawn but actually two
puns white is able to take on e5
afterward
and force the transition into a rook end
game up two puns this is completely
winning for white i believe that this is
the line they're going to go down
esopenko has
more than enough time to calculate this
out to its conclusion and here he goes
and the move rook f3 was actually
accompanied
by
the look the the the knowing the knowing
look
and i think also
you're well we'll see if you're then
if he has already understood he's taken
the
the pawn on c5 and uh
h4 will probably be the
the cold shower here
and by the way the difference is it you
can't start like this if you if you go
the other move order
black draws with queen f6 and
at first i was like wait a second h5 and
hg wins the queen no it doesn't queen
takes she takes g6 and black is the one
who's winning so you have to start
specifically with h4 here and it's on
the board
did just that yeah this is this is
child's play for him
wow what a what a turnaround i mean
andreas panko he was in control for most
of the game done that missed opportunity
jordan defending uh so resiliently but
now
that was a slip not throwing in the
check on g3 and
i think there's just no saving from here
on out this is too easy for yasipanko
yeah it is and an understandable blunder
by jordan who's been under tremendous
pressure really since the early middle
game
and you'll often see that you know these
blunders
are partially a product of the fatigue
that builds up as you have to defend
move in and move out and you know jordan
found some great ideas in this game
bishop takes c4 it's going to be a pity
that he doesn't take this all the way to
its conclusion but for andre isapenko
um a phenomenal win going into the rest
day
and he's had a topsy-turvy event but he
is looking to finish strong
and the moment
of realization here for jordan is always
kind of
painful to watch um
as after working
so hard for so many hours he understands
that with just one slip here this has um
the position is gone
yeah you can kind of see it dawning on
him he's calculating the limit he has to
go h5
that is absolutely forced otherwise
white goes h i mean the only other move
is queen c2
uh but now the simple rook g3 ends the
game so
he's got to bite the bullet and go for
it but
it's not going to help
now and well while we leave him to this
maybe let's bring back the bird's eye
view see
is neil's making progress is prague
making progress
um
which of the two do you want to start
with
yes and well niels is going down the
line we discussed i mean in that
position you see
over on your lower right hand side he
should go a2 and the pawn is going to be
untouchable due to a fork so a2 is going
to win the game
and prague is thinking in that critical
position but it has indeed gone rook a3
uh and now queen takes h2 with the idea
of queen h8 is what we were discussing
there's actually several winning moves
in that position
probably doing a great job uh taking his
time making sure that
that he doesn't let this one slip i mean
i don't know who's gonna play for
probably nils is gonna play faster
because he's actually in time pressure
again so maybe we can go to his game
yeah and also
oops also i have a feeling that duboff
although he still has an hour on the
clock
he is not one who
likes to sit and torture himself in a
lost position so i think as soon as he
understands there is
nothing left at all he will just resign
yeah now he's holding out a little bit
of hope based on the clock situation
that's for sure and as he should i mean
seven minutes
there are seven moves to be played you
just never know that's the skit the
scary thing about time pressure is you
put yourself in a situation where
you all of a sudden might encounter a
problem and you can't guarantee that
you'll solve this problem correctly if
you have no time on your clock so you
leave
some of it up to chance and dubai is
going to do his utmost
uh to create complications with the
little material that he has left
and well as you mentioned earlier a2 can
be played here the pawn looks like it's
hanging but it's actually
defended tactically white cannot capture
it because of the fork on
b4
so i guess white should make a king move
step out of that
and
well the engine move was rooked before
but
f5 is a little bit uncertain i mean rook
takes nope sorry not that move rook
takes sport takes pawn
f takes e6 rook g3 check should be
thrown in to toss the king back to b2
and now black can come around to e2 and
start eating up the pawns from the e
file but all of this is not
uh that elementary i'm sure there are
other wins along the way i'm just sort
of following the top line just to give
people a sense of what what that would
entail
uh but maybe not as convincing as niels
would would like this for something like
this to be
and okay if he doesn't go
a2 there isn't
there's no other way to defend
the pawn right
i was thinking about rook a6 here
it's cube but the
the king is gonna walk over and take the
apon now in the time that it's doing so
maybe black can win by coming around and
attacking
well it's king side pawns but that is
also
quite a precarious strategy when white
has ideas like f5 to create his own
passpond
neil's down to five minutes
here we go
here we go
again actually incredible it feels like
the time travel is less severe
than last time but
still but he knows i think if he
if he makes move 60 the a pawn is still
alive uh
and the advantage in fact
and what has he played night before
yeah night before check which is a
possible move i mean he decides to
support the pawn of course he saw ooh
now he saw me too maybe he wants knight
a6 to cut off the rook
okay but wait a minute king c3 is going
to be played by dooba
king c3 i think he wants
this but after knight b3 a2 of course
black threatens rook takes b3 so knight
a1 is forced how exactly does black make
progress
in this position is the question that i
have
and what does black do here
i would love to be one yeah
but then i take take and i walk over to
b3 and i start taking your pawns
i'm not sure about that
i was going to say i would love in that
position to activate the king but that's
just not possible with the rook cutting
it off
uh along the eighth rank and i guess the
g6 never an option because of rook a7
czech
right that's a good point
now dubai has no real choice i mean he
has to approach the pawn
walking over to the other side of the
board is just unthinkable due to knight
a6 or a2
okay here he goes he's gone king c3
yeah this is still
not as easy i thought it was almost over
when the a pawn was running down the
void but i should know i've been playing
chess for long enough it's never over
especially in these end games i mean
past pawns are great but
you know when they're stopped uh it may
it just the position has the appearance
of oh black's gonna promote for sure but
concretely it's hard to make that happen
and what what concerns me even more is
that even if niels makes move 60 it's
only 15 minutes so
he's at most going to have you know 19
minutes or so
um and probably even less he's just
gonna have the 15 minutes he's gonna get
yeah
right he's going to have exactly 15.
and by the way is the penguin going for
that line let's let's go back there uh
maybe
and prague taking the pawn on h2 but
let's go back to isabenko let's watch as
he eats up jordan's two pawns
he has a mask in hand he's ready to go
home right
he is he's ready to chop up some pawns
and win the game he's looking for
something better nothing better exists
he he should just take on h5
there he goes
i think he did that i thought he made a
move
it looks a lot like it's here than
to move but it doesn't yeah it's andre's
move still oh i guess he hasn't yeah i i
thought he moved but he hasn't yet he's
just taking his time but yeah rook h
rook h5 king g8 queen takes e5 and the
point is that if rookie six it may seem
like black
wins the pawn back but white has a very
important resource queen d5
pinning the rook and essentially forcing
the queen trade so
this is also probable
yeah basically i mean there's just after
i wonder what he is
what he's looking at if maybe he's
wondering if there's a way he can take
even more advantage of the pin
could g4 be something is like no and
then the king is g4 there's always going
to be perpetual unfortunately
but and you can't really hide your king
anywhere in order to make g4 work so
i'm
surprised he hasn't played it yet i mean
he's been taking
but he has plenty of time of course
yeah plenty of time he will take on h5 i
think we're both certain i think this
would be
what was it earlier when you said add a
short side castles but here i mean if he
doesn't take that pawn
then really
i don't understand anything um but he's
going back into the tank so that gives
us the opportunity to check in with
vivid and
prague
yeah well um
prague has indeed
taken on h2 in this position we were
discussing that move with the idea of
swinging the queen all the way back to
aj invented vitidis found a nice
defensive response i like his move queen
d2
uh the idea is
to meet queen hha check with the move
queen d4 and this would be quite
counterproductive from black's
perspective now if i'm prague
you know one thing i would consider here
is returning
to h1
and and keeping white as tied down as
humanly possible i suppose you have to
be a little bit careful about this move
queen
queen d7 maybe
and once again rook a8
would be the best favorite
our old friend
our old friend
i mean has the rook
ever it's never he's never played it
right in any of the moments the work has
never been on it maybe now it's it's
time at last
he's anti-anti-gay but i mean
there's this move knight p6 also which
which is extremely strong swinging the
night around to c4
finding greener pastures also should be
winning
but i think he might move his queen back
to the first rank i feel like that's the
the instinctual response
no i like that suggestion and for prague
i think now
um i already mentioned
the nerves must be
adrenaline is pumping i mean he is on
the cusp and he knows that of beating
fit it um
which i think beating any top gm like
fidget right to 27 or 30 is going to be
a huge accomplishment for him
but especially so and when it's your
fellow countrymen indian number two
and um yeah so it's partly just the the
nerves keep the nerves in check and also
the other uh point is
he has a few pleasant options so
sometimes it's tricky deciding between
uh good moves
again not to be a broken record but if
he takes another 20-minute think you
know he's gonna be down to six minutes
so at some point he's gonna have to
start trusting
his his feel for the position because
these positions are very difficult to
calculate out by brute force white has
so many different queen moves and
you know you have to factor in some
concrete details like for example if you
play queen h1 you have to have a
response to queen d7
and it appears that knight b6
is the most effective response and once
again this
oh you can actually play queen h8 here
and okay king a2 rook c2 we've already
discussed in a previous position in
queen b2 you trade you go in ic4 and you
get this end game which
to be fair is not the easiest to win but
i think black is just in time to
infiltrate white's ranks and win at
least one of white's pawns which should
be enough to win the whole game
not so easy to see that from a distance
not at all that's very tight that's the
talk we need straight there is a tough
move to spot
okay well i think uh not with it prague
might take a bit more time here so let's
go back to the bird's eye view niels has
indeed played uh knight a6 trying to
to cut off and
cut
the transmission between the the rook
and the pond
and yeah now the question is how do we
make progress here
yeah and i mean knight b3 has been
played by
dubaf who
i can guarantee you is still feeling
hopeful and it's maybe even more hopeful
now that they've gone down this
relatively unconvincing line for black
i guess we can go back to that game and
await nils's move
because he's down at two minutes and 50
seconds for five moves here we go with
this again oh my goodness yeah even six
moves to make still four six moves my
bad yeah yeah
the timing wasn't a math major
i don't know why the times haven't
adjusted on the bottom left corner neil
certainly wishes he had 24 minutes right
but no this is his dream like the bottom
left is reflecting there we go
it was reflecting his desires
okay so now we are in that spot we kind
of discussed earlier of how do we make
progress from here now the night the
white knight is now stopping at that
pond
i was saying i would love to activate my
king i don't
doesn't seem possible to do that
so
we can't move tonight well could we play
knight b4 is that leading
anywhere but the knight came here that's
the problem i don't see where it goes
from b4 now you can go rig b1 we
discussed that move i think niels might
actually do that
um rook b1 rook takes a6 rook takes a1
and then you get that rook end game
i mean according to the computer it's it
should be a draw
uh but at least from a distance it
seemed very tempting to me to go for
that you could also go
rook
c6 check and force the king to decide
where it wants to go i mean if it goes
to the left then you can start pushing
your d-pawn down the board although that
is that means giving up your a pawn
and then
you're really in danger of not winning
the game if that deepon doesn't go all
the way through
such a tough spot here for nils with
two minutes under two minutes now he's
about to make a move i'm very curious to
see what it's going to be d4
i think he might be playing d4 check
which is actually a really fascinating
idea
let's see
yeah d4 check king takes c4 and only
then rook b1 is the idea but let's let's
wait for him to move and then i'll show
the idea if he in fact goes through with
it
under a minute and a half he needs a
move now six moves to go until he gets
his final
uh final 15 minutes and rook b1 has been
played
yeah so rook b1 essentially forces white
to take the knight
so rook takes a1
and then dubov is going to
win the a2 pawn with his king so what's
gonna happen is rook a6 or k1 king b2
what was tempting me about this is the
move rook f1 and black comes around and
starts taking white's pawns king a2 rook
uh rook f4
but the the engine seems to think
amazingly that this position
is closer to a draw than to a black wind
even though black can come around and
win another pawn
the whole problem is how at look at how
active white's king suddenly is right
king comes to c5 and because this pawn
is so far advanced
white should be able to draw this with
accurate play this would be a remarkable
save by dubab if this is indeed what
happens let me tell you one thing dania
if i was in that final position with the
black pieces i would suddenly
start being worried that i might even
lose
to that advanced white pawn
right you start thinking about like how
all right maybe i should start looking
for a draw like
no and your
concerns would be somewhat justified
no i mean this is but the problem is
this whole line uh you should we just
went down and
seems
more or less forced i mean
i'm not sure if there was any moment
where nils
where where black could improve on that
line we just went down
yeah no it's force black black has to
obviously has to take the knight and
then black is a choice between rook g1
and rook f1 and both moves lead
essentially to the same
prototypical end game where black will
have the g and h puns
and white will have that far advanced
what hurts black as well as the
placement of his king the king is
really far away from the epon and has a
hard time walking through
uh via g6 that that square is going to
be cut off as long as white maintains
the h pawn which is going to be a long
time
maybe danny uh maybe we can look at your
idea with d4 jack which looked really
interesting
yeah i mean i when i spotted it i
thought for a second that it was a game
changer so the point is that after king
takes d4 rook b1 if you just blindly
take the
oh no it doesn't work i thought this
position is winning for black but it's
not uh it's amazing
c3 the king is back in time
and already here black should start
thinking about making a draw as you said
so
wow
i feel like niels was hovering over the
pawn
i mean this is such a tough game for if
if duboff holds i mean all credit for
him but that is going to be so another
really tough blow for nils this one
isn't over yet but
um already duboff and i think you can
also sense it from his uh
demeanor that he
he has there is some new some new life
some new hope
there's definitely hope and you know he
he's certainly
this would be a game changer for him he
hasn't had the best event i mean he's
been really on the defensive
in essentially all of the last games
since his forfeit
and uh
you know including this game uh it
seemed like he was off to a very
promising start but then
uh then when niels castled short
everything everything changed
yeah this would be huge
what an incredible moment at some point
we'll have to go back and
and show that for now let's bring back
the bird's eye view see if andre has
finally i can't believe it he still
hasn't taken on it taking the pawn he's
gone through three so he's now between
those for the slow improvement
but the pawn isn't go it doesn't really
change much right the pawn isn't going
anywhere
it changes very very little i mean black
can throw in the check
but ultimately black will have to return
to c6 in fact black can do nothing
except
uh
stay on the left side of the sixth rank
because if
black goes queen f6 and tries to force
things he only
uh forces his own defeat queen c8 check
now if queen fa there's rook h8 of
course and if king f7 there is a nice
little
skewer here
so or a pin rather um
again i
always do that
so jordan will go queen whatever queen
yeah
oh no the queen b6 loses again there's a
check
he's got an a6 to cover the the square
on c8
yeah of course that's the point rook h5
king g8
and then there's no queen c8 check i
think andre is trying to find a way
uh to do this without having to take the
ponza he has to go king h3 here i think
but wait a second king h3 there's this
move
wait a minute i am not sure i i love the
move g3
i think andre might have overlooked the
detail because if he goes
for this
then it's a druk we need to check as a
perpetual
right
and what's the problem with that other
line
so kh3 it's winning
it's winning according to the engine but
it
i mean white
only has one extra pawn rather than two
but apparently this end game is still
winning because white is so active
king f7 white nope doesn't take that one
not yet soon check and now black has i
mean black is essentially just getting
squeezed another check
king f7 h5 king f5 and ultimately this
pawn on e5 is way too weak it's just not
sustainable white maybe andre has
calculated this end game and decided
that it is winning but
he's taking some more time here and he's
about to make a move yeah king h3 is on
the skin h3
i think jordan's gonna go queen e6 he
really has no other choice this is the
best practical chance
if he keeps waiting if he goes back to
c6 then again we just pick up the two
pawns i guess yeah at that point white
will have no choice but to do that yeah
okay back to the bird's eye view what
did prague decide on i'm curious
prague decided on
queen h5
so he gets the queen onto a nice square
where it defends the b5 pawn and
potentially threatens to
uh to to give a check on e5 so vidit
playing f4 depriving the queen of that
square
so let's bring up the sorry let's just
bring up the big board so we can analyze
here
um
sorry sorry danny i will ask you maybe
just to reiterate with the with the
arrows to show again
so basically yeah what i was just saying
is queen d2 and now proc playing queen
h5
uh in order to
aim at the e5 square and protect the b5
pawn and vid it taking away that square
with the move f4 and currently oh
project just played queen f5
prague just played queen f5 aiming at
the knight i mean i feel like
practically speaking defending this for
white is such a nightmare i mean every
single move
you have the potential to blunder
i i mean prague is below 20 minutes but
i really just don't see this happening
for a minute
yeah i did it
he's i mean he was in control early he
was a pawn up life was good and one
moment and it all turned around
now he's suffering he's been suffering
for a long time i think this is far from
over yet but dania we're gonna go on a
short break and then we will be back
with the last three games here in
another very exciting round don't go
anywhere you don't want to miss it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the first time i came here in was 2017
where i played the c group and then 2019
i played the british and now this is my
third time here yeah it's a great
opportunity for me because you know i
can
i can learn a lot from these games and
i'm really looking forward to this
you know to have fun and
interesting games
i started to work with engine like
pretty late after i became an
i am and mostly seriously after i became
a geo
i sometimes think over the board and try
to you know find human ideas
and also use computer as well
i use technology and as well as you know
used books and
and seeing a chess book i don't think
computer will solve just like um for now
definitely
and maybe later like they could solve
but for now i think
just won't be sold
i'm looking forward to play against
magnus in a classical game but also
other players like
karwana and
all the others as well
[Music]
welcome back to todd of steel the
chess.com rapid chess championship is a
brand new world-class online rapid event
series for the top 100 players top 10
women and top 10 juniors in the world
watch as the very best compete for their
share of 20 000 each week culminating
with a 150 000 prize final it all starts
at 9 00 a.m pacific noon eastern on
saturday february 12th right here on
chess.com and for so many weekends
thereafter for more information head on
over to go.chess.com
r c c mark your calendars for the rapid
chess championship never spent another
weekend being bored fiona this round has
been anything but boring we are in hour
five of
tata steel
around not around 10 that is and we are
watching the remaining three games
absolutely and danya i think there's
only one place
for us to start and that is duboff
against nilsguandelius i'm absolutely
shocked that duboff
did not go for the rook ending
what
i actually was zoning out on the prague
game i was checking that whoa whoa whoa
rook b1 he went knight c2
oh my god he went knight c2
oh i'm sorry this is crazy
maybe he was worried about d4 but then
just rook takes a2 and obviously you
stopped the pawn
i mean i that is ridiculous
especially with so much time on the
clock like i am shocked that he decided
to give up the piece rather than to go
for a work ending which we thought
looked much more drawish than
than winning
simply knight c7 here rook c8 rook c5 is
there something that maybe there's
something he sees maybe f6
no but then takes takes in 96 and black
luck wins
and if if white goes e6 by the way fiona
there still knight takes c6 very nice so
oh my goodness
and dubai of not taking all that much
time he still has 50 minutes on the
clock i'm honestly shocked that he
didn't spend
20 30 minutes trying to calculate the
rook end game
i really cannot understand it at all and
here we see the time control once again
niels has just made move 60 so as soon
um as he makes a move you will see those
15 minutes added we'll see how much how
much is left of i think we'll see about
three minutes at it
it's time to get into time pressure
again
um but yeah this was the final move 60
is the second and final time
control
and uh yeah let's get back to the
to the game and
i'm just absolutely shocked and there we
see the close-up uh so at the moment ten
minutes remain so five are already gone
and uh those ten they're gonna tick down
fast but the position seems to be
i was gonna say completely winning
which it seems to be but it's never
quite that easy of course just a couple
more moves i mean he first of all he
needs to see knight c7 which is very
easy
i mean you drop the knight back and
attack that move is obvious what's not
as obvious is figuring out that you
should play rook c5 and calculating f f6
looks scary i mean i just showed the
slime this does look scary at first
because the king can't walk over to g7
but if you look very concretely after 96
okay i can try rookie 8 but then the
knight swings over to g5 and the moment
you stop the pawn the game is over here
you don't have to calculate any further
um so it's just really a couple of
details that have to be accounted for i
mean i suppose white could keep the
tension with king d3
fine here there is even here there's 96
i mean 96 is essentially the threat
that's a very nice motif actually this
uh
knight e6 ideas went to work on c5
probably rook c6 in this position is
what is also
attracting niels i i don't i really
don't know but rexy thinks there is e6
and i don't know what to do there
let's put it on the board rook c6 e6
no but i think this simply is a blunder
e6 no no here here it's a draw
niels has gone completely the other way
okay
um he's giving up the knight and his
point is that he's just gonna take all
of white's pawns in return for it
that probably is also winning
dubai did he go f6
i think so yeah yeah he won f6
and now dubop's point is if she takes f6
there's going to be rook a7 checking g8
and now rook takes a6 niels has to be
very careful this is probably a draw
with this h pawn being as far advanced
as it is fiona so
after f6 it looks like niels has to move
the knight
and allow rook a7 uh this gets scary
this looks sweet it's very scary my
goodness if this game ends in a draw
eyesore that would be insane
in a way i mean it almost feels like a
draw would be
not necessarily the logical conclusion
but this game has been so insane
i know what you're saying but it always
feels like these games tend to end in
draws
uh but niels is not going to have uh a
good night's sleep if that is the case
definitely not so let's look once again
the night looks like it should move
first of all where do you go do you go
to c5
there's two candidate moves right the
drawback of knights knight c7 is bad
because it allows for k7 and it may seem
like black stabilizes no
rookie 7 and you have to move the knight
and give up g7 still winning chances
even there because the pawns are
restrained but not what niels would want
for that reason
you want to go knight c5 get out of the
line of fire of the rook and after rook
a7
the engine indicates a very powerful
move king g8 now yes you give up g7 with
check but at least you get the king to
an ideal defensive square where it is
basically ready to take on these pawns
but man man man rook h7 and now you have
to play rook f5 and you're gonna still
have to win this position
uh and neil's once again
approaching serious time pressure this
time it will be permanent so he doesn't
have much margin for error anymore and
one thing that's maybe important to
mention at this point
there might be some new viewers watching
us and i saw one person asking will we
see work against rook and knight if you
are uncertain let's say all the pawns
came off unfortunately for neil's
rook and knight is not enough to win
against the rook and it's quite an easy
uh
actually a very easy draw very easy to
hold with the rook so niels
cannot afford to just go down to the
pure end game without pawns
and by the way rook versus rook and
bishop is also a theoretical draw but a
lot harder to hold i mean rook versus
working bishop
probably is not held like at least 25
percent of the time probably even more
um but rook versus working that you're
right on the money is is a pretty
elementary draw you don't really have to
know anything
okay
and what did he play knight
correct
now rook a7 is what we're going to see
and we're going to see it instantly
and there it is
do bob has over an hour on the clock
and will nils find this move king g8
or will he be tempted by a move like 96
what about
the check on e4 does
his king e3 knight takes f6 is winning
but unfortunately for nils white can go
king e2
and if you give a check on f2 then king
e3 and all of a sudden black's pieces
are kind of all stuck together
and you're unable to take on f6 because
the rook is gonna hang
oh man neil's now down to six minutes i
mean this game it's never
never over so many times it perfect yeah
it's crazy
okay now there's this mating attack in
the in the end game and then
and then uh duboff is back and suddenly
it's winning again and then suddenly we
think oh now it's gonna go to this rock
ending yeah but no i didn't even see
that duboff could refrain from the
rocketing i thought it was literally
forced
otherwise i would have talked about this
option i didn't even see it but
man this is a pivotal moment kg8
seems to be the winning move as long as
black could preserve the d5 pawn he
should be winning if black gives up that
pawn then you know we run into trouble
if you're kneels
and the knight on c5 is doing such a
great job covering the square on d7 so
that the rook can never get behind that
one
now by the way rook g1 is another way to
defend the pawn and is also bad
because of a weird move rooks i mean
it's unclear rook c7 chases the night
around if you go 94 check ultimately
you're going to run into the issue that
white is threatening to win the game uh
by pushing these pawns forward so
uh rook g1 is probably not the the right
approach five minutes now for niels
now this is getting nerve-wracking you
can see he's starting to feel tense
and reminder for everyone this is it
this other five final five minutes so
niels is not gonna get any more extra
time on here from here on out the time
you see on the clock is what he has uh
for the rest of the game
yeah he's playing blitz and uh he
realizes that he has to be accurate here
i he was about to make a move i didn't
see what it was
i thought he was hovering over the king
with the hand i thought so too i will be
very impressed if he plays king j that's
a move which requires
a lot of
presence of mind and also fearlessness
to allow white to take the pawn with
check like that and to see past that
that is not easy super uh impressed with
niels he looks so cunn
considering he always wow
amazing
niels finds it in dubai did you see the
reaction
damn it you know why of course he sees
it
darn it i mean
that blank king has been such a hero in
this game first by castling and always
g8 the key square first the king castle
uh king side two g8 and now king j8
again looks like it could be the the
winning move here
yeah that's the the symbol of the game
is the king landing on g8 well dubois
has to play rook takes you seven there
is nothing to think about for him
um and after king f8
he has to find some way to complicate
the game now i thought about going after
the h pawn apparently rook c7 is the
most resilient move to base the knight
around
and if the knight drops back to e6 you
go rookie seven and the game is still
not over i mean if the knight parks
itself on g5 fiona white actually has
everything defended look at this and
white could start bringing the king up
to d4 and guess what black still has to
work pretty darn hard
uh to win this kind of position with
four minutes on the clock daniel to be
honest this kind of position the last
one we had on the board there i am
always like i see the engine says minus
four but it's still to my
human absolutely right it looks
terrifying still as black
and if it doesn't look terrifying then
there's something wrong with you i mean
it ha these positions always do with
these past pawns
uh you make one little mistake and you
allow promotion
uh so any time there's even a
tiny possibility of losing
uh and you're in time pressure you're
always going to be scared but
let's see what duba ends up doing he's
about to take on g7
he can also give a check on a8 but then
the king walks over through f7 to e6 and
escapes
and daniel dubov he's also have to be
concerned about his time because danya
he's about to drop under an hour soon
i know yeah he's basically an acute time
pressure yeah he needs to get moving he
needs to get cracking
there we go off he goes he's hurt on
smoke g7 and king f8 on the board
indeed
and now the big moment
now i think dubob
either he's gonna take a long time or
he's gonna adopt the approach of
playing quickly and
you know trying not to give niels any
time on his move
that's been the approach he's taken so
far yeah
if i had to bet i would i think he will
stick to that
yeah should we quickly uh go there
yeah let's check out the other two games
i think andre
is grinding it out slowly but surely
he's trying to force a queen jordan
didn't end up going for that end game
uh because it is completely lost
but man jordan doing everything he can
down two pawns but for for now he has
succeeded in avoiding the queen trade i
don't think he's going to be able to do
that for very long though
in fact i think queen d5 ends the game
immediately
queen d5 ends the game
because
if you don't take the queen you walk
into sorry you walk into rookie five
if you play queen f7 you walk into rook
f5 followed by rook e5 you have to take
the queen e takes d5 this has got to be
completely winning for white
yeah looks like queen d5
will be the end can we try instead uh
to checkmate the black king after queen
h7
where i thought about it i don't see it
though i mean this also completely
winning rook f6 and now
now the movie h5 is very powerful
actually setting up queen g6 check and
also threatening h6 look at how white
uses both of these pins
yeah i mean this also i think uh once
again yes the banker is spoiled for a
choice of winning moves here and it's
just a
matter of transference
i feel like he's taking like 20 minutes
on every one of these moves and
he's really working out the most
clinical pathway and we just need to
update the clock times because those are
still from the nils game here the
players andre is down to 12 minutes but
he has just played queen d5 and any time
considerations
um are
irrelevant because i think jordan very
likely will just um maybe not resign
here but soon
yeah i mean rook end game down two pawns
is almost never a draw now there is a
scenario you can imagine where if white
is not careful here
yeah you can actually first of all d6
would be the best way to screw this up
all in one move if you lose the pawn
i mean i guess ricky five would be but
other than blundering a rook
um the best approach is to put the real
country five and anchor it to the pawns
that black's king
limiting the range of the king's
mobility right it now has to stick to
the pawn at all times
and you could even throw an h5 for good
measure
okay blackstroke is probably going to
stand behind the plot and then you just
walk your king over to d6 and you win
the game i mean that's very very easy
yeah and look at the black king i mean
it kind of couldn't join the game
anywhere was completely cut off
and uh jordan from his face there we
briefly saw him he he knows that it's
over i don't know if he's gonna try and
defend this work ending he is already
he might resign yeah
it's over
great job isapenko
very disciplined
very very impressive indeed and let's uh
go quickly to uh prague see
if he is making progress the queens are
off the board in that game
but he's winning i mean he he decided
vidit out of desperation finally decided
all right enough is enough i'm forcing
the queen trade but products said all
right thank you very much
uh now you're gonna suffer in this kind
of position right he's winning the e5
pawn
this is just nasty because white is
going to be left with these two
incredibly weak pawns oh but wait a
second fit it though he finds a way he's
going to play knight a3 here isn't he
he's going to play knight a3
and he's going to win the b5 pawn
let's have a look 93 i was wondering if
b4 if anything works but no
there's knight c5 maybe rook takes b5
brook takes c3
man we are in for a very long game if
they go into this kind of end game the
question is gonna be whether black can
get to the second pawn if he does black
is winning on the spot if he doesn't
it's still there's still a little
uncertainty in a position like this
i think he's gonna win though i think
prague's gonna win it looks messy
um yeah i mean
sorry
no no go ahead no no
you go ahead
no i mean i i don't really know what to
say in this position other than i feel
like practically speaking for a human to
defend an end game like this is
virtually impossible
yeah and maybe that's the same
i was just wondering what vidit was uh
thinking about if not knight a3 because
it looks like if you don't win the pawn
on b5
well then then what
well if you don't win the opponent b5
then
[Music]
of course you should maybe it is i can
see the resigning here yes but okay
but yeah um
this is very difficult very very
difficult maybe we need to invite
alexander grishik into the studio for
some end game analysis but
maybe later i actually i know
he's not coming he was commentating on
the russian i think on our russian
channel a few days back
oh really well i commentated the world
championship in with him in russian um
we did a couple of rounds
and i had such a great experience i mean
he's funny in english but in his native
language he's obviously
more fluent and he's i mean he's amazing
no i can't imagine
i think he shared yeah go ahead
he shared um
we're tired
he shared this hilarious story
that made me think that this is like the
most gracious thing ever
in this way that only only chess fans
will understand what i mean
um he was he was like all right when i
was first learning to drive
um i i went i had to go somewhere
and then
you know on the way back my phone died
so i couldn't map my way back home and i
didn't know the roads very well
so he says this in the most dead man so
i decided so he's like i went on the
freeway and i drove
all the way until the freeway ended
and then
i just kept driving in the same
direction until i finally hit a spot
that i knew but he said it in the most
like deadpan
rishooky way ever like you imagine this
is the most thug life thing ever like
he's just sitting there driving and he
doesn't know where he's going but he's
completely confident that he's gonna
reach his destination
that's hilarious and daniel funnily
enough look at prague defer for the
first time in the tournament i think the
mask
has come off he needs that oxygen
white's pawns need some oxygen too
the frag face reveal after 10 rounds
here it is that's his face
indeed and uh the pawns are socially
distant but
um
lest i heard there they're not
vaccinated
oh it really has been a long day
yeah
when i resort to these kinds of jokes
that's that's a sign that
i'm bringing the you know
bringing the level down
but prague i mean on a serious note he
looks so focused
like he i think he's known for a long
time he's better but now we're really
getting down to the nitty-gritty of the
final phase of the game
descent came here he's gonna have to put
on some work and we've had a resignation
by
jordan
so kudos to yasipanko also a very
interesting game
between these two and quite a bit of
back and forth
yeah you're in resigns um in this
position down two ponds i mean it's
clear that andre is making progress on
both sides of the board no need to
continue playing
and uh painful painful game uh by jordan
who held out valiantly but made that
critical blunder in allowing
rook f3 rook
g3 in a situation where he was quite
close
uh to holding the drop esapenko with the
win the second decisive result of the of
the day and that leaves us with
only two more games double grendelius
and
vinid against prague let's swing by
duboff's game and see what's going on
there maybe for sure especially with
neil's uh nielsen's time taking down
doombop he's gone under an hour he
actually invested quite a bit of time uh
into his last couple of moves
so we were wondering where is he gonna
go after king f8
he went to c7
yeah tricky tricky move if niels goes
rook f5 which is extremely tempting
looks like it wins all the pawns right
nope broke v8 check okay big deal where
is he going rook b7 nope brook b7 check
and you can never cross e8 because of
rookie 7 check this is actually just a
draw
oh my goodness this guy is definition
so
yeah that's that's the perfect way to
describe it and niels actually has to
move his knight off of e6 in order to be
able to escape the check so knight d4 is
the top move not easy to play
and now
okay if duboff checks and checks
okay i mean king e6 rookie 7 oh barely
and if f7 the king can just walk all
over to e4
and white is unable to make to make
progress e6 nils by the way
has played knight g5 tanya okay knight
g5
probably similar
oh we talked about this now duboff's
gonna approach his king to e3
now king e3
this game okay king e3 let's see and the
king is coming up this is the the
position where i said i would be
terrified still
now king f4 and this is amazing rookie
fortran king somehow slips through the
cracks to f5
are you kidding me
this might
this this can go either way i really
don't know
if this how this game will end it's
impossible to say
i was thinking during our break dania
that uh i don't know we haven't decided
yet what the rapid recap of the day is
going to be but i was thinking if we
chose if which is this game good luck to
us doing it in 10 minutes doing the
rapid recap by the time the next round
started as well there's no rapid
recapping with this game
a slow recap
and he has gone king e3 has do above
my goodness gracious okay four minutes
for nils
i mean i
really don't want to allow the king but
we cannot stop the king from coming
forward right we cannot cover all the
squares on the fourth rank
yeah that's the problem d4 f4
and the knight can't move back to e6
because dubois has set himself up
perfectly for this
idea of giving rook b8 rook b7 check
i mean and imagine sitting here five and
a half hours into the game you've got
three minutes on the clock for the rest
of the game
and
you have to find a precise way to win
when your opponent has two pass pawns
right in your grill
i mean once again the engine says plus
four what if we followed the engine line
what does the engine say the winners in
this position because and by the way i
have to accomplish the chat has been
very understanding of the fact that this
is not an easy win i have to give some
props to people in the chat for not just
saying oh it's plus four
why is nils not winning because
i and i i think that's progress i think
you know looking at this position
immediately makes you realize that it's
not an easy win so props
um the actual engine moves rook a1 come
on oh my god what does this even do
king f4 oh and now it's saying rook f1
check now you need to let it reach a
higher i mean the thing is
the computer at a lower depth here even
the engine can't figure out exactly what
to do
good luck to nils i mean under three
minutes on the clock i feel nervous just
watching this i mean
i said earlier i would be i would be
absolutely terrified here as like i
wouldn't just be terrified that i'm not
going to win and i would be terrified if
that king gets
anywhere near my own king because the
black king
back there on the back rank i mean if we
imagine a white king appearing on on g6
or e6 and suddenly i know you can lose
yeah oh my goodness i think neil's just
allowed to drive i think neil just
blundered rook b7 check because you
can't go to e6 you can't maintain
now does he want king e8 maybe
oh my goodness he blunted i think he
forgot that king e6 gets checkmated with
rookie seven and king eight what's the
problem
well if you go king it at the very least
i should be able to go
rookie seven check and then king d4 and
then take the pawn
and then we really are playing for three
results
oh my
god crazy
on i mean this is going to be such a
heartbreaker if niels
doesn't win and it's looking like a draw
i think he has to just repeat
and i think it's just dawning on on nils
i think
probably just a blind spot for a second
uh king cannot go to e6 he has gone back
now
and he's gonna repeat once and then
think about going king e8
unbelievable and
we were all and i think as commentators
were obviously unbiased but you can't
help but
root for niels when you see how he's
playing
and how much he's trying and you can't
help but feel
terribly for him but at the same time
you have to give it up for duba i mean
he was playing quickly
but he was always staying in the game
and he found a lot of practical chances
this game he didn't
beat himself
and at every critical juncture he really
did force nils to find
you know very very accurate moves that's
what make 2700s so insanely hard to
bring down they never die
they just never die
it's so
incredible really how how many times you
have to beat them once isn't enough
twice isn't enough like
they always come back and i mean the the
resistance that lubov has put on i mean
i'm even i'm starting to wonder you know
earlier i was wondering why didn't he go
for that rook ending
i wonder if he considered both and
thought that this one gave him maybe
even more practical chances i'm very
yeah and you know i stand corrected i i
was almost positive that niels was going
to win
and you know what i'm going to say i
think niels is big big mistake
practically speaking even though again
let me be very clear this doesn't
squander the actual win
in this position i think knight c7 just
ended the game because it prevented e6
from ever being a thing of course neil's
thought that duba would take his knight
here and then the end game is winning
amazing move f6 and i feel like niels
might have missed this detail this
tremendously complicates the winning
task and
after that it was never easy it just
wasn't
and he's down to two minutes i think
he's going to concede the draw here
this is crazy
what a crazy game uh between the two
players i'm lost for words and for ninth
such a tough spot and we're going to go
with just one interview what yes
you just beat jordan for race uh with
the white pieces um can i say that it
was like esipenko won the rook on g50
yeah yeah maybe but it was a
strange game because i played some
really
weird opening
and it was uh
all about equal i think
but then he played f5 i'm not sure about
this move
i took the pawn rook f5 he could play as
well bishop f5 i think it was better
maybe and when i played queen b4 queen
b4 c5 i think it's already a mistake
and after
queen e4 i think it's
[Music]
almost
not winning but it's a
big advantage i thought yeah and uh
after he played rook g5 i could also
play uh
knight g6 i think
but
he has
queen d7
i play rook a7
he can take because of
because of the mate
and after rook b rook b8
i didn't see anything so probably he's
he's fine there
yes and that's why i played the queen of
three and uh rook just
was trapped
um
yeah can you say that like the whole
game basically was like trying to find
your way to
to to get that rook yeah and to keep the
tension on that room yeah yeah probably
but i'm not sure
um when he played b5 he could also play
queen e7
and
i'm not able to
change the rooks
so
i'm not sure about this position if i
have something but
probably b5 was a mistake because after
this i can change the rooks and it's
much more easier for me
so you're at plus one no back in the
tournament um actually i want to talk
about something completely different
because like i know that you're like a
big football fan yes and uh you play
like the
fantasy
are you the
best fantasy player in this tournament
apologies for cutting out of the
interview we will play the end of it
later on but the game is going on so we
will return there neil's deciding to
play on but now suddenly archery results
possible in this game again danya
yeah i mean niels has actually gone for
the win what a gutsy decision king e8
and dubaf as we discussed going down
this line now the engine is showing a
draw objectively speaking
um
how is this draw to be achieved king
takes d5
um i suppose rook takes h5 and then the
king will have to step back to e4 in
order to pave the way for the pawn to
move to e6 now i said all three results
are possible not really black can't
really lose this game because at any
moment black can give up the night for
the pawn the problem is that white's
pawns are simply too active
uh and in the long run black cannot make
progress because of the constant threat
fiona of the pawn advancing to e6 this
is just this is a draw
and this
game really i mean duboff he has so much
time
uh he's still thinking
could there be anything more for him
than taking on d5 is there a tricky
attempt because i think he feels the
momentum shifting as well and he might
harbor some dreams of creating some
chances some tricks
no no i i would say no because
again because because the point is black
is going to take on h5 in the next move
i mean i guess e6 is also a move here
um but but then after night you five
white is simply losing because white
loses the pawns
so
i've actually done that before where you
you come back and then your opponent's
in thai pressure and you really really
want to win
but then you over press and you make a
you know you you make an attempt at a
trap okay take stakes and king e4 has
been played i think duba was doing this
perfectly
and
okay let's see once okay first of all
where do we go with uh with the rook
well rook h1 is the sort of traditional
way to do it right putting the rook
behind the king and after rook h1
i suppose it would be premature for for
white to go e6 you could end up losing
these pawns i mean the knight can go to
g5
so i think dubois just needs to hang
around
these pawns with this king i think he
should go king f5
and you see the what the problem is
after rook f1 check the king just goes
to g6 rook g1 check king h7
the king makes contact with the pawn and
if the pawn moves there's gonna be e6
and then the king is gonna chase the
pawn through h6 anyways let's see what
niels does he goes rook g5
he goes richie five and i guess king f4
king f4 and then once again the question
will have to move the rook again i guess
yeah i mean i guess niels is buying
himself some
buying himself some time
i mean he can make back and forth moves
as much as you want here
yeah i vic is telling us i don't think
it was a draw if i also saw that neil
said something uh to do buff i don't
think it was to me it looked more like
uh it's like
what
sorry it interrupted united shape 98 oh
my goodness goodness oh my god
oh my god
the night the knight heads to jesus and
he's played it
night haters on the board
dude russian rook g5 was such a tricky
move dubois had to go rook e6 he had to
keep the king on e4 oh my goodness oh my
god
danny i cannot take it my heart is too
weak i cannot deal with another
turnaround goodness
just at the moment when he was about to
save the game and here's the why is this
a problem well this is a problem not
because this is a fork that's not the
issue right the issue is that the e pawn
is going to be lost rookie 6 king f7 you
have to move the rook away and you give
up the epon once the e pawn is lost
black goes around and takes the f on and
that is going to be an easy win rook
knight in h-pawn against ruckus famously
one of the easiest theoretical wins
which is there is nothing what i can do
about this
oh my goodness
and now dawning on duboff i mean for
dupa if it's all i i talked earlier
about how heartbreaking this is but it's
also hard this game is going to end in
heartbreak no matter what happens
right it's going to end in heartbreak
for duba and
you know i hate to be that guy but he's
got 55 minutes he just had to hold
himself down he had to make himself be a
little bit more patient whenever there's
a knight you know you just never know
when a move like this is going to be
possible and knight h8 what a beautiful
geometric idea the only path to g6 that
you could just see
this is my incredulous there i came that
far no
but just to be clear once i'll go back
to what i was saying before night h8
appeared on the word which was really a
shot out of the blue and i don't think
there was a draw for just weekly i think
first of all it wouldn't make sense for
nils to offer it wouldn't make sense for
daniel
to to decline and what neil said i don't
think it looked like to me it looked
like maybe daniel maybe unintentionally
kicked him under the table and
apologized to me it looked more like
something like that with neil saying oh
it's okay so i don't think i don't think
there was a drawer
but now i mean for daniel and yeah now
the devastation uh
he really came so far danielle he was
one step away from holding this game
and these are the heart you know there
are swindles where you're losing right
and you make your opponent makes a big
mistake or you catch catch your opponent
on a trap okay that's impressive
but this was more impressive because
it's not like niels made a huge bond i
mean niels made a series of inaccuracies
and mistakes but duboff kept himself in
the game
for over 40 moves i mean he was lost in
the middle game then he was lost in the
early end game then he was lost in one
type of end game then they went into
another and in every type of new
position daniel managed to adapt and
find a whole new set of tricks and traps
particularly this decision
uh to play a night down realizing that
the past pawns present tremendous
difficulty this is tremendous defense by
doubt and this is the reality of chess
this is why it's the most brutal game in
the universe because just one second one
momentary loss of concentration cancels
out six hours of
laborious insane effort
i mean this is so
so brutal
and i mean i'm at a loss for words this
game i was thinking dania maybe if this
is our game of the day instead of doing
a rapid recap since tomorrow is the rest
day we just gather here and film a nice
two-hour week i would be down i would be
down for that i would be totally down
for that i would say that i yeah if we
do that we should definitely do it
tomorrow because i am i don't know if
i'd be capable of talking about this
game from the start today
we had a question in the chat what about
rook g7 so here black takes on g7 and
you might say wait a second isn't the h1
a draw no not with the knight when you
have a knight the h pawn is winning and
the e pawn is very easily restrained you
can just win it with the king and if
white doesn't push it you can just play
knight g6
you know revert back d7 one way or
another you're gonna push white away
from that pawn
uh you're gonna win it and the rest is
very very easy you can kind of convince
yourself of that um and dubaf
makes a move
it's king e4 but obviously knight g6
and just one or two more precise moves
are required
of grindelius
i mean this is
this is maybe the most intense game i've
ever commentated on life
absolutely i mean i would say top five
for sure the other game by the way is
also ongoing and they also have a very
close end game
but i suppose we can stick on this game
for now because that other game is not
ending anytime soon that's for sure
and we are getting to this position the
e pawn uh drops and now
h5
h5 is
winning you could also play rook h5
and then migrate the knight over to f7
that's actually the most clinical
approach after h5 black is still a
little tied down
but winning it's also winning
so now nils
he just needs to now put the finishing
touches this is the most winning
position he's had
all game for sure uh but
under two minutes here i don't think
the time is too much of a problem
anymore i think as soon as he's played
either h5 or i think he'll go rook h5
yeah i mean either is fine he's gonna go
the pawn
i'm wrong the hand was hovering
you might not be wrong he retracted it
maybe he'll change his mind
no h5
is on the voyage
and dubai was going to play rook g7 rook
g5 and then king e4 maybe but then niels
can just keep pushing his pawn you can
push it to h4
you can push it to h4
so let's see you're saying work cheese
have one
yeah i mean rook g7 rook g5 let's say
king e4
okay dubop has gone
yeah he's gone i think he's gonna g7
right yeah
okay now you can give a check on g4 you
know what makes this terrible for white
is that the king can never cross the
f-file because the knight is always
gonna have a check
so
you're gonna have to go king e3
and then niels can just keep pushing the
pawn i mean this is completely winning
g7 or g5 has been played
did he resign or are they starting a new
score sheet i think they're starting a
new score
it's move 81 so that's a a new score
sheet rook h7 has been played
oh you know what the easiest one is rook
f5
go after the f-pawn then if king f king
e4 you'll play rook at 4 check
then play h4 and then pick up the pun
that is the wind that ends that that is
the wind that will cause immediate
resignation on the most part
so rook f5 here the move we are looking
for
yep rook f5 followed by h4 followed by
rook takes f6 and if white plays rook h6
then the king comes up to f7 all hands
on jack it's a team effort by black's
pieces
it really is actually evaporates for the
last time yeah i think once the f-pawn
drops we'll see a resignation
by duboff
niels
down to his last minute i mean he's
really used up all the time that he was
allocated today
he's gonna move his knight knight e5
knight f7 is another
winning maneuver by the way that he can
play
yeah and he looked like he was reaching
for the knight so that's what we might
see
yeah knight although e5 is on the board
e4
[Music]
thing e4
and if knight f7 then maybe king f4
how is black in the how exactly does
black
put the finishing touch man this game
just never
you just don't know what's going to
happen in this game you can't call
anything it's so unpredictable
um
robert has joined us in the chat he's
saying wow and in that line so after
rook f5 king e4 rook f4 check
king d5 rook takes f6 wins because of
the falcon f4
beautiful and actually that is a very
important detail
thank you robert because h4
uh would would make it a lot more
complicated on the count of thingy six
so that's probably the detail that niels
failed to account for not that his move
ruins anything but
uh
i think dubois should try king e4 here
and then king f4
i really i mean this game
has exhausted me i don't know how to
play it it's a good thing that tomorrow
is a rest day because this game
absolutely is going to be really tough
to recover from from for both players
and i think regardless even for neil's
he will be of course delighted if
he gets to win
but
a game like that
really really really takes it out of you
and you know just like going to the gym
and getting a very tough leg workout you
don't feel it the day of the day off you
feel really good about yourself when you
wake up the next morning i'm exhausted
i'm sore all over the place that's how
niels is going to feel tomorrow morning
he's not going to want to get out of bed
he's going to want to watch a football
match and order room service and he
deserves it
after this game yeah he definitely does
uh nils he actually doesn't like
football but he spends he's been very
active here i think he's going for a run
every day with his second christmas swan
and
he's quite a routine guy so i think a
run a rock a nice meal that will be his
jam and he's earned it after this game
as
uh
tries
to
oh i thought he would have knight c6
this is resignation it's time to mount a
resignation knight c6 in the game is
over
niels was going to play it in about five
seconds i think
or not or he's going to spend the rest
of his time there's nothing to calculate
knight c6 king moves and you take the
rook there
did he play it i think no he went
no oh my god i see six nils well this
also wins of course of course this also
wins because the rook is trapped it's
just funny that that you didn't give
that check and there's the handshake
resignation by duboff and danya what
an
absolutely incredible game we have just
witnessed
and good sportsmanship there by duba if
he smiles
um it's very very difficult to to not be
angry when you resign a game like this
and just storm out of the playing hall
to to sit around and you know still have
the strength to discuss the game it says
a lot um and niels
is a
he
he is a gladiator he is a hero for the
way that he played today the resilience
he won the game again and again and
again how many times did he have to win
this game
i can't count too many
oh guess what we have another one
i visited against pregnant and now the
last game to be going
sorry they're on increment they're both
on increment oh no they just made move
fifth oh they just made move 60 and
they're going to have another 15 minutes
i thought we were about to see a a 50
move a bullet finish your favorite word
uh favorite word in the english language
after hyper bullet
dania we are gonna go on a very very
quick break and we'll be back here
with the conclusion of this game of
course we'll also catch up with
everything we have missed so don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round 10 here at the
data center tournament and what an
absolutely insane round it has been but
dania it is past
8 p.m here in the netherlands so they've
been playing for over six hours and
still the indian clash between uh vidit
and pragnanda remains
as i see nils getting ready for the
interview so before we do a deep dive
well let's get go to nils
niels gondalias your first win in the
tournament and what a rollercoaster
event it was
the game yeah yeah yeah i think i mean
first two hours i was basically uh
playing as bad as all the other days i
ended up in i think i don't know if it's
lost but it's just very very bad for me
i think at some point but then he gave
me some some counter chances and in very
few moves it already turned that i was
the one declining repetitions and it's
clear that i'm the one pressing
uh
but then okay in with not that much time
before i move 40 i decided to go into
this position ending upon ups like very
safe but probably i had something much
better is my guess but i went to this
and it's for the rest of the game it was
all the time like
for me at least my evaluation was that
it was in between draw and the win like
like i think i changed maybe evaluation
five six times during the game during
the end game so i don't know finally
even in the end like i finally got this
one last trick with knight h8 after
which it's completely over but even like
one move before that if it doesn't allow
it i'm not even sure that it's winning
so like i mean yeah i seem to have no
idea
yeah um
how many squares have your knight been
because like it was all you know you
know like these famous diagrams right
like uh yeah exactly but you know at
least it was extra i mean
[Laughter]
so a better uh bad night than no night
at all i guess was there like this
moment where uh you could actually like
uh
trade the nights or like daniel could
like trade he could have traded then i i
have to i was very surprised that he
didn't trade the knights because i
thought
the rook ending should be his best
chance he just pushes all the pawns on
the king side and uh
i was
thinking that it's closer to a draw than
a win at least and in the game i thought
it's closer to a win than a draw but
again i i don't really know i mean all
rook endings are drawn no exactly yeah
um
time management
there was quite a big thing in this game
like the nil at some point was like was
an hour up
yeah but you yeah yeah sure no it was a
bit slow like i haven't uh
when i have a very bad position
the good thing is to keep playing fast
and then when chances appear if they
appear you are ready to take them
but somehow i was spending time not to
end up in a bad position and did anyway
so i don't know like if he just made me
on move 20 it doesn't matter if i have
10 minutes or one hour
but like were there like moments that
you uh that you were looking at your
clock and was sticking down and you felt
the nerves like [ __ ] i have to make a
move
uh yeah i but i actually i would only
say like it was one moment and it was
this decision to go into the ending uh
winning upon but relieving all the
pressing pressure that wasn't a decision
that was like heavily influenced by by
my bad time
uh but for the rest no i was just trying
to play the position
um yeah like i said like it's your first
first win in this tournament finally
like how relief are you
i'm quite relieved actually but okay
i mean i could easily have lost this
game as well so i'm not sure it's
my best game here but uh well it's
something it's a start is it something
uh to play against daniel because like
for example like fidet had also like
this amazing game against the nil
uh also one
um like does he bring the best out of uh
out of his opponents look we had a very
normal position and they casted long
suddenly i mean i think very few people
would actually do this and it's very
interesting and it took me completely by
surprise and
i mean yeah that's daniel dubo for you i
mean he's
going long castle whenever possible
uh three more rounds to go um what are
your ambitions goals
uh i'm hoping to play a good game
basically that's it i i don't think i
have any right for more hopes than that
now
okay well i wish you all the best thank
you very much
niels grandelius uh what did he say
daniel he's very relieved indeed and
sometimes it's easy to find the words as
well after a game like that but he's
confirming what we thought that the work
ending um was probably more george and
he also was surprised that daniel didn't
go for that
yeah we all were
and i it does seem upon analysis that
that was probably a drop
so what an incredible game but
um we have one more incredible game that
is still going we have this end game
between vivit and prague i'm going to
very quickly run through
what what has happened since they traded
queens so uh prague won the pawn with
193
oh he did go knight c5 so we talked
about this knight c4 we talked about all
of this 94 g4 and somehow prague
wasn't able to win that fun it looks
like he had some better attempts knight
h3 knight h3 in this position
looks like it was it was a winning move
if black wins the pawn fiona the game is
over if black wins g5 that end game with
two pawns up is indefensible and right
now they have this position vinid is
down to his last nine minutes
it looks like objectively speaking white
should be able to hold but practically
this is such a difficult end game to
play one mistake and it's over
i mean this game is it's almost a
similar story
in terms of emotions to to the uh dub of
crandelius this is going to end in
heartbreak other for divided who was the
one pressing initially and then one slip
prague seized control of the game he was
very near winning at a in a couple of
moments there was of course this
moment with rook 8 which we talked about
plenty and then the game continued
continued and now we find ourselves in
this endgame but it has defended so
stubbornly if he loses it will be
heartbreaking for him if prague cannot
convert that will be equally
heartbreaking what do you make of
prague's chances to get to that
all-important uh g5 pawn
yeah i mean he has to keep trying
various methods i mean right now he's
gone roxy that's a good move he's cut
off the king now he's got several
approaches that he can take he can take
the approach of saying okay first of all
rook trade can some
it can be both good and bad like
sometimes a rook trade is good
sometimes it is bad for example
white can play the move king b3 and
let's
just for the sake of illustration if
black trades rooks here
that's terrible because white is able in
the resulting position to get the knight
into e4 and this is just a fortress so
prague has to be very careful about rook
trades
as vidit goes rook d5 in this position
yeah you got to keep swinging your
knight keep trying maybe knight d193
maybe get the knight to f5 in order to
cut off the rook's access along the
fifth rank to the g5 pawn i don't know
it's incredibly difficult to play this
accurately and i was seeing in the chat
someone saying prague looks uh exhausted
i mean of course he is going to be and
this is one of the longest time controls
but i think his chances are quite good
now for he is up five six minutes on the
clock remember the players are not
getting any extra time apart from the
30-second increment and i've i feel i
don't know if you would agree but
from a practical point of view with such
little time it's harder to defend than
it is
on the the offensive side
for sure i mean prague has a million
different attempts he can gain time at
any moment whenever he wants to
uh but right now if we were to reason
really i like this idea of maneuvering
the knight
uh from d1 to
to e3 you could also like in this
position you could play rook b8 check
that's actually a very very strong move
it forces the king onto the a file
because both of these moves
land in four land on forks
and here already knight c3
and you know in this position already
black can probably trade knights
and the point is that it looks like
white is a fortress but no rook f1
king b4 and black stroke steps into f5
intercepting white's rook and this is
winning king c4
takes takes and black is just in time to
play off six and reach a winning punt in
game by a single tempo so is that
necessarily going to happen i don't know
but maybe
maybe it will oh my goodness oh man i
mean i really don't envy the players um
prague here knight d1 one of the
tempting moves he's about to reach out
it looks to me like it could be 91 from
the hand movement yeah 91.
and if it goes king b3 i think it's
losing by force actually
king b3 rook b8
which is very easy to miss extremely
easy to miss the move rook b8 check
now according to the engine king a3
straight away is better because it
obviously because it doesn't allow the
nitrate
but this is a big oh it does allow the
knight to knight e3
rook d3 knight c4 check but
in this particular version of the end
game white could defend from g3 so
this is oh no but f6 is winning i mean
the king is cut off
no i think black is winning
i i think black is just winning this
right oh by force yeah
i think it's winning by force
yeah black trades black trades knights
wherever the king goes and the most
important resource is this rook v8 check
which i think vidit failed to foresee
when he played rook d5 and this is what
i'm talking about right one little
inaccuracy he put the rook on the wrong
square
and that's it that that caused
uh the you know king b3 was the most
accurate move here but rook d5 allows
this beautiful transition to a rook end
game that's winning
and it's funny to see both these final
games decided in the end by and late
coming to the back rank in nils's case
even more impressive because retreating
knight moves are very difficult often to
see but here also knight d1 the king has
gone at 2a3
yeah now this is going to lead to a
well-known theoretical end game prague
needs to decide on the nitrate which by
the way is
it's not a given that he that he
realizes that it's winning i mean he
still has to has to figure that out the
point is that the white king is going to
be cut off along the c file
and and that's what really devastates
wise chances
he's rolled up his sleeves though that's
a good sign yeah i mean for the first
time in the tournament not only has the
mask come up also the jacket has come up
i think for the first time as well but
prague i mean
the focus on his face is so intense
right now he knows he is on the verge
it's been such a long game
and for sure both players are exhausted
not only was it a long game it was so
intense
um but he knows
a bit more focus a few uh precise moves
and he is going to be
going into the wrestling with a huge win
over his compatriot
with it
yeah that's gonna feel so good and
i i would show the line once again and
delve into a little bit more detail but
i feel like he's about to make a move
um let's wait for him
to to decide whether he wants to trade
in our because if he doesn't play knight
e3 knight c4 then it's all a moot point
um he's got 10 minutes on the clock
plenty of time so he can even take five
of them to
evaluate the consequences of by the way
knight e3 rook d4 of course stops the
trade of knights but not the fork
knights are tricky beasts
yes they are
they certainly are
all right well
thinking thinking thinking they are
going to use all of their time up
the eyes and warting all over all over
the world
oh my goodness
do you want to shall we have a look uh
i know you wanted to wait for
yeah it doesn't seem like he's going to
move anytime soon so
we have we have a lot of time so 93
now it doesn't really matter where the
rook goes because here's the thing
if white's rook has two defensive
approaches it can stay on
e5 and in that case we already know
that the winning approach well actually
the winning approach is one and the same
you just go rook c7
and then you go f6 that's it you force
the trade and this leads to a very well
known theoretical end game now the win
here is the following you go king f5
white's only approach is to keep
checking and then attacking the pawn
and the only idea i remember alex your
malinsky taught me this you go king e3
this is what you do
if the rook keeps checking you go king
f2
now you're threatening to push the pawn
so the rook has to stop it
back to f3 and then you're ready to play
g4
if the rook goes to g1
then and only then do you bring your
rook up to c5 defending the pawn
white has to try to make a mad dash to
b4 even if white has king before in this
position it doesn't actually help
because black plays king f2
rook g4 back to f3 and once the pawn
hits g4 it's all over the pondrest gets
to g2 you don't even need to know the
lucino position the king is so far away
that there isn't even a sliver of
opportunity if proxies this he ends the
game immediately
and this is such an instructive
uh moment
do you think he's gonna go for it
yes i think because he's taking so long
if he didn't see that there was a
possibility he would have already moved
yeah i think he's just making sure and
quadruple checking because it has all
come down to this and the last thing he
wants to do is
make a rash decision and squander
what has been a tremendous effort all
game long
and really i mean knight d1 shaq was
such a brilliant move by by prague
where suddenly the white king had no
safe square to step onto
i feel like it all started i mean if i'm
honest yeah but it made that big big
mistake with queen takes h6 right or
queen h6
but when he played way back when in the
opening when he played knight b1 instead
of queen e7 i felt like after queen e7
black doesn't even have
black really doesn't have any kind of
initiative against white's king when
vinnie played knight b1 that kind of
gave prague these long-term chances so
that even if objectively he was much
worse and he didn't have enough comp
you know vinit constantly had to remain
on his toes
and play accurately on every move which
was really hard to do across like 20
moves shout out to our producer big who
has produced a really beautiful scene
here for the end of the game
that is really really cool
that looks awesome
so prague double checking triple
checking this is
forest uh he can force the knights off
and um
that will be
the end of the game with it with the
poker face i think he has also seen
but not giving anything away
nope and
prague is now down to six minutes i mean
he needs to start thinking about making
a move sometime soon
although again if he determines that 93
knight c4 is winning that end game i
think he can win with 30 seconds on the
clock like he can win it just by just
with the increment because if he knows
the plan
he he will play instantly
to be honest i'm surprised that he
hasn't moved yet because the end game i
think that you show it really very
instructive but players like prague
they
they know like i think they didn't know
it by heart but of course i mean it's
been so intense who knows what frag is
is checking
could there be any other move
than light e3 he could be considering
i i mean maybe knight c3 but
also i'm going to defend bigfoot chad is
really nitpicking this layout but big
literally just put this together on the
fly
um this isn't you know
you know it's not going to be perfect
but i think it's a really really nice
view it gives you the board it gives you
the view of the players
uh what else do you need and the time
stamps
um i think the times are readable yes
you know they're not high definition but
i think we can see how much time they
have
um what else is there to think about i
think knight c3
is is maybe tempting him just like
attacking the rook and trying to get the
rook off of the off of the fifth rank
but
honestly fiona i mean this is so easy to
calculate this end game
it's really forced i mean there's no
variability here it's just boom boom
boom and if you see this idea of going
rook c7 and f6 it's game over
and he is down now under five minutes uh
i agree with you
if he gets to the rook ending he doesn't
need any more time so
i'm not gonna criticize him for using up
all his time if he wants to the problem
is if he doesn't play knight e3 then
then he really needs to to make a move
now
it's gonna be too big of a sunk cost
like he he's already taken too long not
to play it yeah i'm i'm 99 sure we're
going to see
something like 93 knights before then he
just i think he's spending this whole
time calculating the rook and gaiman as
long as he sees rook c7 and f6 that's
the key idea and there he goes
and
ninety goes 93 that's step one
so
um prague he
i will have the chance on the next move
to get the knights
off the board and i agree with you i
think that's what he will go for
and
then the rook ending will just be be
lost i think vidit will fight probably
until the very end
yes but uh yeah prague i mean
what's
impressive composure from him today
reminder he's only 16 years old
indeed as vidit goes rook d3 i think i
know what he wants to do but it wants
knight c for check and then king b4
oh that's a tricky defensive idea
but it doesn't help because still rook
c7 so here here
here here
aha so if rook c7 then you stop f6 yeah
then you stop f6
but this has to be winning i mean
rook
e7
i think threatening rookie five
and if rook d1 i still think f6 is
winning although
with the king being this close it gets a
little bit more hairy
now this is where prague would need a
little bit more time so let's see what
happens and suddenly it also becomes a
lot more understandable that he was
spending that time on knight d3
right
i don't know i mean i i hope prague saw
this because now he's spending more time
three and a half minutes remaining
it's 100 winning i'm positive but you
just need to work it out
but with it is also finding the most
uh the toughest after going astray which
rook d5 lang knight d1 is now once again
putting up the toughest
the toughest defense as
frag ticks down under three minutes
we talked about it they don't die these
players no matter how many pieces they
have left on the board it might be two
they will make out of these two pieces
uh the most resilient defense here
prague goes did he play knight c4 he did
and king before by vinit he's gonna why
king before to prevent the rook from
getting to c5 and consigning white's
rook to a passive
resistance and now prague of course is
gonna take the knight i would imagine
and then he's gonna have to be very very
accurate with three minutes on the clock
the moment of truth is about to arrive
indeed so 92 work d2
and
now i'm not even done it's been such a
long day did we find something that was
completely convincing
no i mean 92 rook d2
you could just play rook fade and f5
like even that should be winning
but man this is it's been a while since
i reviewed these types of end games
this is where we we uh bust out
varetsky's manual page 284.
yeah but it's not easy i i honestly
missed this king before i did this
changes
the difficulty level of the conversion i
have to say
yeah once again maybe we can just
explain one more time if anyone is just
joining us now as prague i think he
messed up some pieces there but he has
captured
on d2 and the problem is
that now suddenly we're not um
not in time to get in both rook c7 to
cover the seventh rank and
f6 yeah and rook c7 vidit can have
either rook d6 or probably he's going to
play rook f2
and obviously then black can also move
the king around
black doesn't have to commit to anything
yet because white's king is cut off when
i say cut off what do i mean by that i
mean the king can't cross the c file
black can sort of experiment with
several different approaches and gain
some time
but i can even repeat i mean pratt could
even just move his rook back and forth a
couple times nothing wrong with that uh
as he decides how he wants to go about
this process
i was just thinking daniel that today i
mean we we always encourage you guys to
do roaches before the round there was so
many
uh kneels and and prague they were at
the bottom of the standings today has
really been an
insane day but this game isn't over yet
uh but
i don't even know what i'm saying
anymore i'm blessed yeah i don't know
either i'm
we are pretty exhausted too i mean
this has been such a roller coaster ride
in so many games you might even forget
that carlson carjacking was today that
was this morning
they drew this morning
well this afternoon here in bike
although even for me it feels like that
happened
this morning
right no absolutely ages ago and i mean
another thing which is incredible is
that we talked about before the previous
wednesday that in general uh games
rounds before the rest they tend to be a
bit more peaceful on average
but uh
famous last words
right exactly last words yeah
oh my goodness
and this is gonna end with both players
uh really using up all their time i
think it's probably the longest game of
the tournament
oh
without question i think and by probably
by like half an hour yeah i don't know
did you and robert ever go past uh
i i suppose it's 8 00 p.m your time
i don't remember going past even last
year going past yeah i think 8 p.m was
usually
the time at which we would finish
and maybe a couple of times we finished
at 8 30 with the game the rapid recap
but
i think 8 30 was the absolute latest we
ended the stream so this is you know by
far the longest game
oh my goodness now vitid is taking all
of his time trying to figure out where
to put his rook
does he keep it on g2 does he play rook
t5 does he move his king there's like
800 candidate moves here i don't know if
it makes a difference one way or the
other i think rook d5
is probably bad because of this old idea
that i that i showed rook f1 and rook f5
but who knows
who knows
question from the can the players eat
something while playing uh absolutely
yes um
they should
canon should indeed
see another comment why is fiona
laughing all the time i didn't see
anything funny today
that's right why are you constantly not
taking your job seriously
come on
i have a clip of it that's all you do is
you're just always laughing
you're not even compensating i think a
lot of people like and also i think they
don't realize not just for i think
well even for us
it's exhausting being here
but for the players
yeah sorry go ahead
no it's different kinds of example but
you know we're we're basically reliving
the moments in the games i mean we're
we're basically there in spirit of
course it's much more exhausting to be
the player to
to put your blood sweat and tears into a
game like this when there's so much on
the line but
it's you know it's exhausting all around
it really is and at some point at least
for me kicks in like
what's the word
it's like your mind is just fried at
some point it's almost like being
punched drunk or is that a word is that
a word punch drunk yeah it is no and it
makes sense that's exactly what it is
actually it's just you're just sort of
in a haze yeah
and
vet vidit also is seemingly and he's
down to three and a half minutes
on his clock and now we're finally about
to see what i really came here for which
is the bullet segment of this game
and he's
finally about to make a move
or so it seems
i mean it's also you know we are sitting
here okay i'm laughing all the time but
for these players
i'm not sure if if they even know is
this uh definitely uh i don't know if it
knows this is definitely losing
does prague is this definitely the
winning probably not and in that case
for vidic every move could be the
decisive
uh the decisive move um if that makes
sense
right for us we might be saying well why
is he thinking it doesn't matter but we
know it doesn't matter because we can
see that the evaluation is the same as
you have indicated
and just to rephrase vidit
might be saying to himself well what if
i what if only one move makes a draw you
know i need to find that one move and
he's going to keep searching and
searching
and that's what he's doing here as he is
now down to two and a half minutes i
thought he was about to make a move but
no
he is still deep in thought
let's imagine danya this was uh this was
a bullet game and you were playing white
which move would you instinctively go
for
rook d5 or
well we discussed rook t5 i just
realized that rook d5 rook f1 is still
okay for white because now i can drop
the rook back to d4
and rook f5 rook g4 so i would be
tempted to do this or i would just move
the king i would play king b5 maybe just
keep the status quo
rook a2
okay well that's
i mean a similar type of rook g1 rook a5
so uh the idea of course if
frag attacks the pawn from g1 he will
defend it
uh from a5
a5 yeah
so you can do the whole routine with
rook g1 or k5 or f1
and then the rook is going to come back
to a2 in order to
defend
the g pawn with rg2 so the bottom line
is when does black play f6 obviously not
here
because that that allows for k7 check
um
okay so if not here then the question is
when
did prank play
did prank play king jade
frog did flaking g8 i think he's buying
himself some time
i think he's buying himself some time
they're going to repeat moves okay a
checking g7
or king h7 he's just going to buy some
time
that's actually a good practical
decision don't you think
yeah it is it is
so by making that triangulation maneuver
i guess if if 4k is 7 he will just go
back to g7 or
is there anything i guess he'll go back
to g7 i mean of course he has to be very
careful not to um
he has to be very careful uh
not to repeat moves three times but
right now it's not even close to
that okay he's made what he's done he's
played three fast moves for anyone in
the chat curious as to what prague is
doing why is he not trying to actively
make progress he played three fast move
moves which give him a little bit of
extra time uh on the the clock to then
um
i mean even one extra minute in this
situation could be a game changer yeah
it's a game changer you need every
second to calculate now just to complete
the thought because i he he i was rudely
interrupted by it by vidi deciding to
make a move at that moment
black has to decide when to push the f1
when do you trade the ideal version
is to keep the rook on the c file
because then it's completely winning
that doesn't seem to be possible
uh so one possibility is you know for
example let's say white
no king b5 loses terror or g1 but okay
rook d2 or whatever
you can play rook g1
rook f1 rook d2 rook f5 rookie two you
can play f6 in this version but you see
the problem is that white's king is
really close all of a sudden
to
to the right square and it does seem
like rook f3 wins the game i think
black is just in time to keep the king
confined and away from e4 but fiona this
is so hard to go for when you've got no
time and
tempo for tempo i don't know if brock is
going to be able to go for this
yeah and i think
that is exactly the point
the problem is
if you whenever you break with f6 you
want to be 100 certain that it will be
winning because there will be
no way back and with
two minutes on the clock three minutes
on the clock it's just so hard to
to decide on the moment when you go for
that committal
f6 push
that's right and vidit taking once again
all of his remaining time i i mean i
assume he's going to play something like
rook d2
i just don't see what else
there is to do i mean he can go rook a7
it all
essentially will lead to the same
conclusion if black plays rook g1
yeah i'm a little bit surprised that
again this isn't criticism the players
have been there for so long but i'm
surprised that village is leaving
himself with so little
he's just now moving and
i guess what he's essentially thinking
is that when push comes to shove his
moves are going to be forced
but he has to move he's got 13 seconds
oh my goodness
and rook
where did he go rook d2 rook a5 yeah i
mean again one of
several moves that
wait a minute i mean rook rook f1 yeah
rook f1 or k2 is the point
rook f1 rock a2
and vidiq making that move with five
seconds on the clock prague he has three
minutes now
yup now he's the one with a lot of time
you can also go f5 by the way but the
problem with doing that i think some
people in the chat were suggesting it if
you play it here
you're gonna encounter a lot of
difficulties with your pawn on g6 and
white's gonna keep attacking that pawn
yeah you can try king f7 and then king
e6 and you can try to sacrifice that
pawn
but evaluating this i mean this is a
nightmare try evaluating this end game
oh god
i think there is no way he's gonna go
for something like that
i i agree although you know he's going
to have to go for something ultimately
eventually he's going to have to play
push the f pawn because he's not just
winning the g5 pawn for nothing
and he's going to have to take a
calculated risk at some point just go
for a line that yeah might be a draw
and you can see the nerves i really
don't envy any of the players he's about
to make a move
i think f5 is winning
but i think that final position i just
showed there was winning for black but
that's the whole point it's not easy to
to figure it out
some great camera work again by by
vikken what has he done
king
kf8
okay well he's trying to get around
three seven to e6 to f5 but rookie five
obviously video needs to play rookie
five here he needs to cut that king off
cannot let it get to e7
and vivit once i mean he's just playing
on increment now
uh
can we also cut the king via a7 no
because then and then rook g1 stand upon
false 10 seconds once again for village
i mean rookie 5 is like you just got to
do it
you just got to do it
but ah so i guess his point is okay rook
g1 rook a5 and if the black's king moves
then white's king is going to get over
to c4 just in time
so my goodness
i guess king king maybe uh prague should
put his king on e8 for now and see what
white does why it might be in zuk's long
there
white might be in zugzwang after king e8
oh my goodness that's actually an
incredible position of you know the rook
has nowhere to go along the seventh rank
because if you go to b7 you lose your
rook
if you move your king back you lose he's
done it dania
he's done it
and vidit has to go rook a2 and let prox
king out of the cage i think this is the
decisive idea
i think this is the decisive idea
king eight is such a cool move
that's great i mean
again the king kit can't move in either
direction because of the arrows
the rook can't move to b7 if it gives
the check on a if the king escapes
you've got to go rook a2 and hope for
the best 10 seconds for videos
five four he's gotta move he's gonna go
rookie two
rook a5 he's gone okay five
okay five now i think prague can start
walking out with his
king yeah so 87 for example king e7
and even okay let's say the king gets to
e6 and then how do we continue then
we're trying to bring
first of all f5 is already easily
winning and second of all
you can yeah then you can play rook f1
or f5 and at that point you're not even
going to give up the f7 pawn you're just
going to win the g pawn all on its own
so
probably just a couple games accurate
moves away from winning yeah king i
think he's gone d7
all the same the king is going to go to
e6
yeah
and bid it with only the increment no
time to even think about it i think he's
going to lose within a couple of moves
he tried everything he could he took as
much time as he could but
it just isn't going to be quite enough
five seconds per minute four
three
two
oh four
rook a six
okay well rook g1
or is yo he's gonna go king e7 and again
he's gonna induce zuk's song it's the
same problem it's wong again oh my
goodness look at this position it's the
same principle rook b6 you lose
king moves you lose
the rook has to move away from the sixth
rank and it has to let the black king on
to e6 and that is decisive
amazing stuff by prague just great
technique i mean it's been stunning i'm
so impressed seven seconds once again
forbid it but it looks like it doesn't
matter any longer rook is dropping back
to a2 and now king e6
is the crucial move
that prague is going to play i'm sure
no that's it it's over
king e6 is his game you're gonna get the
ideal position with black's rick
returning to c1 later on to cut off the
king
i mean the
the technique that prague has displayed
here with only two three minutes on the
clock is just so so so impressive
yeah no i mean
i feel like king e6 should be kind of
automatic here but prague is gonna
double triple check it
and surely i mean surely this is gonna
rank as one of his uh best victories in
in classical chess i don't know who the
highest rated it's not so much to rating
but i think this is a game that is going
to stay with him forever
well the rating is also impressive 27-27
is
not some not a rating you beat every day
so especially with black yeah and for
prague i mean he's just going to be
really happy to score his first win of
the tournament in fact both of the
lowest seeds he beat the nils actually
he lost a lot of games
he did beat me that's right okay okay
that's fair yeah so he's already won a
game in this tournament this is i guess
his first super gm victory
and man he's gonna
take up all of his time as well
he's almost there i mean he just needs
to play king e6 i really don't know
there isn't much to calculate there you
just go king e6 he got five take the
pawn and king e6 rook f2 there's rook g1
he is also down to 30 seconds now and we
will danya we will see that bullet
finish that you've been waiting for all
tournament long we will 26 seconds now
you've just got to be careful not to
imagine if you there he goes
did he go king e6 yeah
he did and with it going rook
the final attempt at a fortress at a
defensive construction and the move rook
f1 ends the game rook f1 rook f5 is the
maneuver that wins
rook f1
king let's say c4 rook f5 and then
black's king walks around the rook to f4
and you simply take the pawn and then
vidit is gonna resign if prague plays
rook f1 then it's two moves away or two
three moves away from resignation
and there he goes where is
where is the rook going
it's definitely going to f1 it is
rook f1 is on the board i might try
rookies but it might try rook a6 check
by the way
final trap hoping for king f5 or cops
extreme
oh my goodness imagine if that actually
happened
that would be crazy
but approximately king e5
i think if that were me playing and if i
walked into rook f6 that would be the
end of my career
oh yeah it would be the end of anyone's
career i think even if you're a gm i
would definitely retire after that the
end of your life the end
the end of all the furniture in the
hotel room
[Laughter]
15 seconds
i think he has played or asic's check
yep
okay
and
k5
yeah prague making sure that it's not
putting the king anywhere near f5 you
should put it closer to d5 than to f5
just to make sure
my goodness and yeah this now
wow really
really
is
is it i think
this is it rook five king f4 king takes
g5 and with two pawns fitted is not
going to continue the game
he might play rook a7 and i think he
will resign after rook f5
10 seconds again for a video but
prague has done everything right here
king a5 rook a5 check
king f4 king g4
and then rook f5
or you can play even king e4 and then
rook f5 and then king of four any order
is fine for black
yeah it's it's all winning all equally
winning
man they are like so patient i would be
playing pretty much instantly i would be
too excited to think i know i mean
prague has really demonstrated some
not just outstanding technique but his
maturity like the way he used his time
and how he handled his nerve has just
been uh very impressive
yep king f4
there's no point in continuing now i
mean king g4 would have five
here i would say that it should resign
for him it's a very tough loss he was um
one of the early leaders he was still
you know very close pursuer and um with
only three rounds to go
this loss is
probably going to end his uh hopes to
potentially win the tournament yep
no without question i mean
this is how it always happens in
tournaments you know you just
you make plans but uh
you never plan to to lose to lose a game
like this you know you're in great form
you can draw magnus and
but but everybody in this tournament is
so good including prague that
it can always it can always happen at
the least expected moment
and i i mean
now he should definitely resign
yeah for sure we see the time ticking
down only 14 seconds to go and we might
just see a
handshake here as videt's final pawn is
about to drop
is coming
and there it is the resignation
wow
congratulations to pragnanda uh the game
lasted six hours and 50 minutes and what
a game it was sonia unbelievable game
and i mean this game could probably be
analyzed for hours it was so complex
really from the opening onwards vidiq
played a very good opening got an
advantage but at the end of the day you
know he gave prague too much activity
and even though it wasn't the smoothest
conversion prognost wins in the middle
game he kept his foot on the gas pedal
and he played exquisitely in the end
game getting into the rook in game and
then figuring out the most precise win
amazing win for prague very well
deserved and he's going to be feeling
great going into the rest day for sure
and dania four decisive results here
once again
in round ten
and it was a weird day it kind of
started slowly as you were saying the
start of the games feels like they
happened
yesterday or something right yeah it's
like do two day games i mean of course
karjakin carlson is a quick draw
shanklin momidarov is also a pretty
peaceful result
giri duda was a little more topsy-turvy
so all of our draws were relatively
peaceful but man the decisive games were
absolutely incredible back and forth we
had richard report playing a great game
let's not forget to beat carawanda with
black that was equally as impressive
absolutely stunning stuff dania we're
going to go
on a quick break but we're expecting to
hear from pragnanda very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the first time i came here in was 2017
where i played the c pragananda
it's a national holiday in india today
and what a day it was with a fight
between two indian players
you just beat fitted with the black
pieces
describe the game just like in one word
um
interesting
interesting
what were the interesting moments
um
yeah first i think in the middle game
probably i was
slightly worse uh maybe even worse
and he took the pawn on a4 which gave me
huge counter play with 97
and uh even went for queen at 6 where i
got queen b5 probably after that i was
completely winning but i couldn't find
the clear way then i went went to this
end game
probably with accurate play maybe it's
holdable this rook knight but i think in
a practical game it's very difficult
and rook ending
yeah rook ending i have seen some
similar endings with the king
far away but uh
i think it's winning but uh
as my coach said it's winning but i'm
not sure
yeah i think it was it was winning
indeed yeah um
you played like about 80 moves you were
the last
uh lost game left in the in the playing
hall like it must be very tiring for you
yeah it is tiring and
yeah i'll go and take rest
and it's good that it's tomorrow rest
day so
yeah and um so how does it feel like you
i think it's the second time you be
defeated in a classical game
yeah last time it was in nation and okay
this time this time it's much more
special because uh last few months i was
struggling with my play and okay today
at least i won
finally won a game i remember the last
time we had like an interview you said a
little you talked a little bit about um
that you worked on on the mental side
trying to um to to get back from from a
loss for example
um the tournament didn't go super well
for you yet but like
how how did you manage to to to strike
back
no i just i knew it's going it will be
tough this tournament because all the
players are very strong
so
so i was just ready for it mentally you
know and uh so when the situation came i
was
you know i could focus on the next game
so how do you prepare like mentally for
for yeah like after for example loss
like yesterday i didn't do much like i
just uh
went from just uh
just checked my game a little bit and
then uh slept like just relax basically
and uh yeah then
just i just try to forget about the game
how how long do you usually sleep
you mean in this tournament yeah yeah
how long do you sleep that's what you're
asked yeah
around nine hours and of course
but like you go to bed like uh cause
like today like right now it's like
almost nine yeah o'clock like what time
do you go to bed
i'll go at around 10 10 30
but today i think it will be late
will there be some celebration
uh no i don't think so no
probably dinner yes
okay well i wish you a good dinner and
a good rest yeah thank you thanks
welcome back to todd of steel chest it
is now time it was a great interview it
is now time for your round 10 rapid
recap and fiona there was there were a
lot of gains that we could have chosen
we decided to go with uh fabiana caruana
against richard report which was a
fascinating game in its own right
indeed so from the get-go uh surprise
surprise we got something
quite uh unusual which with widget
reports um that's bound to happen
it really is i mean the typical move
here is d5 there was a different game
in this very round between gear and duda
that followed d5 but here report going
from our old school move c5 this allows
e5 and now the knight drops back to g8
the point is that white has this big
hole on d4 but fabi instead of going
knight f3 which is the main line he goes
for the immediate d4
and pretty quickly we we had a series of
simplifications fiona
yeah it looked like this game
we were thinking might
and somewhat peacefully let's see what
happened uh as richard report actually
did a great job uh controlling all of
fabi's um initiative
indeed and fabian this position after a
series of normal developing moves he
plays queen g5 essentially forcing a
queen trade because of the attack on the
g7 pawn and it does definitely look like
white is slightly better here black is a
bad bishop white is the possibility of
castling along but report makes a very
impressive move f5 this move has two
purposes the first is to send the knight
back to f7 where it's controlling a lot
of important squares and as we'll later
see uh he also sets his pawns in motion
and later on he can go e5 uh e4 and the
next stage of the game was also very
well played by him
yes starting from this moment with f5 a
strange looking move um i was thinking i
like fabiano's position but he just
richard started playing very pretty
precisely and after uh 95 as you
mentioned the knight uh drops back to f7
which led to a series of exchanges
yeah i did as i was indicating you can't
take that knife knight f7 is so cold
blooded knight takes c6 bc
and even though it looks like black
structure is damaged white has to go for
this move bishop b3 otherwise either you
lose the f pawn or in the event of a
bishop h4 the bishop gets trapped so
after bishop b3 both sides now have uh a
damaged pawn structure
and richard brings his king up to e7 and
now um you know he's not just slowly
developing this is typical report very
ambitious fiona he just starts pushing
his pawns down the king side trying to
grab as much space as possible
indeed fabiano trying to
rewoud bringing his knight to c5 and
those king side pawns they just keep on
rolling
yeah i mean it might have been more
prudent to go h4 at this moment we were
discussing that that could have averted
some of the subsequent problems
uh that befell fabiano he decided to do
something similar after h4 he goes g4
obviously he's inviting it on poisson
and then he's going to get control of
the h file richard doesn't do that he
doesn't take on busan no instead he goes
95 centralizing his knight and fiona
this is the most important moment in the
whole game absolutely fabio fabiano now
going astray with rook d4 from a
distance it might be easy to have to
miss what's happening but uh after
knight g4 the problem is
that you recapture but uh black is not
forced to take on g4 immediately
no black plays this wonderful
intermediate movie five which fell out
of fabi's field division it attacks the
rook forcing the rook back and then
after f takes g4 black is not just up a
pawn but look at this massive pawn fail
except it's only a matter of time before
black breaks through with g3 and that's
kind of what happened report making
another very interesting decision rather
than just clinging to the pawn he
decides to sacrifice his extra bond back
but instead to activate his rook it
seems like he sacrifices two puns but no
he recovers one of them and ultimately
they get this type of material situation
where black has this incredibly
dangerous majority on the king side and
richard converted that majority
masterfully fiona and the next stage was
just lovely yeah look at this technique
first of course the rook gets activated
hitting the knight on f2 that went
to d3 and now those the pawn majority
you're just mentioning starts advancing
uh the rook uh
giving a check the king of course
stays on the side of the pawns maybe it
was better to go the other way but the
natural move king e2
yeah king c3 was an interesting try with
the idea of playing e4 actually trying
to dislodge the bishop um after king e2
king f6 e4
black has the move rook e8 here so that
might have been a more resilient try but
who can blame fabi for you know for
playing to e2 richard continues to cramp
down uh stopping any possible pawn
motions on the queen side and then after
fully improving his position to the
absolute maximum he is ready to break
through g3
and of course if h takes g3 black wins
the game by playing h3 h2 and sticking a
bishop on e4 dislodging the rook from h1
fabi was forced uh to move the rook up
to g2 but fiona this is not a
sustainable defensive construction and
the final stage look at this beautiful
move that's coming up after h3 fabiano
going a3 and what did richard play here
how do we make uh the pawns go through
rook d8
what a move then the rook from d2
amazing move if rook takes c2 there's g
takes h3 and t takes h2 and the pawn is
simply unstoppable fabiano was forced to
move the rook back and there's another
detail which is that if knight takes h3
uh richard has several winning moves so
the simplest is just to take and then to
take and to promote to a queen fabiano
had to move his rock back and the final
move of the game is bishop f3 clinical
stuff threatening checkmate and the
point is that if fabi intercepts that
with 92 then the pawn is going to take
on h2 and promote not easy to beat
fabiano like that he made it look easy
but of course the blunder helped still
it was an exquisite effort by richard
absolutely richard mentioned in the
interview he got a little bit lucky but
from there on out he played with
clinical precision a beautiful game this
was your rapid recap
your rapid recap of the day
and danya i mean it is nine o'clock here
we've been live
for over seven hours and what a day it
has been here the results of this round
10.
wow i can't believe it started at 8 in
the morning my time it's three
and the results indeed three draws they
were pretty peaceful the four decisive
games were all incredible in their own
way andre winning gridelius i mean and
niels and pragnanda i think they're the
real heroes of today in terms of their
resilience their ability to withstand
phenomenal resistance by their opponents
daniel dubois and uh vidid respectively
and what do you say this is why we watch
this is why we watch uh just indeed and
um i am still laughing i couldn't i'm so
tired i couldn't tell if i had said
rapid recap or if i had said recap recap
it's that time of day
i said rapid rapidly
i literally couldn't that's why i
started laughing anyway the standings at
the top they haven't changed so much
magnus carlsen maintains
the so lead on seven out of ten anish uh
gear is still the closest pursuant on
six and a half and behind uh well now
richard report with his win he's
suddenly lurking there just uh one point
behind magnus
alongside marmodyarov
and so very likely i would say dania
that the tournament
victory will decided decided between
these four players absolutely and let's
have a look at the pairings uh not for
tomorrow but for the day after for the
next round round 11. uh the important
match up so we have carlson vidit and
[ __ ]
it's reward for losing to prague with
white yeah how about magnus of black how
was that uh prague himself is going to
be playing carowanna he's going to be
looking to extend that winning streak
rhondella says panko dude shankland and
anish geary against van forest a game
that i think anish is going to try to
play for a win because of the rounds of
the tournament nearing its conclusion
he's going to try to close that half
point gap between him and magnus carlson
and the round fiona is not tomorrow it's
not tomorrow i think coverage never has
the rest day been scheduled better than
the one from tomorrow i think i
definitely need it the players need it i
think we all need it after today
but we'll be back two days from now on
january the 28th at the same time 2 p.m
central european time 5 a.m pacific
dania
it's been emotional today
it has been very emotional but it's also
been a lovely experience so thank you
fiona this was so much fun
and uh we know that it was an emotional
and hopefully a fun experience for
everyone in the chat as well so thank
you to everyone on twitch and on youtube
for watching and cheering on your
favorite players
thank you so much dania it's been a
pleasure indeed big shout out to the
chat to our producers everyone watching
and enjoy the rest day tomorrow we'll
see you two days from now have a good
one bye
the first time i came here in was 2017
where i played the c group and then 2019
i played the very good and now this is
my third time here yeah it's a great
opportunity for me because you know i
can i can learn a lot from these games
and i'm really looking forward to this
you know to have fun and
interesting games
i started to work with engine like
pretty late after i became an
i am and mostly seriously after i became
a geo
i sometimes think over the board and try
to you know find human ideas
and also use computer as well
i use technology and as well as you know
use books and
and seen a chess book i don't think
computers are just like um for now
definitely
and maybe later like they could solve
but for now i think uh
just won't be solved
i'm looking forward to play against
magnus in a classical game and also
other players like
karwana and
all the others as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you